I just don't care. John Snell.
You heard it? Jared, so he'll probably know this one.
Jared is probably Christmas present.
The dude, the dude,
I don't know you mention the dude yet, but he's a big fan I'm
actually riding on that right now. He said,
oh yeah, he said, but we can both appreciate it very respectfully.
He posted it to the job, but don't post it around.
and Thunder, Target Welding Special Code,
and that we can use on these jobs.
So we can say, OK, standby time or whatever you want to call it
like this. And so, again, we can say, yeah, we can do that. Yeah,
so that's why I'm not even in the front now. I hopped into the
gym. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, just to show that we got a very funny,
you all together. Okay, I got a lot of Jira Medi and fast.
That's what we need. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
So, in that way, with respect for all of our time,
growing, layout, and all of our other stuff to be in,
we can still just get in the absence of our other stuff. 775,
put it in and decorate it. Then make a little channings.
I'm going to yeah,
yeah. Umm, if there's any files, I can give you some for a time,
if I can give you, uhh, a lot of fishiness,
cloves, but I'm going to help. Alright, we'll see you Umm,
you
Uhh, uhh, .
. .
. and that's what we think of the human system for time,
for the time to go and that's how it's going to be like on
a shaped pocket. Here's what you get,
huh? Yeah, so that's what was going to get in the minutes.
Alright, I'm going to take you a second.
Uh, there you go. . .
the air is only three or 10. This one's a pilot.
Here's our mission.
Shouldn't shoot. First,
it's the pilot. Okay.
Okay. Okay. All right.
Thank you for your service. Bye. and then, like,
I'll ask her to make sure it's difficult to get back into the material
I'm going to say. I'm hot. Here we go. If like this video,
Don't forget to subscribe for more It's like, a lot of it, yeah.
We should be honest with you. I don't know.
I don't know. I don't know. I I don't know.
I mean, I don't know. There's just many people who've cycled up,
but he doesn't know It's like, you know, it's happen. It's gonna happen.
It's gonna happen. It's gonna be there. It's gonna be there in .
I-I-I-I One.
That's
smart, and now I'm going to take the Gira Mikes.
But also, boy, how are you? How you? I'm fascinated.
I'm sorry, boy, I'm here to spell the message so much wrong.
Uh, this is Gira Mikes. I mean, ehm, I'm going to you a chat.
I'm going show you how to have a speech. I got it. I mean,
I should, I got a little Z in Q. Well,
that brain varies. Sorry, nah, like, it's like,
new Geometric. I'm sure. I'm sure. Board of Chairman's.
I guess that's how the pump is. That's it.
I would give you a search statement. Oh, there you go.
Yeah, give me a- Yeah, I was hard. Any purposes?
I didn't put it on the side, but my team does all over the
same. I just make sure that the new pro-career again.
you Has a very good music, up to about propulsion.
I got it I think thats good because it has many years of it,
so. So, that is not it without it.
Yeah, yeah, I got some good context in the valley.
How are you? Uh, um, as soon as I see it.
Well, I've sent a Bitbucket, let's get it a lot. Ready.
Yeah. It's 31 days. So, seven thousand dollars.
I'll see you Bye guys. That's definitely Bitbucket's portion of it,
absolutely. See, uh, the things we've given,
spiders and unsterled, and bright stuff. Uh, uh, uh,
ehm. That's all. I'm so sure it's the same thing I thought of.
I don't see anything. I've got all this research on the body.
I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm sure you show See you the face.
He's really, really excited to have him. Don't have him,
they say. So, you're not even going to be able to see that.
He's not going to shock. He's, yeah,
most. Almost. Kind of the stuff is in drag, but that's what we have,
our, our ranking. See,
we look for the ethics there, it's not good.
Guys, mostly, you know, and we- They want to have prices done then,
we'll be able to do it in time, and then we'll do that slowly.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, here I go.
Yeah, I think the good, the only way to set it is that you
don't have anybody's, there's a certain way to high distribution,
or all of you have to go, you have to go, go, you know,
it's even, butinent it allows us to become,
OK, I'll see you then. and uh, Empy Mine will be caught.
One of the uh, can you tell I need my childhood? Not to,
I don't know if I'm very little to study, but that's when I said
I need my school to see Taylor right now. They have three or two
miles in their bus, and that's the end of the tunnel. So that's the
end of the tunnel. We have two disabilities here,
and we have a security hub. M***********.
You need to do 93 tons a day.
Yeah, it's like 81-0 day.
Isn't that neat in every single one? I think we could try.
But, uh, we thought it was gonna be like a child in Stockholm.
Yeah, so. Okay. I had a lack of the dog. He got some context
like that. We had freedom, melody with the, um, play,
uh, sound like those. Those, they're trucking. Thank you.
All we can are out of the middle. It's interesting that tuning to the
working 80 and 26 cents a time profit award versus standardization.
. . . . . ah, so I tried to find Justin,
so I use mountains, I know,
it's not on the server.
Now that I've got left, it's,
it's out of my head. It's, it's so jimmy.
You that. See if you work with, okay, we have to run.
Have a s I've got a lot of this.
I got it. It's worth it. I can't accept this.
We've always been around and talk to the Bushlow Church, Baldwin,
but if I just give you a chance to do it, I'll be sure
I'll be sure to do it. I'm not, I'm not But can't accept it.
I'll it. It's just the go and do table,
throw it in the top. They're doing a template, but I just want to
steal. They really don't want to make sure right now that you've seen how
you're doing, so I'll be sure to make sure honest. Thank Thank you,
ladies, and gentlemen. I appreciate it.
Thank you. Thank you. We'll in the next and instead of beginning
to hear about Trello so far, I'm not doubting that I have to listen
to us, uh, when the ladies don't leave my response or it leaves me
so- Here's a, And there's an app that you should have,
so you should have, uh, if you sit there and come in and talk
to them about it with them. Okay, it's close, it's okay,
it's okay, it's okay, it's Do I mean, say aye, look. I'm gonna You're
not in pain. You're gonna struggle with tech.
Otherwise, all our details are bad. It's made for them.
And we sit on the of us and stay happy with it.
I'm gonna have to say, okay, that's good.
That's good. We might add new stuff.
Nothing. Come on, we should pick a song for you.
We are just, I'm gonna start it, but I've been.
It's definitely gonna keep us going.
We can't be crossing it with Bitbucket.
and a chance at that. I was right little.
I would say to come up and reach and we're not getting any of
these. Yeah. I don't mind now obviously because I've always able to have that
lookin' out as a decision. I'll in the video. Yeah, it's fine. So, you
guys know later about stock pace.
I'm just going to buy some of the sunny nights.
Bye bye. Thank you very much. I'm here to see how St.
Gilston figured that. Okay, that's not really the deal.
You only see the results. Do you have any comments?
So I should have a plan. Yeah, that was it.
I haven't launched it yet. That's the deal. Give us a better question. I
don't know where to go.
And that's, again, to all the people that,
uh, got anything, wanted to find it, and to give it to the team.
So, uh, uh, I'll start with you in the next one.
I remember you all started doing this kind of thing.
I'm a new 20 cents on the beginning. So, uh, I'm interested. We'll be
back for a second. Last year, next week. Let's if we can see how
we can see how we get started.
selected from accident,
so borrows.
Yeah, the default, the 10-game,
it has to hit. So it works.
I'm hitting the 1.5, so I'll save you.
We are. I said it was a good program, it's interesting if you ask
it, even if it doesn't have the one day to stall the challenge.
Yeah, he's down on the middle of the night, but yeah,
he does. Bye Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need you to take this over,
guys. I just popped in. By the way, I thought you were gonna be
destroyed. I'm gonna be recording recording for you. Be in service. Get inside,
it's changing, so we're all curious to hear what that's gonna be.
Change the lighting, but light it. Yeah.
Yeah. and all my lips, it's a good word.
Ah, neither. Alright,
okay. Okay, it's a time for you guys. That's it,
really. I think you should be proper and look in the check.
You guys are safe but please be got it.
You don't. Still got to be hard and- That's right,
that's right. And then it's time to become that gap and come that gap.
It's about good, you know, time to use it. I appreciate you playing with
it. Take care guys. Please see you then. Good luck.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. You made it?
You made the way. Alright, good. Thank you. Okay.
I
feel bad Muffles with you and like,
Umm, I think you got to do
it again. Umm, you got to, yeah, I don't know if you're using homes.
Okay. Yeah, one brand new security character,
so that's the other guy, too. That's the other guy,
That's the other guy. . Oh,
that's the guy. Yes. Yeah,
they're really fun. Thank you, sir. Thank you. Bye.
Bye. Bye. Bye!
Okay, I'm cool.
Alright, give them a cheap bow. Umm, yeah, and they're so good. You have
to have it. Steve, buddy. I think these guys are com- They did a
new guy, right? And then they're aligning systems.
So I think when all these are positions, I think they've got,
Bunch of the system, they're throwing work straight out of soda,
and I'm not even stressed. Today's baby housing,
so they- And guys next time. They've been doing that for like a period,
and we hope that we must be about decisions like this,
you know? So there is a maintenance station.
There is a pocket like we're going to have a Bye-bye. And then it's
just like, oh, you need procurement?
Okay. Okay.
And I hope to speak to you if you haven't said it.
This one. You need to find an establishment.
established. So yeah,
people will be hired to find stuff in the G.O.
and the student administration, but they're not. You sure,
but it's just some people eating those bad stuff.
I mean, I'm a man,
I'd love a student purchasing person in there.
. . I was around the morning now.
Here's the right amount of controls, not too much, not too little.
And I will like to get a block in the system.
What we were trying to do is, uhm, cool all
the water. you Purchasing for all the different,
uh, shops together so that we could,
uhm, uhm, uh.
The demand and unfortunately, you know, purchasing power is,
we need to find power in the community.
Yeah, I wish we were kind of here with our consumables. Now, before we
start the list, the work you have in a deal with, uh,
we were talking about air and gas. That's just looking over there.
You know, right there. I mean, we, they gave us
the bananas system, so we basically put the long,
long child's eye on this. with us. I
got all over it, you'd buy her. I was sent them a master of
agreements, and,
and it stopped me,
like that. And, uh,
things slowly go down. See,
I think that I'm gonna deal in this book. You have a whole new
example of them, so they didn't want to.
Let's go.
It's time.
It's time. It's time.
It's time. Must be. You It's Loom,
MediRoute. Check our open up is four o'clock.
Turn in the notification button. If you,
I'm good. I'm What is this?
There is nothing. Thank you. Alright,
you what I'm gonna I have a lesson about
the anomaly. Can we show him?
you. Thank you,
Jeff. I'm selecting us. We're doing this today.
It's, uh, the, rounders, yes.
I mean, is there any part of the vlog? Bye And we're seeing an
edge of this. We're at this thing. We're changing through something.
We, uhm, no, there's not any vlog we're shooting at.
Here we go. We'll see you in the other things where it is.
I mean, you can walk the estimates up so we don't change.
We don't revolve on that. Terros, we can do it.
. Can you dump the old settings?
Yeah. So we have the old settings.
. Yup. Yup. You can set up a different shop,
you know, and ere well. Well done.
Well, some things are differentially upshot,
like the television stuff, differentially upshot.
you about shot, we built a new shot,
and we built a hole in the video, and started placing the video.
But it's so structural, it's ready to slide down.
Go! I'm gonna
do that,
I'm gonna do that, while my body's not gonna fit into the tube, that
won't. . That will not stay the same,
you can wonder if you're supposed to have the other ones that are staying
across the shot. But yes, you could.
. .
. I think, uh, I mean, I'm glad they only got him to do
it, right? So, he's the master of that,
uh, thank you. Please. That's it. Please. You know,
we start changing the lot. They say, uh,
boom. We start changing the area. It's a brainwave. That,
ah, um, I W and still,
you know, you can do it. You can do that in a minute.
You'll find nothing last week or something,
but you know how to do it. from Taiwan. And then,
you'll find something last week or
something. me.
That ever changed, and when I said those,
I kept saying, how did I just, you know, be able to do that.
I just, yeah, I don't know. Can you do that?
So, uhm, but the language was the main testament in,
uhm, uhm, uhm, I was confused. The only thing that was in the beginning
is so much- . . . I just didn't know what the question was,
why didn't you find something, to be,
I didn't fit in the ground the size of it. Yeah,
I was just. Just be. We earned this at the end of the,
at the end of the week increases,
at the end of the week increases, at the of the week,
we earned it all. Stay safe. . . . we will work a Bound
with Fontana is going on, tx set up c5ble. So should be a .
. .
and then the changes are going to be,
um, it's way faster than me.
Adjusting the speed and then also a Putting the parameters,
kind of, amongst all parameters in the plate.
I was told to support that. That's about it.
That should have been going to be the third thing.
It is One day, we did it for ourselves.
That's a nice, uhm, changes that you would pick up.
You're using that. Oh, but it's, uhm,
60% of the time from using it.
While Atlassian seems to want stuff for a look at it,
shouldn't it? Have you given a different vision of the format that I had?
So, uhm, and if I didn't even say,
well, I think they should go up here. I'd like to- And they know
that, also, these are my favorite. It's cool.
It's not here. It's not tuned enough.
They know that they're- I'm not even asking.
You can see what you've got for this right now. So,
typically, we're getting you needed to advance so you can use it all the
time. You know what I mean? Uh. Now,
you know what I mean? But it wouldn't be nice.
Thank you. That's
some, uh, I'll take it.
The electric tool portion of it again is going to meet in the accuracy.
Since June, it's not a good swine. Probably it's something to take care of
it. Uh, but, I that,
uh, uh, we have a lot of implementation.
Um,
this, You think is a problem for this,
uhm, if you want to be on-site at the beginning.
I'm excited to, the-the balance of this area,
uhm, however, with part B in that
section. in the show. The coding is shipping your city,
uhm, fully adopted girl,
uhm, leak, uhm, we could call All for
us, or, uhm, the Agile,
kit them in here, and then also,
uhm, kind of a report. Let's get started.
So we don't, you can, uhm,
so I don't can watch this back after, because that is the coding coordinator.
We'll see you in a minute. As well, uhm,
so I'm missing. He'll be facilitating some of the coding staff that bring Chris
Peña in the mirrors so that we can kind of.
We'll open the process of the code, what he's gonna do when he's seeing
when they're out there, the shit is, and then the coding staff's there to
kind of, at least. He's troubling his task,
and that's really all I can do. He knows that I've been,
you know, it's a fully functioning system at this point.
No. No. The implementation side of it's just us getting equipment in the
guy's hands and saying, this is the law.
Follow it. Yeah, bye. What is going on?
What is going going on?
What is going on? It's part of it. It's not going to be the
stage. It's going to main thing. It's not going to release into the shot.
So, here goes your thing from receiving volume.
You can do it in depth. Yeah.
So, it's just a module of power.
Yeah. I look at it like a simple vibration.
I look at it like the input. Yeah. With you know,
if that's where you're digging this further, drag the shot and use the input
for exactly.
This time, since we've been, I was trying to,
I was trying, don't even get up,
get in fast order, come on. So,
I'm a bit, like, a little bit of snack essential when I'm here.
Can you send me a little bit of this? Can you meet your partner
when you get the chat, please? Yeah, I need the real,
What happens later? I need to get a lock installed first so you can
be brought. Yeah, so I need to start getting actually,
them. Yeah, do you want to reach up to Ann?
You know, you guys have the people that are going to use it.
Yes, we want to do the go training time.
All right. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. All right.
All right. Bye.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
Yeah. Yeah. Possible day at a time of difficult
days. I'm Dennis, Jennifer Kerry, and umm,
and horse back, read sit down and eat.
Go over the, umm, you have to go to each tablet.
I got 17 packages, so I should go there.
I'm not aiming to do the issue.
Alright, I have a big charging station off of this.
Okay. Yeah, we can sign everybody.
Bye bye. But, I'll,
I'll share that. I don't want to be able to log in. It's not
fast. I don't care about it. Yeah,
I'm not gonna use regular. Thank you. I know from weeks where I've been
looking, ouuh, and a smosh you start to w Cut the,
his ears go so fast. Yeah, straighten it up. Okay. There are
a skin stop here, you can't put a cheap phone before us.
I usually don't do much. Okay. We're too committed.
I'm not trying to handle it right now. This is about a month and
a half. Oh. Last time.
Thank you. and the other side.
It's actually, it's a 24-hour
turn. Oh Stocks, yeah,
and then you go all the long guys to war and he's got like
a frickin' brand and a complete frickin' snack No.
Hacks in there. So,
I would only do pretty good and then shop as a community.
You're welcome. Yeah.
Touch my step, you're gonna get my ability to order the step,
take it away from you. So.
It's so amazing.
It's so amazing, guys. You can hear us, but you can put a- It's
okay. No invoices. Because I've got a lot of them.
It's something that you can question.
We'll see you in just a little.
You think that's, so it's important.
You know, right? Later. Yeah. Nice.
Thanks so much for listening.
I think it's back with a nice little. You really stood in the data
to help me work. I've been working a lot back to you and uhm,
uhm, replace two types of stuff. I've been working lot back to you and
I've been working a lot back to you.
I've lot back to you. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
. .
1,000 apps is going to be squeezed.
Um, we have to run the work that I will do,
which will be going to be squeezed so the details vary today.
So I'm going to say, that's- It looks States state of Iowa,
you mean? Do we have a light force? Oh, no, not the loads that
you- You don't even if the local or shop would be a statute.
Now, we're gonna give K a credit to coupons they gave us for a
field job. . . . People are always speaking of paper as such and
paint and they ask to get a video and they gave it to us
for free disks. Yeah,
we have something that we were painting for that so we kind of, I
would- We took pictures of seeing all the caveats through it and
I hope it's something that we can look at and, you know,
let's come in here to- Oh, I think Jeff's gonna take- Thank you.
That'd be- that'd be awesome. I think it's fun,
it's not better. Take a once and get out of here.
Everything that's not the pressure in this is. Oh,
really? That's in the chin. Okay. You're not trying.
That's- that's very good. Doing it. And that's really- Okay.
They're just pissing all their customers off.
That's what most of us are leaving. Later.
First lesson is,
you know, satisfy your customers. Thank you for your participation.
I don't know,
Oh I don't forget it. Yeah,
that was construction, wasn't it?
It's, uh, ending and shooting. Okay. Interesting.
I just haven't found the best way to search it.
What is it? I'd like to search it. How does it look longer?
It's gonna be hard. I'm going to talk about research. I'm already not going
to search the hard drive. Uh, and I would be.
I have some of the links in the video that are developing.
. . . .
. . . . . . . . For you, it's actually Microsoft.
Start the search, that way. You
know what I'm talking about, where this isn't the first thing about that.
It's a new way that it's about that. Thank for listening. I'll go out
and move it first. Thank you for joining us.
Let's just Okay.
First, first. I thought we brought them to each other at the top of
the time, so I had a lot of fun. What was that?
Good. Good. Uh, uh, the key sequence?
And then, uh, gonna be able to do a little speed.
Yeah. . . . So you can do one for the columns.
.
Thank I'm
so lonely. Ahhh.
I don't know if I'm here.
I'm not computer if you want to learn from this other students.
go to Clearcabs
with a couple of our reports from the past,
they can show. So, go. What's this,
uh, I hear you guys using the term,
like. Ah,
not with a word something, HoloLens, HoloLens.
Yes, and this is our HoloLens. So essentially. the day.
I'm let's go get actually. Alright. You know what, I'm not going to do
the fast station, and then we can overlay the model over our built
assemblies. of these. See if anything's off,
MediRoute, Loom, where it needs to be.
And, uh, is that a visual check or?
part of the just like the program of the service work to a comparison.
This is a visual check and we use the HoloLens,
it's within 16th of an inch. Thank you very But you have to pick
it up, or it picks it up and it won't you?
It picks it up. So, so I can help you keep.
You know, addition markers, we put these magnets that we'll pull in at the
reference point, and then we pull the correct,
um, model course. as as possible. I'm not supporting this,
and we'll go over and make sure it's scaled.
And then it takes about five minutes to do a very intricate beam.
And it's- It's just one of our quality checks that we are now encompassing
for the last year. We headed it last year to have,
The answer is a little bit. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So did you lay out on it? We have not gotten that far
yet. We do have some restriction.
Thank you. I would say with a, you know, open shop to sometimes one
of these, part of life would be if the sun is in your way,
you know. Good luck. Good luck. Good luck.
We, we used this performing card for QC guys just to do a,
uh, a QA. No. you on our side for our week.
That's part of our process in the show. Now since I'm people using it
in videos, that's layout tool. Yes.
A lot of the holidays were just continuing.
Yeah, Microsoft discontinued. Umm, there you go.
It's going to be 20 states, but they're not going to manufacture those,
but they are trying to incorporate either Meda or another,
uhh. I'm going to buy it.
Like, I don't know how it was going to be coming out of their
own person. Yeah. So, we're working with Fast Nation on,
in that regard, so. to the way in the United States of the Lush
and Bitbucket. So third party people has to do this as well.
Is it common to use it? Yes.
I don't know, people that do like not to belay them.
Alright. Not,
not for belay. That's, that's not common.
Uh, that's it. Like, I don't know that I'm ever sitting good.
Good. For layup purchases,
just, you see virtually the world, I see it.
Eventually they didn't want to come in on this glass.
Easy. Please. I think,
I think, I think, I I think, think, much here, and have, uh,
4.5-0 go-to-1, a lot of some spicy and wilder food.
We are waiting for one is trigger on the web, right? Yeah.
So, yeah, I think, I think,
all of it was, almost.
. Yeah.
It's pretty wild. Yeah. That one was, uh,
really, really trusting us to put that out of here.
You really enjoy eating the shop.
Yeah. But,
uh, process has gotten pretty good and we've,
uh, Bye. We've gotten some complaint where,
we're getting the IFCs with me from all of our internal,
internal detail. in order to see. So, uh, definitely is,
uh, nice to have.
Umm, customer requested Trello So, uh,
I will be this in the last half.
Yeah, I know how I did that.
Like, I thought the same way. So. Um,
and the sale upon us each other. This is what the APM looks like
when you pull it up in your tablet. It's gonna be your signing screen.
Uh, you'll end up coming in here,
signing with your ID.
Uh. It's gonna ask you to do a pass,
he, maybe, you know,
send me to skip this one more. So,
this is what the mainstream is gonna look like with us.
us. And using the format that we're using at this point,
and the parts of everything you need will be in order to package this
portion. Bye bye. Umm,
we are seeing to make sure the proteins is on the same page with
their code, it's only projects. Thanks. Uh,
creating the work package for what they've outlined to the floor.
Um, I don't see any reason why they wouldn't use the exact same- See
ya. You can cross this floor that, that word to me.
Umm, I've lost it up at the start of the year,
and I'm trying to build scenes to do the bit.
Good. It's illegal, it's illegal.
Alright, span has not been there yet.
second.
You
know. your own. So, uhm,
you're going to the work that is just.
You need to get this, it's like, uhm,
so that's the, uhm, that's it. So right now,
you'll have your work package. We're gonna change the subject.
. . and worlds sometimes . . you'll see further project ,
ah ok, and work properly .
. you know, ehm um,
but that's the more we can really get down to the nitty gritty of
. . . ok, this is what needs to be a humping course .
. . that's the whole middle this is . . this is the follow
and we can schedule those kind of things out .
. assign priority based upon what should be addressed with
that and said when you go into this work that you can access all
of and the assemblies that are associated with it,
you can get your drawings, this information isn't going to be practical for you
guys. But, uhm,
piece tracking is what's going to be relevant for you guys,
because you're going to be using the piece- Peace.
Um, we didn't set up any inspections
that are- I was trying to do the project.
Um, so, you wouldn't be able to see the inspection
and the current can't set up the- Let's back to the screen. You'd have
to go back to the home screen and go to, uhh, probably my inspections
and do the- I'm sorry,
in that module, uhh, in the future of beta.
I'm guessing, potentially, it will be . We have any codes and inspections on
a project basis. So, in that instance,
you would be able to access them.
and and to the specific chat box,
um, production status.
This is where, if you guys haven't put these only projects,
it's simple. You know, it's gonna have prep and trying,
but this complex is gonna have prep, trying,
you know, MediRoute Thank so much for attention. Umm,
and then we can expand on that further as you guys have been going
on for our complex system, uh,
cracking the, uh, the- in-betweens,
uh, I don't know what the extent,
uh, we had, you know, too early for the calling set of things.
And in the next Did you have a financial system,
or what, uh, when, uh, I keep you over here quickly to career out
at an additional stations, and it's- I just can get you guys the ability
to keep track of each section of what you're going for.
Um, anything else? Okay, we'll see.
See can do. Also, the ability to create the list and,
you know, shipping inside of this. So,
word types and packages. you can be super helpful with core.
Keep it among them in one place with all the data where it needs
to be, and flow visibility. Let's go. So your job number,
your area of work start date, due dates,
and where it is. So,
um. I love you. This project doesn't have the piece
tracking associated with it, but I will go in here just to kind of
show you. you what this looks like for this project,
this one's gonna be catered if that actually doesn't have,
uhh, so I'm actually gone.
Bye! So, I forgot I adjusted some of our way to the certification models
to have that in there. So,
this is gonna be the screen that, One of your painters is gonna have
up, and, or many of your prep guys is gonna have up,
and when he grabs a,
He has to work 15-some ways that he's taken over into the blast area.
You know, this freedom of this tablet, you're going to this app.
You have that sports engine typically here.
And when he's got everything ready to go,
he's going to come in here and hit start.
Then he can go start blasting all this stuff.
And once he has all of those,
it's definitely done. All Then he can come in here,
hit stop, and then go to update,
and then first. Where is she?
It's going to be here.
That should be if all of those pieces,
A little bit, yes. So,
um, hit the start and beginning of it.
Update next quantity. Now,
that's the, I'm gonna be really brainy. I'm just gonna ensure that you guys
have the total count of what you're bawling for.
Instead of doing the max quantity, uhm,
and then you go in. There, you know the line by the line,
okay, I've got two of these, four of these, four of these,
four of these, and one of these, and then,
uhm, from there. I you click update,
and then this will get you a nice move.
. If we know the production sass into the form and
see income here to find it.
It does sound excellent.
So we're on the- on the variety of- didn't that turn off your payments?
I'm going do that's going to have a a little bit of a- a
little of a a little bit of a I'm sorry I didn't have to.
Yep. All right.
So,
now I don't see all of those,
I don't think I'll be just confused. Thank So, uhm,
from that, then it would go
into its next area. Yeah Um,
so you could go back in your production tracking,
and, just hit it right.
. .
And then you go to time, go in the ad batch, and you involve
Atlassian process. It's our,
umm, the biggest thing that we're gonna wanna confirm is
When we want that start button to be hit,
is it when an operator comes over with a stack of
their Everything looks pulled out in the glass, and it's still on the pallet.
Before you guys put it up on some horses,
or if it's once it's on the stop.
The horses staged out, everything's ready to go,
paint comes ready to go, front is ready to go.
Then you hit start, and then you start. And then once you're done painting,
then hit stop. Um,
so that's one discussion that we'll have to have in months.
All right. Well, um, if he's trying to capture,
um, the full scale of this process.
See you in the next each of these categories,
off he's trying to capture the nitty gritty.
This is what it takes to blast. Hanley's going to be in between.
And then this is what it's going to take to paint everything else in
between me. So, umm,
so am I. Cheers. Trust me for you.
I know some of them are to do different activities when they're setting up
a machine for this job. Welcome.
I let you know. So,
that's one thing we want to make sure with the mode,
that's something that he wants included.
You can miss the portion, uhm, cause I think that would be relevant,
especially in the time. Yeah,
and they help us survive. They're calm, they're mixing their pain.
You know, again, and then the second part would be,
you know, those are, are spreading in his box.
Yeah, he's mixing his pain,
he's folding his line, he's checking it for him.
So they both like, they're,
they both would have a difference. We'll you in the tablet, they can go,
what's that? So I mean,
one guy, umm, the way that our estimates currently set up.
I'll see you that our factor is back with two guys assisting
in every portion of the work that you guys operate.
So, umm. With this tracking,
umm, the assumptions going to be that there is,
there's going to be quite a bit of promise. So.
So. You will be able to do that in the next version of the
center. If we're going to set you down with us.
Next, I'll go. Go on. Go on. Go on.
Go on. Go on.
Okay.
He could cross this category,
the piece of another one, cross this category with piece of 90 cat for
both of their times. Yep. Thank you. Um,
so, yeah, what do we need to cross this if we're done?
So, um, but this is the hierarchical- over the entirety of what's included in
the work package, or the sequence comes by.
You can do individual tracking. And a second.
Okay. In my mind,
I always contract with hours as such,
um, for peace and my love.
So, um. Bye. You can switch to part-timers and each
one of them has its own. They have a very complex assembly,
and they're all- of those relatively similar complex assemblies,
e.k. in time studies, on individual items,
like W and W with those- Good columns,
and say, well, that's a start of the project. We were doing one column
in 30 minutes by the end of the project. We're gonna have one column
in 10 minutes. Here in an hour,
so the next time you get it, you can shoot it right in the
middle and have, have the middle ground,
you know, taking the company sooner. So,
uhm, so that's,
that's why the main thing is, Uhh,
so, work that because it is super helpful having the,
the transparency, uhm, uhm,
uhm, uhm, The transparency, uhm, I forget to shoot on the screen.
I do, okay.
Alright. Okay, uhm, the transparency, I'm assuming this
function,
the work package isn't set. So, I'm that up,
and you guys are trying to, uhm,
you're, you're at this screen, you don't have to work that,
you just set up. Oh, she got the project you already received with us.
You can go into the project's position and then tilt
it for your project. Umm, we'll do 6.1,
4.5, then you can open the project and you'll see that.
and have a whole lot of All of this information is very similar to
what's in the uhh, uhh,
in the work package.
But. Bye. This is on a plastic scale.
So with this being said,
uhm, if it's a really big project, then you're gonna have to go- Mhm.
So, uhm, into your filters, up in the top here,
filter for the sequence and line that you guys have on the floor.
tomorrow. See you. Trinotope, and then you can go through this same exact process
here. That's just why work back.
It's a little easier for the benefits. Thank you. We did developing
the friends so that you You can actually,
and many of us. So,
check it out. What? Okay. Okay.
Good answer. Let's see. Okay.
So, that's the biggest thing is,
Um, with this,
we've got a bunch of devices that we're gonna be assigned to your guys,
and this is- This is what we have set up in the system that
well wants to use going forward, that everyone on this property
is going to be- So, anything that touches the fabrication shop,
encodings, me and on. Bye I've got a picture set up in
the way that, you guys are going to see at least about coding set,
anything that's coding only. you think that would be,
uh, the session managed by Alan and,
uh, depending on the name of the mode,
what's on the- and uhm, that you guys will have this available
to you so that we can get percentage completion uh.
I'm worried guys that they have any process. Uh huh.
So, then, if,
if something's in here and you've got multiple jobs in there.
. And if ever guys entering these in within two
minutes of them getting completed, you can be at your best.
Yes. You know, hey, I just got a phone call and I'll be adding
a site for 15% complete. I'm dropping the prime.
And, uh, perhaps 100%. I'm. Complete prime of spittings,
I'm completing now. Cause as soon as these guys mark this off,
it's recently updated on, uhm. Um a fraction in your computer
version, and you can run from side to side immediately.
So, that'll save you if you haven't known. on,
we'll see you Bye. Top of the golf cart, run out there and physically
check exactly what's going on.
This should give you a good how to review, uhm. Remove.
Umm, those are all these videos that are holding your guys to,
once this is done, it's not a, at the end of the day,
I'm gonna go get all these updated. Go. Get it done,
you have a channel right there, you're ready to go.
I can get it in the ones that say I'll just wait for them
to get them away and they submit it for a running. Don't forget. You
know, it's never a right to be with them.
So, this is not going to be a lie. But,
uhm, p-p-p-p-p-p-p, Let's talk about it. Thank you.
and I can find it.
Other parts. Just swap it out and you know.
And thing. And longer they have it, the longer I can. You Yeah.
And that'll get down there because it's our first goin' out a little bit.
So, it's still unforeseen. seeing you next year.
I know the blackboard company here, everything is covered by whatever.
It's gonna be thundernose when it's on and out.
Bye. A couple more with the screen and there's a thin out of the
case. Just gonna be recycling,
you know, these are not cases, so they're gonna be six months. I'll see
you in a while. Okay,
so touch screen,
it's an iPad, you know, so,
uhh. So, I hate abilities,
and I'm pretty sure the one who was bad.
That's not what you're doing.
You know, so. Hey, what's up?
What are you guys doing? Yeah. So,
you'll give me a complete ephemera that's something we got Okay,
flip it and wish some screws, not uh, or whatever.
Let me know, use the screen and have a little keyboard more things and
the trunk keyboards are nice. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. You have our procedures, the stylists and some PR PT games,
uses stylists. So,
let's look at the main function of trying to get you ready to this,
because I'm sure they're probably gonna be having you push this to the guy.
You know, if you have any questions or anything along the
process of us pushing yourself,
and then you make, you can use our, uhm,
Set and Stone Roll. A this
is an area of user friendly interface.
So, once your guys can use through the,
this is right here from this, this is right here. I hope this is
really going to be very good at talking with us.
And you can be- should be- so I just- uh,
if you have all of the tablets,
so it's pretty much just going to be, um,
either Monday, next week. Thank you for fighting and you see we're gonna assign
devices to people and say, this is what you're gonna do or you can
vent tomorrow school. Don't believe so.
So, uh, so that will be,
He'll also be a pushing factor on us if we need
to a separate meeting just with me and- And .
. All of the encodings guys, once we get devices and get the sand,
we can go all over that and just do it once over and be
sure we'll sit on the seat of age. Um,
but pretty simple process,
and then kind of tailing back into why these work-packing kids are super helpful.
Oh, come um,
like in the year, especially in the north side,
I know they tend to have you on a QC.
See soon. Sometimes,
so from here, you can access all of your lines,
say the- or anything you guys are working on,
can come in here and just pull up this specific- on top of
what you mean and it'll have a lot of everything.
So, umm, if you guys do need the- I'll back.
I'll back. Alright, so, Anyway. Yeah,
this is a funny kind. Also double checker,
I mean, it would be right, singers, if you like these years,
they're a big PDF. Yeah. Right under there, hit the drawing list and go
back there. It'll, it'll sing right there to the very
land, this boy. And next time, 100 A and Y London Sword,
there will be lucky in the F right there. That would,
that would be the drawing. But I'll say.
I think there's more link, is that a display link that somebody has said
or how does that would be? Yeah, I'd like to be here if somebody
just, if you get it done, head to the caller and- Yeah,
yep. Sit on shoulder. So,
I'll make sure with all of our updates that all of our invertellers are
set up. 7 7 for the spill,
and that's, uhm, everything's very important for me,
because these, this one was clearly,
more and minuses the drives didn't work on the initial,
but he probably didn't get a request to file on him as a kiss,
uh, and they probably weren't coming in,
uhm, the city government is there,
and then, uh, uhm, the drives zeroes. Thank so much for your So yeah,
it looks like some of them said yeroms during the worst of the time,
yeroms, and, and it's similar to yeroms.
Yep, and so, yeah. So,
so I think I'll look at this one, and yeah, this would be where
you can do with reference to grinds, and you could pull out better.
Uhm, you don't have any inspection setup for,
for toting stuff in here, but probably an inspection Having did set up
for them all while he was in here,
uhm, is in this general inspection step.
In here, you can put that in here.
You finally, the test that we paid for service per inspection,
and this one, uhm,
we ended up doing one test. Yes. One,
uhm, essentially you're going here.
Shout location, you can select, use the inspector,
and you'll select. lecture. You
can select what type of system you're doing, uhm, you can type in your
profile, uhm. Bye. You know,
any specific notes, uhm,
if you're in the clicking and final, uh,
generally prompt you to tick. You can take a picture of a fail attached
to this impression before.
and . And submit this so that this is not right.
And would it be associated with the job number?
Can you go into my inspection report?
It's no different job. And pull a report that breaks down all
the inspections for projects, specific projects,
and you get that. You get it. It's not.
This would be, this would be where you would have since that.
So, you can always look up here. is I'm going to get back up
to the whole screen. Umm,
this is, uhh,
that was kind of the main function that I was trying to show.
Sure. I know you guys, umm, in the future,
potentially, they might have us add the guys in the top of the graphic.
Umm, I don't know how that's- I don't- I don't know if you guys
are struggling, but they're the ten workers who are welcome enough to meet their
dad and get to their time differently, uh,
all over shotgun. Okay. Um, that even tastes more like
eating po- probably a lot of time,
you guys know, time tracking here.
Umm, it doesn't, it doesn't Jira's easily done.
Done. So, if we can venture into that,
um, the time tracking module, we can go over it better.
So, here we go. The main functions will be projects,
um, and work packages,
and you can access any knowledge that you need for your work to give.
You go to do your peace tracking,
um, you check production statuses,
and I love you guys love it.
See you later. I'm going to show you later.
So this is also going to bite you back and why you didn't start
messing with me. It's a check that I've done with me. Yeah,
I'll- . I'll take a look at the scene and make sure you have
the power to have it all on your side. Yeah, you should be able
to see anything about it. Yeah, it's- Yeah,
really have. So,
basically, we don't have enough access to this technique to apply into the calibration.
Uh. Bye-bye. See how this,
this, you have access right when you go back to your desk.
Uh, you can also pull this up on your phone.
I don't You can tablet. As long as you have this domain,
then you can access, uh,
any of them. Hold So,
it will be really nice in a smooth part and way .
.
the organization that would be, uh, just a new product deal.
Uhm, in the first talk, it would speak any less.
We'll see you in a little
bit.
Right now, umm, the most prevalent
group in there is home chain,
just to do it. Thanks. There's so many home chain jobs,
yeah, and we've all worked home chain times together,
umm, loosely, we tend to do a lot of job,
and then we can do that. Yes. Yeah. on a custom basis.
So, you're getting set in the biophiles group, those group teams.
Yeah. So,
but yeah, because otherwise,
if they're for property, you didn't see all that stuff.
That's enough. I can tell you that,
that really not a part of it. It's not. It's just possible for setting
up to make sure the code is just see what code is.
So, employee by employee basis is just filtering. So, I guess what I'm saying
is, when I- I saw earlier on in that,
like, hundred and one, hundred and one twice,
you know. Who makes sure that it only shows up one.
So, it's just relevant to the coming work.
So, the PC,
the ones that can- controls as soon as time does.
And, essentially, with that being of Rev-A and one of them being Rev-0,
the- there's a Rev-A in there, they cannot access that.
They don't- you know, there's a Rev-A in the system that'll show growing long-wise.
See you guys. Bye. But, it will only let you access the most current
Rev-A. Uhm, the issue with that one,
I'd like to check and see if- Yeah. If our directors are late,
uhm, and make sure that,
because we have had connection issues between our database and meet them- I know
it depends on how you can call that to see Inspector all the time.
Anything's certainly going in here, what's going on,
uhm, pretending it is. next slide. Uh, exterior customer
giving us chis found in a different style of important than drawings that land.
Okay. Uh, like, a law practically, uh,
for a directory not being set up correctly, so you need death.
Yeah. I have this impression by attempting to do it with the soul of
the race of drawings anywhere, all in shops,
go to the top of the modes, so there, go see if you see
the drop. If we, we set up the global fault directories,
there was a map, your heart was generally not a thing on the server.
You used to basically stop the fault directories on the server.
So, if this wasn't for a larger hour on the server,
which really, like this, the C drive of a server,
then it's not on the C drive of a server. That might be something
we have to have. You I'm trying to speak
with you. It's a very long thing.
Later. I'm just to you.
Yeah, I wanted to work that. I was about to do one with the
good, the the good, the 1 of all the units.
She found it might be something else.
Yeah, this project, we ran all of it through.
And all of it was going to do good.
Yeah, that's probably just going on with that drive of,
you know, on the server, probably. So I- Yeah,
I'm here at the full time.
Um.
Bye.
We can get it instead of our use of computer maintenance slash
whatever it can be out of here. It's gonna suck.
Don't be it. I'll make no note of that so that I can use
that to give it your ass. And if that's not even changing,
receiving will use this as well. Oh, yes.
And then somebody sets their back into the,
uhm, step early, they're really cool to see.
Uhm, they their portion will have,
uhm, uhm, the packages.
Their portion will be, yes. Yes. Yes.
Yes. fulfill.'-'-'-'-'-'-' -'-'-'-'-'-' It's a man who's out,
but their portion will be material receiving as well as generating
no less entrusting the goods. So,
you guys will have the tablet out there. If a load comes in,
you can pull up the purchase order. See what items arrive with quantities.
You can mark and proceed as it comes in.
And then, fall back it is as- .
So, you'll have your available leading there
and say, why don't you just say- you know,
man, you have a key member in there that proceeds and is on his
call and then it's just interceded.
He can then- all of those PDFs to associate all of the C numbers
so that we can still do our activity for Trello.
Excuse me, please let him happen. Bye. Yeah, this,
and they're going in to speak to me, you know,
and so this is only a basic or terrible thing.
You know, it doesn't be this diverse. Yes. So it'll all make free
set. Yeah, every first start of the lead issue gives
the. And the list of what they're needed.
And they also get which we should be some more nervous now.
So,
we'll learn the shop page.
We track the same length through here. All right. Um,
I think they're working towards issuing type of videos from other people.
Um. Bye That portion we haven't really discussed.
Um, we don't really have anything broke up in inventory or anything in the
size database. Peace. Or paint,
some of them have done some kind of, uh, uhm,
the inventory at this point.
Talk about fillets. All right. All right. Try, basically,
look over here, you know, how many, down,
and look, look, look, look, look,
look, look, look, look.
Yeah, so we did our best to be able to able to get into
this. And then we break down the island,
we see in there, uhm, which is incredibly relevant for our steel purchases.
Then it goes into our inventory. Thanks for coming on this week's video. Thanks
for Try. Thank you coming on this week's video.
Uh, we keep, however,
with the paint portion, there's none and hold it.
There's no pieceface that I brought you out in here,
and it's, you know, we're gonna most definitely put it in there.
If we don't want to always be getting- you can buy it again on
the bales of this piece back, and you can go,
um, buy it again on the bale of the ice.
And then, um, front to see show me the billions, and then you can
go into a purchase order online.
You
would be limited to the point of, we used one,
one gallon of disfibing, and then I'm going to have to pour it in.
It comes out, there's no way to quantify that,
and it was a mere headache. It needs to come in garbage science,
not anything is bad at the end. Yeah. What about you guys doing this?
Umm, it's an easy video you said.
I'm taking shape or something like that. But,
what? You I've been hitting me in that during this very day.
Let's say I've had a lot of time down in the room,
so we've got a primer. I don't I don't think I've ever had it.
As I pull one out of storage, and bring it into the market,
I'm going to get this thing, so I don't know.
The storage must have one full one down, and perhaps start using it.
But, you know what you've got in storage, and of course,
it wasn't happening really loose. Thank very much.
Rather than having to track, I've shopped,
pointed to get a little bit, so I didn't, umm, to check where I
went. I will see here all the time. Here are my questions.
Yeah, let's do something we'll do and,
uhh. 7 That one would be,
umm,
uhh, quite simple process to do,
so, perfect. All right.
All right. Yeah, we've been talking a little bit about this.
So let's see if I can go in the piece.
It's gonna be it. Yeah. Uh, no, no.
no, no,
I have it in, um, if you got eight to the other twelve,
you just type in one of an e-game,
and you're buying them, it won't save twenty, it won't save twenty.
And then that total quantity will go to twelve,
or whatever your difference is. and we'll see you just
go back in here, and you can receive a whole item,
or you can receive a portion of a whole item.
So, I can, I can,
uh, show you what they're on.
you So,
all over and over and over again, please come back to me.
Thank Thank you very much. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
very much. Thank you very much.
It will probably be
my party in the next week or whatever,
so we'll sign up for everybody in the beginning of the week.
I'll go through the IT, get a list of guys that don't need it.
Again, again, that don't have a list of business signage,
and we'll get all of that set up and then try it in a
little bit of video. This is what,
and one on five, everyone's going to be entering,
receding, shaping, and instead of smacking my rhythm.
You welcome. Okay,
so I'm going to do that, but I'm not going to do that. You
guys you're up.
Uh, you guys shouldn't have to do any of that. Umm,
you're going to realize it's not interacting with your, your construct or everything.
So that's all, that's all a circuit instance.
Umm, I think you guys are really good at it.
So unless somebody, you know, may I specifically request that they want your time
to act into the untyped part of the universe's plan.
But, uh,
we do our contract in the ear for the shock side,
and, uh, we do do that all the time, so go, go, go,
go, go, and then try to eat everything for hours and use to begin
to properly sail. So, um,
you guys can have your own service. But it's,
it's, you know, a lot of it's going to be,
I'm trying to watch, I'm just going to watch some of that one way,
some, some of the- So, uhm,
I guess everybody has their own weird way of doing this.
They're compromised, they're temp employees, they don't aim them through this,
uh, they're their own server. Our entity,
uh-huh-huh-huh-huh-huh-huh-huh.
The other guy, folks, is pretty much sour at that point.
Uh, let me see the exception, I can't believe it was cheap.
And, um, he's MediRoute, he won't drink with his- in the biscuit,
like, uhm, amongst the other guy.
He and Alan, they'll try, try,
try with the tekwa. I love you. I you.
I love you. I love you.
I love you.
I love bringing, ah, you guys doing all the visuals,
because that's one thing that this doesn't show is all the additional time,
so shitting hours and getting to the living room.
I love you, ah, these guys, if you're convinced that they actually go to
the living room, I love you. So, it came through us,
of course you're not gonna be able to- All right. So, enough of this,
uh, this cover doesn't mind if the volume,
right? It's gonna give the masses, kind of, it's having trouble.
I think it's where we need- to go, but currently,
right now, when we're done, it's multiple systems.
We've got a certain volume in the body, your collection will know what- All
right. Oh, darling, it's just going to look forward to close,
right now. So, ah,
but- you And now I'm out shooting with your against the person who will
arrive. Uh, I can't believe it all.
Yeah, I'm in here. You Yeah, it,
it, I don't see a lot. They have to be injured.
Um, the question is if we get- .
But
if it's sound like a majority of the app, if you're going with it.
you Yeah, with a drawer in the house,
and the only area where it would be,
um. All right. And oh I'm a little All right. Or we created additional
work that's added in the projects that are telling our steep production.
All the impression people it is. . They're all production data,
shitting, cuz they see a little bit of an animal quest,
different and oddball things, where they're just taking something new,
taking something new. Nolke. So then we'd have to add all the good jobs
in the nearage so that they have the ability to try it and it's
um, same thing with codeings. Thanks for watching.
See time. However, being a little bit more prevalent because they're trying to keep
the tracking, uhm, shipping is uh,
really weird. in your opinion.
I to me, we are a lot of that.
So you're really being able to be shipping over the whole day.
And it's not- Bye. It's not time to use the second job,
it's what I'm hearing. It's just a- Ops that it's just a little spread
in today. Okay.
It's just spread out with a ball jump, is that how it's going to
go? Okay. Kelsk,
Are you guys going to get too tough now? They went fast,
and now they're in Georgia up into Johnson.
Too tough. Go. And then, you what? But it is a beast that we're
talking about in last couple months,
isn't it? It's darn pretty, it was just a- It's a game over here,
it's true, it's a bit over that thousand shot.
I'll see you up. Okay. So,
no. Bye bye. and an envelope for your recent portion of the unit in
this inventory module. So. No.
When you open the inventory module,
you'll have all of these action available for you.
You're gonna probably just be able to move over, take some stock.
Bye-bye. This, if you need a point, uhm,
once Chris Chief puts his plan together,
then we put lines in the yard,
and then we cut bins. Uh, that's where you remove the functions going to
be. Incredibly useful.
If you guys want to with one
project to the name of the community, because a bigger project came in and
the availability here is going to be better and you want to look and
shop. I saw things around me. If you want something on here,
update the inventory location, you want it in the stop,
operators that you saw. Bye bye. That inventory location updates on their cut list,
and they can see where the steel is at that point.
So, let's get rid of what was going on right now. Yup.
So, uhm, in the future, both function will be super helpful once
we have a very good plan in place. Thank you.
For the whilst in the dedicated encodings,
what's gonna be where for steel, because they are the many rows.
those.
function, we have our old categories for what I have,
which we might have in our, that's,
where do I go in the middle of it. It's good. So, uhm,
the taken stop portion that you guys shouldn't really have to use,
uhm, test. . I would be more prevalent in the lines of,
I feel like I came in with under six foot or eight foot pieces.
Please be, material, E-Verify,
then he can escape it, and confirm with us that it's not allocated to
a project, you can then go, If the tape comes up,
it's fine, that's six-o-piece. Hit tape from the stop.
That should also be the exception to the bullet onto the load,
or just a, Rightly yank it out of the system,
but it's not gonna track any more and they take it loaded up and
it's, So, go ahead and look.
That means a functioned tagline that you guys track.
Mhm. Who does the handling?
It's a checking and receiving, or isn't it?
. . . Well, it's . . . It's more of a faceted,
uhh, my song operator is picking it up from the yard,
picking up the song, and then we'll pass it by us handling And then
by sort of the fabricating material into the,
uhh, the shop, what I'm gonna solve.
Whoa. And that's the part that's happening here.
But it's not a ship that perceives a ship. It doesn't. So that's all
shop camp. We did it now. That's right. It doesn't have any tone with
it there. I don't know if this will be applied to you.
Okay. And we're usually two weeks behind, and this is so,
I don't get a full synopsis. an office. So you guys
have a lot of guys trained to try to afford this.
So
it's a very sugary quality of a shot, but it's, you know, even the
other specs, you know. Okay.
. Yes, sir. So, um, you went on to the next category
of the boat. Uh, this would be.
We're in a prenatal modulus.
You can take that load portion and physically- You
Load the items onto the truck, set against the four loudest three loads of
the system. So we can go in here and kinda show you.
You uhm,
we can have a few Thank you.
So,
let me throw, like, a whole thing until they can go in
it. . . and add each member as they're blooming it on the truck.
Yup. And that would then build a separate little list of..
Yeah, I mean, that's for you. It's not a good,
good, good truck, but it's not a good truck.
Anyways, there's, uhh, uhh, checkbox there and I've
left you a quarter of it. I'll move on so,
do you mind check that? Consistent so you can create a place.
What I They think about something loaded, loaded,
loaded at least, loaded at least, loaded at least.
Okay, this right here is what I'm getting into tat.
I can slap that. Yeah, this is what I can do. Okay.
We're moving to the doors already to the job.
Yeah. After adding up the image shipping portion of the project to the- No
unloading. If you- if you pre-plug the whole type of your talking,
uh, the thing's safe. Which is not always- guys.
But always, uh,
I think you'd have something to do with that. I guess,
if I can go play by the lead.
. . Okay, but we go to siblings that have wonky,
you know, figurations and they just don't wind up the way.
You don't have to go, right? Yeah, I don't have to bathe my work,
but, you know, like, I'm just sticking out of there.
Or it's too tall, so you have to fold it. Yeah.
So. you can do that. I highly suggest
you start using the shipping back on your unit.
It's not pre-built in short. Bye. At least here next Friday.
Right. Then, I usually try to get rid of the organization of it and
the guys at B.R. to say good. I don't care if I'm not going
shoot a few weeks from the end of it. What's your tomorrow?
I see you on P****, the living on calendar. I'm outta here.
I'm here. I hold it up. That'd be my list. I'm ready to get
my, get my, get my, get my, get my, get the boat. And so,
get worse off the calendar. down here. Which means you a lot more in
a mission. So, basically really,
really nice. So. And I think if you want to schedule it.
Good morning. I mean,
shipping is going to need to be part of it.
I mean, we would have such a- massive backlog and that we're,
you know, shipping guys everywhere and we just didn't have the resources to put
on the trucks. Yeah. There I
want to face it. And then can it quite be a lot more?
I'm just going to look at it. So, I'm going to do the inventory.
I'm going to see the portion of it. This is already ready to see
here. You can see your video volume here.
This will represent your videos,
what's included on it. Perfect. And then this is where you can,
you can dial in your quantities, type in your view number,
and then click received.
up. That will receive in four with that heat
downer, and once you do that,
the three remaining stubby out there, you can enter that heat number. We see,
and then we'll walk with that computer, and we'll see if I know what's
going on over here. Now if you're new. So,
on the load side. Bye. Hey, my name is Scott.
So, paper and stock, and it's not right on the list,
and they're just being here from the yard, and it's milling,
then taking the stock. The stock will pull it from the inventory
as well, but it's where you can visit the load inventory in the yard.
. I don't know what load. And ship that up,
receive is where you're going, and this is where you can come and steal
your entry. So you experience the amount of orders that show the
materials that are coming in by purchase order.
I'm not sure. I'm not interested in it,
and you can receive those items in it.
And, uh, click receive down below.
This will be updated in minutes. I a time of this item came in,
this is the heat number, and then the operator instantly knows it had to
stop. Uh, hey, this is here, this is received in,
and I just need to find out where it is,
and once we establish the- the location is in a good line of the
hour that we're going to be, then you guys can add in.
So, like, here. Thank you. Umm,
you can assign your location, and then you'll search your location,
and then that'll update. Okay. Okay. On the outreach,
Atlas, this is in this area,
and then they all, they just came in and built it.
They didn't post on the end of the cell that we saw before.
They're reaching out to us before they're going to go down over there,
so I mean, that's that, you might need to put it.
So, do the family guys,
uh, the shock guys that are moving things,
the vital location where they put the, things in the system.
So, if they're not done running,
I'm not really supposed to say finish good.
Good. Comes out practically,
it's sitting out in the yard somewhere, uhm,
but the handling guy from the shop did it.
There's no, there's no heat and fabrication, location and separation.
So how does the shimmy guy know? You can get everything that's complete and
reduction before taking the police station,
the center area or the shops. What does that I'll stop. After that. Does
that mean it's okay? And anything that is complete from commings,
it's staged in a completion area in the center of the yard.
part of the video. . . And then we'll go back to the beginning
part. . . . are saying basically that you can be with working across
those areas for each. Yeah, essentially.
Yeah, essentially Tinted into those shots, uhh,
that's either completion from Motion and .
. they're going out on whill
and then anything that's completing between the stereo, the current stereo and toadings So
I'm completely, going to go out on a trail.
How do you prepare next to jobs?
I'm a great dad. Have a good day.
You know, if it's a large sequence, a reporter law will give you a
really good identification,
but typically, we have all our data tags.
It'll, uh, form our QC that should have those jobs.
You can slot each one, and then they're going through,
based off of the list of these guys. But you better,
and you don't want them to run any, but it can't be sent over.
We're going to get by it, and then we'll go that way.
See you later then. Goodnight. I mean,
facility's small. It's two working on four acres,
so I guess I better not get lost here.
Right. Yeah, that's,
yeah, that's better. We're seeing,
you know, these, uh, play balls, uh, ballad, and friend of tasey.
Go ahead. Good. I'm glad. Sure.
Thanks. Thank you. Good. So,
this inventory is on the whole screen.
Yeah. Yeah. Inventory risk is where you're gonna go for
moving things, taking things from stock,
loading things, loading raw steel. Thank So that will be the main governing
portion of the house.
Both your order does,
it should be received by personnel. Um,
in addition to that, you'll also have this.
. Work packages, portion, uhm,
work packages, projects, uhm,
anything that's going to be out of less room, if that's enough,
it's going to end in work time. I don't know,
so that's probably the best place for you to look at.
It's going to grow in a way, uhm,
weave.
So, that's- creation is how you can ship. I would be your
best reference is to go get into work that good news.
Umm, can we ship every world for the landowner yet?
I love them. Okay,
so I hope that,
you know, because I've rebuilt all of the loads for that landowner. We'll in
the one.
So,
we have all of our work packages in here, um,
you'll click into your sequence, and then- and here in your shipping category
is where you can reference anything associated
with your bill. So we can see here that we've got one load,
load 19. That's not started yet.
Thank you. . I'm looking at this load, and this would be where you
can make the designation of,
uhm. . Removing,
adding additional, uhm,
could have been blown about, that's really, really nice.
you just check where she wants you to be blown.
No parents, stop, appear,
or if you need to remove it from the load because- It Some items
not gonna fit. If you remove this from the load because it's not gonna
fit, my computer will update- Okay.
What? Didn't shit. And then when you get smart with this shit,
it updates everything and it'll put it back and it's- I can raise it
to a new load and then we can now transfer a track unit from
what went out and we didn't go out and explain it.
I'm going to send a lot. So, you know,
sort of crease of that shit, right? It's like, where the deal would set
me, right? Yeah. And you're looking for D-None.
Bye-bye. Pick the little part meat symbol over there,
or whatever that symbol really reminds of.
That is y'all's station that's supposed to be- No.
Okay,
well, everything's been thinned up. Two of them have been well in it. You
know that new- . We're getting figured out.
Here we have a- . . is best shit, Mars.
Go get knowin' about it. Though, if you want to go in the whole
shop, you can kinda at least see you in a- Yeah.
Yeah. Well,
I have a nice time here at sites where you should go and break
the source that I need. The reason which we're looking for is it could
be a deviant 8x28 with 3 clips or 5 clips.
Oops. See,
you're a bender scrub, it's ruined. I'm just saying,
the shipping guys are always telling me to load the trucks.
I'm gonna- unless the order is consolidated by somebody that either dedicates an area
or whatever, the shipping guys don't.
There's so much that you can add to the movement. We'll see you in
a minute. But they don't really know exactly what the piece looks like.
There's lots of pieces that look really similar. And then you get the wrong
piece on the wrong piece. And I've seen them just having more than I'd
like to. Yeah, they're really smart, so yeah. But you know what I'll say,
they might be smart now. I have not even
had that area where these more packages will really help,
you know, because they're in here. Thank you. And they're trying to look at
everything, umm, once I figure out why I earned the virus,
I can't get it at this point. I don't know how it gets to
the bottom. Come I how it that when you do it this week.
Maybe they'll put it on over the end today, uhh, but they can always
pull this up and have you very clear reference.
Unlike for a B5, I'll shoot it at 60 for the long.
This thing should stand out, so I'm up here.
Let's go ahead and show it. And then, And uh,
I mean, they can go right back to their,
uhm, shipping items.
And then go, Go back into their glove.
Okay. Yep. I have a B9.
Yeah. And this will show the length.
Bye. Umm, but it's only in the shot of length in the main number.
So, if the main number is spliced,
you'll be sub-part to a- Actually,
you're told the length, that might not always be the exact,
you know, if you've done a six-year-old in a day to end the- Thank
you. I said third, but he was a third-year-old with 20-year-olds?
Yeah. So, so that is,
You helpful to assert,
says, but once you start getting rid of the really big stuff,
um, unless the main member is specifically,
detailed out as that full length,
and we run it as a splice package in here,
and you keep that raw length, the full length. And again.
For this one, umm, the detail package anticipated a
splice, so the main number was actually a sub.
So. A portion of your full length. So,
umm, there is a way for us to leave a main number,
add a full length, and create a splice. A splice package and splice the
parts together to keep that main number length that way.
Yeah, so don't always be like this. That's a big mess.
It has no- . . I'm not singing with the trucks but he wants
this, that wants to turn the parts together. Okay.
The name of the cousin will be Kim Snowman.
So, So. Well, uhm,
it'll be project by project basis, but then it will be over the best
recognizability, projects and events. Thanks.
So, but you can pull up all these different things.
You guys will have visibility tunes in here.
And, and you guys can see.
Bye. I have a lot of of work and everything.
What's it where it turns? Can you can go,
uhh, back to here? You back to your overview,
assemblies, uhh, material status,
showing status, and uh,
let's see. I'm going be one day. Dashboards.
I'm going to go to our shipping camp there. This is what we're going
to- Thank very much. We have
all of them on here.
And then, once we've heard our chat,
we have a seat request to have all three of them fully set up
a ton of glue over to one week. I brad it them,
dr- Dray. They're already built in there,
everything's very needed to be, so I just started bringing pre-organizing for the-
You guys are in here, and you know something's not in the ship,
umm, so. I think that's where- uh,
bring the level up. You think about it,
and bring up the legend. So the origin
of the product risk, Loom, is central,
but- . . . you've seen Zero-Shaded in the bottom?
Yeah. That Zero-Shaded says, Peace and Better Plan for that job,
and that doesn't mean a lot of it yet. So.
Bye! Whereas the orange can be there as an ownership player.
Um, and they've got green,
which is, it's already shaded in Maria that was supposed to be shaded in
Maria. It's your persona. So, that's why I didn't mark it.
So, uhm, from here, uhm, you know, tomorrow's in 12.
Well, Excellent schedule.
Nothing's been loaded. Nothing's been confirmed.
You can go in here, reschedule.
Push this Go on a day if you needed to. Push it through Monday.
And then, if you're going here,
just populate back down here. And- And then,
the visibility quality there for everybody involved on it.
Or give it a sexy rating, but- I don't if you should write it,
you'll be there. I'm going to say this for now.
Who's the last of me, Sk Shilid.
So, yeah, it's not the length of the helmet,
it's a transport. So, this would be
nice for,
I'm having a good communication with Hey, what's your own,
and what's your own next day, what's your own Monday?
This, come on. It's a good, it's a good, it's it's a it's a
thing. This will be it. I have every communication home for that thing.
You better be impacted while your int is, when this person is good.
How does it feel, guys, though? What's coming in- The thing is,
can I use this counter? You're welcome.
Hopefully
right. You So,
honestly, typically we'll set during our kickoff,
we schedule the current date that goes as expected by the bill poll winner.
Umm, if there are any changes that the bill is born in,
or the project manager, or that child,
would reach out to each and the shooting man. I'm sure I know the
rest of the time. Uh,
did salary mixing up, or did we have to make sure that we're on
par and meet that kid? Are they talking to you,
the field, construction guy like yourself,
the back kid, and then the top of the knee. They're all up,
they'll talk and call for anything you need to say they don't put.
Good. If it's an accelerated jumping forward,
or inward, then I'm going to communicate with us to see if we can
hear about them. Goodnight. Yeah.
Sometimes I attend recently, if they just communicate with Paul,
I hit on a rectangle, but if you pushed it out,
you know, not quickly. Mm Mm-hmm. Mm Mm
Mm Mm.
Dear Quok, y'know, their hits go wild!
Am I out, ladies and gentlemen?
Ay sir? I just keep telling you,
that's what you're going to get. I'm going to get all this new beat,
y'know, at once then, shoot. I don't care if that's the question.
We're ready. I'm just getting doin' it real quick.
It's on there. Also, I'm in the head of Atlassian's own beat.
Yeah, next. Okay. Okay.
Okay. I'll that you We're ready to You know,
it's most people who kinda like me listening.
My hands are like, what she do, and I'm like,
okay. Let me play it then. Then, I'm like,
yeah, right. You know, so it might be,
um, so I'm like, okay,
so we will be able to take it. So I'm only in a single.
Thank you. Okay. very carefully. It's the one
that's coming here, it's the last of the year in our Kingdom.
It's just beautiful.
Hahaha, that's it.
Good.
and then I will get you permission to get out.
Thank you.
And finally I'm going to simply give you a setup with this.
See you in the next video.
It's just now that I've got it that's what I've been doing.
My best, especially with Taylor. Thank you very much.
So,
it's super stunning to be one of those kids,
right? Good. And I'm in support of being this great thing,
so I'm not making the way, but proceed.
See you. See you at the end of the night.
I'm ready for the move.
And
if I can't, I'm ready for the end. you why really this relation was?
really? hahaha no,
I'm never gonna get back.
hahaha So
that actually had jumped on me to sign this side a little more,
or whether we better sign on to- just to get up here.
Thank you for all that I can .
Yeah,
that's the thing, it's super awful though.
Good. It was really annoying when I got in my phone.
Yeah. It was absolutely the being my existence.
Thank you for listening. I,
uh, I have a term of media that on the left side of the
media, but that's where I see it, so.
Yeah, I should have known what you're going to know. And I think there's
way to turn Thank
you very much.
So, now you're in my interview so I'll take a shot. That's the best.
I got a little trick in the basement, not with the bike needed in
there. It was an even though I didn't consider it.
And I'll go to see. See you. There's a window.
So, uh, so here's,
you can go use the hot number and chop the brush. for the first
time. And you can scroll down into the magnet.
It's not your bracket. It'll come when it's your turn.
You'll go. You can see all of the material you need to be able
Thank you. Have a great Have a Bye. Three.
No worries in the areas, the other five of them all literally shouldn't have.
Well, remember, just don't look like anything. Umm,
uh, I don't know it is. Yeah, I think you got .
. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
See
how it's still turned out, you missed it. . . .
. So what is that?
I've been having a jump, right? Yeah, it's only nice to sit in your
team. Yeah. So now,
now that you've got your set, I'm going to be back,
so I'm going to go through it. Don't you?
I'm going to see your L right there. I just can't be- Yeah.
There are such many.
Right. Just wave. David. Final.
It's the Trello. Open the end. Give me one minute.
I'm bad, too. Unless you want to get a better shirt or a
lee over your pocket shirt, it's a good standard.
Thank you. And if you want us to, I can tell you what we
need to do in a separate case. It's like to do a whole lot
of research about how to wear it. It's an actual word.
But, be eh, you know, I don't- I was going to show you how
to leave this in the morning and wear it for a moment.
Like, the guy is better at your painting,
so you have to get in and put what you need in your house.
you have a nice image. So,
uh, I'm going to pick one, I'm going to pick one,
I'm going to one, I'm going to pick one, I'm going to it's going
to go down, and push the key.
See that magic, I'm going to get it back If you want to receive
a four, five, ten, my items,
and they're all going to say, well, let's say you don't like it.
You can hit me on my- And if you heard the personal options,
well, I'm not sure as if you had to pipe it in different parts.
No, I'm just- I'll see you in the same show you're coming in.
Thank you. And as in the same time, you just go ahead and I'm
not going through it in there. So when I lock in,
just push that and close it in. Yeah,
you were just- you were just- selected all the line lines,
but you remember me because they're unique or a lot of them.
Yeah. And then when you come back in,
it'll be all the way and you could- Okay, so that does it for
all of a lot of notes, yes.
Also, say something next. Thanks for the time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And then now let's go down the sheet.
out of the head. So,
this is gone. They don't hear the, like,
the other big people in the apartment just want you to see today.
Cheers! And
then when they got the last one, it was a bit bigger after moving,
you know, and then it won't be in parts of detail on that.
Yeah, once you guys started getting deeper into that.
Then you can go into your move tab.
We're going to get in here. We can go ahead and make the weekend.
Okay. Okay. All right. Bye. Bye. We're going to get a bit of patience.
So, uh, we few years to move at the bottom.
You just have a moment to get you know, in a Mississippi way,
or just a location, a new section, a location,
a bar, or a pair with it. Yeah.
So let's. So, in a Mississippi portion.
would be able to sign the location. So we already know,
and we got, we got all that steel that's going to go right here.
Here's what I did. Here's my section. He goes.
And receive it, you know, right into that portion.
You know what I'm going to do in the books? If you have these
issues, they're all right. I'll be with the pain or the like that.
Breakout and have people over the years and pour in,
you know, the stories. Alright,
let's see. Let's see how the game's been made.
And okay. Alright, I'm going to go up and see a lot of the
shoots over there. Now, I'm going to go over here and just make this,
uh, you know, a lot. Alright. So, and try.
Okay. So, let's try to get in mind, and I'm so early on this
week, plans to get tablets to do all the question I needed.
We need it. And by Friday and Wednesday week,
I'm gonna take a list of who we have as BPM,
your logins, and Thurgis, you know,
as you can do as you can. Mm. Mm. Mm.
Mm. Mm. Mm. to take it and make sure these cards can be closed
for their time, personality, and women. Mm. Mm.
Mm.
Create an email for them,
and you get to their audience still.
So not for no great children, but that's a good word.
Alright, couple of people on team with us.
Now, so we love the portion. It is where you would love material.
That's the- In the US, there's some, yeah, no violence,
or say, ah, we're calling him and he'll have a shipping order.
Or I'll just go over it for a minute. Bye bye. So, let's take
a line over the road, for example. You got that long load that you're
looking at, really, that still has to go, uhh, you should- I have to
cause you- I need a 8-way band to get anything from where you are.
You go in there, you filter to plan 8.5,
you know, actually there's a 15. Put a piece on here with that word.
Yup. You can go in there, grab the paste and add it to that
earlier. It's all there. Mmm. It's all in there.
You keep up and low. You have,
you know, the world built. It has to add into your city.
Oh, okay. That's what that machine's for.
One, two. I do not believe in this as well, too.
Yeah. Yeah. That'll be, in instances where the field guys really
need this. That. You that's what you use.
So that's how you get a flush pack. If you have a stock,
you're putting it in for months. Okay. Just take a stock push.
Thank much. So here, that's where, uh,
I feel like I've been tensed. I need a system around here.
You know, I've been to my system. It's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's,
it's, it's, it's, it's, it's. So, if it's not 6 foot,
it's very new scrap. Um.
And, they don't even get a log, they just wanna take it.
You know, you can look in there, see what jobs associated with CDP number,
if you don't see that, it's available as a random.
You can grab that. Go ahead. Remove it from the system and send it
online on a set. Okay.
Okay. And have a good time. Keep this quality ready to go.
You don't. Like, it's been a sheath episode.
Yeah. So, since I've been received, umm,
follow up over there now. Scan it.
It's on the PR. are So, like, thank you, you know,
for a new batch, and I've been on my receipt. Okay.
So, uhm, wait, I've got a nice thing about this,
and I'm gonna watch you. You have to do with this, you know,
if you get calls on a little bit more about, hey,
if we receive this, can we get that? that, come and shut when you're
looking. in system because you update the right hand.
Ya know, I mean, I'm honest with that, so the good,
it shouldn't happen. This should be the communication tool there everybody.
Thank you. You shouldn't have to come and use the video that app,
right? You can see the system and work, ya know?
So by the time they call me, you can get it around your day,
it's gonna figure it out, right? Ya. Yeah. So that's really what should be
happening. So, uh,
it should be R as soon as you can click
enter on that, is purchase order and they are no longer started when it's
over. Okay, and you can pull that extra amount of- the overall material or
expected material. Again, we're able to expect a material report for the data,
and we like it. It's- Have a good week.
Okay, so, but then from here,
uhm, for you though, for you to go for fun? Okay. We're have to
We'll next one. Oh, yeah, yeah, Let it
go. Yeah,
so, right there in that the same transparency of the builders,
even though I flipped my job number, building my work back.
Okay, bye. Yeah, and then get yourself down to,
this is what I know, I have to take a look at what I've
been told should be going to stay. Yeah, and then you can get to
know. I think here we go.
If you're in the accident and built your portion,
see if you just find a way to- first one,
2.0, 6.0,
1, so same here all the week. Yeah,
those will do, uh, 3.0. So,
I think that's a new portion there.
I think that'll be easy to do this one.
Yeah, and we'll leave it with that one. Yeah, yeah. Go,
go, Hey, hello. Into the building with the highway in the building.
This will be the main page of that series.
in the future. If you must go in and as you scroll down,
you'll see those options will not take you to address the question.
I'm going in there and see you'll be in that shape because of the
emotion of the body. The shape, right? Yeah, so if you look down there,
they'll not take you into
the shape, the emotion of anything, and you'll see for that work package,
what's been planned? That's already shipped.
You already know. ... ... ,and if you put that below the clock,
um, on the plus statement to the same ship,
that'll give you a great color plus, I don't think so.
See? Thank you. I they said piece of that on the middle, I already
shared, I just shared that with you. Okay.
If you have a balloon, the balloon.
I'm gonna put a number of balloons,
and then the other one, the HCA. Let's all,
always think of the balloon, so yeah. Good.
Do. Thank If you have permissions,
you can un-ship it.
Un-mother pieces, new pieces,
all that all. All right. I don't need it,
but, uhm, that is sure. But, yep. There's more to your face.
Yeah. So, um.
you know, alright. So, that has been pre-built a little.
Then, you can take this tablet out there,
and neither of your items are looking for. More. As you convert them into
your station areas, you can build your load.
Then, as you build your load, you can load it.
. I mean, I hope you can do that louder than that.
Because, you're in the back of course, I'm doing the camera,
because you're alone. Go. And you'll see what we will look at on our
screen. We'll make it beforehand.
Alright, ahead and look.
So, we'll make thousands of items that we've been in.
So, we'll have to have a good day more than next year.
We'll the next video. Bye. So, well, that is not moment.
You hit the three dots on the other thing. We can go on
details. Yeah. Yeah. So now you
got the DSC.
The- And the reason it says it hasn't been loaded again.
So, if- if you're like, and you don't want to get that,
then come back and get that loaded button. Bye.
Hey, checkbox, and you should check in the ones that should load it.
So, just check what we want to do with the chat so that we
can see that you won't- So, you just add anything to your load,
and you can just check that off, and then we'll select the analysis,
and notice you're loading it. It's not- I'm sorry,
you're playing anymore, you're only playing it, right?
So, two minutes in here, it's just something I really like to go with,
really cool, but it's just a good thing. And then, So, the day I
go to load it is all from,
and I know all my parties are there, then I go through and then
select their thing, objectives. Uhh,
I will submit it. That's a few of you guys can do that.
I usually suggest that as I see anyone,
like, if you want to file pieces. please subscribe to me more videos. And
then you come back later in the day, you go to another file.
I probably won't see that as it's happening.
Um, because. because us, I just know that most of the time when it
is in place and it's like, I have to take lightning,
what people are not doing, they are the same.
I'll see Yeah, sure, but eventually when they do that,
they're not gonna piece by piece or whatever you get it and
then just. is. through the depth. So I think we don't know if we
can put it out. I'm changing everything else. It's coming out of one of
these in my piece. And then as we go with Atlassian,
we can get a. Or we can build an instrument so we can get
all the rest of this case. We need to include it in one of
those things, you know. Yeah. But so this is.
Thank you. I do want to do it slowly to get shit out like
that. Yeah. Alright.
Bye You can be building the work on the brand,
then then just going along the truck. Yeah.
So, some people, you guys have to sign this.
This lesson, when we do the shop housing,
that right there would be shown as the logo bit.
Umm. you As it was built on the ground,
it was a truck gave you two pics, we're on the truck and it's
gone, and we get shit. Alright.
You guys can't even decide how you want to do the helicopter.
So everybody knows what does the motive mean.
Does it mean it's basically on the truck or- It's built on ground,
yeah. Uhm, so, ehm, for us,
our definition shot those in. Thank you.
Loom was, that load was built on the ground.
I had a load of them home again, but it's ready to get bumpy.
So yeah, that's it. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. And that's probably the best way to do it,
because then, as you get it, you're all down to down on it,
and you're putting rows and the rows.
You can go through that. And that, ah, you have two of them,
this one, two of them, this row. There are some more elements down,
and start on the next row. I, those two,
you're there, those two are there. You're working down in the list as you
build your load, and then you have that marked off.
You know, your quantities are good, and then when you ship it,
it's all right. Yeah,
so it is. Thank you.
But first time you do it, I would recommend you walk.
Love you. Love Love you. Love Love too.
Yeah. Yes. Yes. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, I would recommend you do
it. No, yeah.
No, I'm going to share, uhm, I'm going to share,
uhm, the rating. That's, uh,
what can you not- I'm going to uhm,
I'm uhm,
I'm going to share, uhm, and in a minute.
Here is how I'll be able to join him for receiving.
And if you call down, he'll say, uhm,
open him uhm. Cool.
But got another You in the middle of the city.
Yeah, I'll have room. Thank you. This
is a final animation, man.
It's just really, you know, it's amazing.
And so,
you can do it this way or flip them back before you have a
speech period. Yeah, eat this. I'm I will.
I'm sorry that that's enough. And that's really,
you know, I'm just,
That's what's been on the line. That's why I'm on the line.
It's not going to play out again.
Thank you. Yeah, yeah. It's exactly.
Well, not so many things in here, in the suggestion of how to contain
it. I couldn't, I couldn't put an estimation point.
. . I couldn't comment down on the frickin' password. You could click the
button and spin it down and it talks about the amount of screens here.
Okay. You could join the Aix. Oh, I think it's just a little powerful.
Okay. That really won't happen. Yeah, I'm gonna shift and get a bit of
into receiving the analysis. I'll see you in the video about him shifting and
1,000, 1,000, 1,000,
1,000, and you just look back and forth with the two pads.
That's it, I'll be back in June. So if I had hit,
uhm, there's no wall holding and then I hit,
uuuh. You And, a lot of people don't know what use to play the
Just me Fisters, me. I, I, it, I, want tackle, uhm. A lot of
people don't it looks like in
some guy that's fully boarded prepared. A lot of times you have to go
in time-tracking. You have to go in time-tracking. to go in-tracking,
you have to go in a second. You You just go in and you
have to go in there. So,
you're fine. You're fine,
Trello. I'm washing my- I'm just using it.
And it's like, you know, you're not- you're not scared of anybody going
to let go of it. Other people are not here.
I'm scared touching them, then we love touching them,
you know? That's not what we're gonna do. I
need to be the captain, yeah.
Come on. Come on.
You are winning on games right now.
Hahaha. That's uh,
uh, uh, uh, it's pretty good. Thank Is that correct?
Yeah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, the average number that's going to
happen to happen The point will sit down with the essential question.
He paid the initiative. I used to make very
much use on the tool, and we gave it to,
we gave it to, uh, dear. It's
a nice to have, um, it's like a little working, but,
uh, yeah. I don't do it all the time.
You don't know why I'm in the shot. Heh, heh,
heh, heh. Do you want me to save all your GTs?
Do you do it all the time? Yeah, yeah.
You don't really need too much, you can, you can bring it back to
the phone, jeez. . Now, how are you going to do it when you
start marking up on sashira and production? Thanks for watching,
and I'll see you again with a lot Thank you.
Everyone permissioned on a computer and heard of the permissioned on really honestly.
So, you know what I mean?
Umm, it goes, they've had to- . Umm, it's profile,
it's written PMDOL, it's user by user basis,
but I can copy PMDOL solutions to cost users.
So. So So,
Miss, how do I write this on the street?
. . I don't know if I'll in there. Of course there are lots
of tabs in this little strip of stuff.
I just went there and thought, you know, I passed you through yourself.
But it'd be much. You haven't added any of your bookmarks to stuff.
I don't know how to put them in here.
I'll keep them in here. I'll keep them here. Thank you.
Come on in, look at that.
So, sit in the area of the bookmarks.
I'm in the- I'm in the on marks here.
Part of you with that one. It's not
true. I'm gonna go ahead and get it.
It's gonna be a little easy. Thank you.
Anything
Rental or Closhing United? You Mm-hmm,
hmm,
uhh, hm, hm, hm, hmm, hm, . . .
Oh,
I missed their share button.
Yeah, alright. No.
And
if you want to retrieve it, well. Let's go.
Jira, Loom,
MediRoute, Bum, MediRoute,
Bum, MediRoute I don't want that.
We'll be trying to get, you know,
the basic buying materials going on to 200 bucks.
I'll see you in a normal life.
And, uh,
this of all, we can't secure that. We have everything like ours.
All right, so. We can't secure that, but all of us,
and I said, you know, basically.
Big buck. We're going to do 15 tablets last month.
Do you want to write? Bye bye. You know how the social media did.
Why? Why? Why are you grabbing a bunch of seriously you?
Thank you You know,
you're not asking, you know, get that yellow pad and see if it changes
for the need. This is like an old viewer being closed free with a
sub. love. So, just get there to get through that yellow
pad. No, then what move?
Thank you. So. But yeah,
I can't think that sometimes we move against that thing,
but all of you are all the way in the middle of thing.
I believe you have this, uh,
display in Spanish, right?
Yeah, sure. Yeah. I'm wearing a lot that I'm fresh and good.
I'm on a long stream that you got out of the world.
I'm going to wish you luck. You I
don't think I'm going to explode, for example. I love Anything,
one damage is a lot easier to get. It's fun enough to manage it.
I actually need to, uh, speed up the subject.
Okay, uhm, there's something in the,
like, feedback and sort of communication, but you can't tell it.
Uh, uhm, uhm, you can go home and read them some- We're going to
be doing a of doing this, and we're going to be doing this in
a minute. See you in a little bit. See you in Hey,
okay. Went. ... ... ... I don't know what to You can see
my dog right now. No, it's not. Keep your eye on the hood.
Shouldn't get out of here.
I never wanted to leave this again, even if it's even up to the
store, so it can fit in there. Oh, I don't know what's going on
with me. Alright, I'm going to turn it over. Thank And then I think
it's going to affect me. Yeah, well, I saw it,
but, umm, I thinking, I'm not thinking, I'm not thinking,
I'm thinking, I'm I'm not. Is it the kid?
You Yeah, I'm not gonna show you a little, but, umm,
it kinda is. It's okay, I'm like, something to show you,
but, umm, I can't even go around saying that,
but essentially, I can't even. Thank you. If you have some material,
you can ask why I can't even protect some of that meaty.
And if you have an explanation about it, you can basically leave it in
the zest of all. Nothing else. . I can go over the process.
This is okay now.
and I'm going to go out with b***** and me again. I'm going to
let them tell me to f*** himself when we're going through this map.
So, we'll use the I'm going to use the shirt.
I'm going to do it. I'm going to do it.
I'm going to throw it and make it happen.
and in a down-and-go-tee, and, uh,
keep that fastest going. So I'm going to make us more efficient,
so we're going to need to do that. We'll a I'm going
to do that. Let's reach it.
Follow me. Can you do it?
. You want me
to know what I'll say? So, if you go over, uh, I'm going to
see if he has any questions, I'm going to have him here. Thank you.
I'm involved. So, please,
thank you very much. I you. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much. Thank you very Thank you very you very Thank you
very much Thank you very much Thank you very much
Thank you very
much Thank
you very much.
Thank you. in my place.
Just, you can see the one hand, or the canvas.
So, uh, in here,
I think there's time to turn it. Thank you. Thank you. John,
I'm actually trying to get you in here. Oh, I don't even,
I was going to be a part of the young son of a son
of a of a son of a son of a son of a a
son a son son. Oh, and then she matched,
and then from there, uhm, Loom,
the sort of style. So, it's the next holiday story.
Sorry. First off, we'll be this entire, from D1 on the way to C3,
right? Yep. So, uhm, I like to separate those out.
Same deal. They win. you have it. You want to make sure you have
So, if they want to be 2, 3, uhm,
then just select, maybe you want to make sure.
It's easy, 3, 3. Yeah, that's what I'm going to do.
You're going to start with some of this. I'm going to do a little
bit while I'm going to share with each of you guys to fight for
the day. You I'm going to actually be going fast on
you and uh,
for the beat. Thank you.
Cause this is for any additional reason to have,
to have it in the power of my head. It's, it makes me believe
it. Well, map was away from Yeah,
I to tell back section. You know what,
if you want to just, so get me an umm,
just start there. . Alright, and then you need more than,
I'm going get this in, which is here. You can set it in one
minute, alright? . . Oops.
. . I hit two. . this is all good. So I'll do the
only one person working. And then we'll get it down,
and we'll do b2 or whatever. just there to shoot you
in memory of all the various work.
It could be exactly that. Yeah. Good luck.
Yeah.
I mean, they need to get back up to the top. Oh.
Whatever you've done in your spot, when you get back,
make that time of the plot on their space. I don't know.
Okay. Mm. Mm.
Why is it going to be so awkward? It ticked in the mirror.
It's like, I want you to do it on the phone. I'm, I'm,
I'm Jasmine. Thank you. I will be your manager now,
and then, uh, I'm happy to hear it out in the video.
I don't know about it. We don't know about it.
Okay. So, go. You and then, so now we'll be happy to have a
check. So, let me know what time you're working on these pieces. I can
tell you that I'm not too honest. Thanks. You know, and a lot of
times, like, as a person.
for a second. You know, shop releases,
there's usually one word that means,
or maybe two word that means it's okay, or something,
like that. And that'll be. You know,
so, in a lot of times,
the ehm, ehm, like that.
Good. That's what we use for the ehm,
and they're going to have time and they're going to be very supportive.
So, over that, it's just a five-year budget,
but it's still here. It's amazing. Thank you. It's really,
really good at the bottom. It's amazing.
Doesn't matter if you can keep on coming.
It's, you're sorry, the shut down will be getting hot. And we'll one.
I'm going to do some release. I'm going to do that. I'm going to
do thing on the additional shut packages for TSM to be done.
Three. Thank you much for doing that.
Um, I'm also going to be coding only to import it.
Um, but for the stuff that's coming up to action.
Um. Bye I'm going to have to work back some sh- We are in
London. Do you have a package of letters?
A minor? Is that an answer in the- .
Back when you tell me it was. In the store,
you can pass it on. There's only five,
but so far out. Yeah. Yeah. I'm going to take a look at that
because I see that you know you're looking down.
I'm going to mess with Bill Broughs and make sure you know how he's
moving. I'm going to make sure you know how. You know, being mites is
either a good one to mention, plenty of ground,
one of the previous ones that I just didn't know were,
uh, maybe not. Bye! I was here to start working on it anyway,
so. But, I think that that would have been here since those are tied
to, So, you know, the station,
or the leading thing that's just on the B-strap inside,
gonna add and kick it away at any And,
maybe it's not gonna affect me, at least. Okay.
Don't have a cut saw on there, and the cutless is cut,
and then a cut saw. That's gonna make me lighter than I have from
working on it, at least trying to meet some of the stations in Bitbucket.
Yeah. Yeah. That's the only way I can do. You know,
I can be lighter than I have from the left, and then I can
see just how there You know,
just not enough things out there for every issue,
or by the way the science language has to be done.
Everything we do. So I'm not thinking we'll be there,
not thinking we'll be able to expose.
It's time.
He's right now. I'm pretty sure I've been following P and the user's stuff.
Well, not since I'm following. Okay. Okay. I heard it's behind me.
I hear it's behind Proclass for PowerFam.
Yeah. He's behind me. He's me.
He's behind me. I'm for Charles. Yes. And he fits in with all the
literature on YouTube. Thank you. I love it. I love the video.
And I'm gonna the tech board of partners and,
and, and the tech board of partners.
And you
you Thank you. Alright,
listen, you guys, you know, there's been a very dangerous hit.
Very good magic. I don't know, I don't know,
don't even know what to do, it's really- Alright. It's pretty cut and dry,
uhm, as we started getting from this low down,
and you're going on the middle side, I know,
and my home is going to be- It's a really, really nice job,
and it's so important. Alright, we're doing a little bit of fun,
and then we're going to go through this one. And then we're going out
with the guy, and he's going to get that. you I'm going to be
able to see anything go through this process. We have really,
stupidly, and with the right hair hoe, I don't know,
any of the production and style issues. questions. State . Start,
stop, you know, through the process of listening.
Once you get it done, give me a call over and I'm up there.
Okay. and we weren't the absolute needed.
We needed that two to three, five times depending on the god.
One of these seconds. Foundation. So,
and then the while, the, while, there, but there's a video.
So, uhm, right now,
there you go. Appreciate it. Take the time. Yeah. Yep.
So, we have a question that you can install,
and then, uh, let's begin with a little situation. situation.
You can follow us on Twitter. We'll make it happen.
Something good? Right here. Yep.
Thanks again, man. Bye. Yeah,
you know what to do. Yes,
you can hear what to do.
Who's going to have to look on any given panel?
You can tell, listen, you're going to be moving on a bad day,
don't you? Yeah,
an issue, yeah. I'm surprised. Don't call me for sounding the idea unless you
vote. out.
If you have It'll be second nature to that.
We put a cheesy cross and we're going to leave that copy.
That's the same kind of eager to want.
I didn't do that. Well, and I've shown it to him a few times
in capabilities, you know, on a teenager,
you know, B. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. It's about 7.5 million in the day.
Tools may open. Yeah. I'll call on the other I know
that would be a challenge for them to sit on the side and put
the meat out bigger, but. Three and a few more.
Um. Don't worry. I'm sorry. For the list, we're gonna do with soft food,
with ice packs. We gotta fill out what is going on here.
Yeah. And then like I was saying, the shot would be.
I and I don't know yet,
but, Everspend, no legal preach.
This is my time to hate. . Alright, a bit of a rant.
Or, yeah, just a smother, so. Ehh,
ugh, yeah, so if you think we want to be some,
we might have to give it a really nice and a good part of
our action. Goodness. I don't know if should look for a stand-up
or a stand-up or a a stand-up.
I wish you'd soon have a please day sponsor. I mean,
uh, so much truth about this time a lot.
So, I'm meeting for a- and this time to add the additional
modules that you don't have. Actually, if you did not have the common
CLC, Yurra,
and a few different things in there.
So. Once
he adds those models to my 12th end of the year,
that was true. Umm, it's better card on the wristband.
. Sats, uhh, coming to the top.
The original port without the additional models is about the key brand.
Amen. So,
we're going to have that, which, um,
how did you, what was yours? Well,
uh huh. I'm going to hit the list of 33K following the lead.
You can call it and run it back, and use the,
great ball networks. There's Sshit, okay.
I'm not even teaching here, I'm using the balance of your team.
Okay. So, anyway. It's like 35,000 and so you can purchase them.
So you think we can figure that out,
can we? This can't be absolute. Thank you for your patience. Oh,
I don't want to call on the reading. I know.
Okay. Okay. Yeah.
We're just going to be like, ignoring from time. Welcome. No,
my guess is probably 17 with 18.
It's about 14, but that's also- The Jira,
and which is stating our main explaining of them.
Cause I've made it, I've been down since first of the year,
so you've got to find some of them. So,
uhm, so we're gonna leave at the maintenance plan on the nurse and that
we have any support. We don't,
uh. What's he doing?
So, we're not loading up.
Let's go for it. Bye. Bye. and Chola,
Phunk, as well. So,
we're planning and helping some great projects.
So, she says it out. She says it out. She says it out. She
says it out. out. She out.
So, okay, you know, a little over a second.
It just covers there. Yeah.
you Umm.
Are we on that little stairs? Can that person report me that I need
to check the numbers? Thank much. Yeah,
uh, you, uh, maybe between the two,
one, maybe, computer and, uh, two. Um. Uh, Middle
school? Uh, uh, So. And there we go.
Oh my gosh. You
Uhm, I would be able to hear this.
I'd say it was funny, it was obvious to me that she had to
read. You get it, baby. And then it says,
oh no, it's his, oh, he's stolen e-mails,
and we need to find Jira, so he can buy. You know what the
chat is? And then it goes to Umm,
it just gets lost. Umm, Umm,
Medi, Loom. I'm not. I'm actually about this one and my things are certainly,
you know, I'm gonna, uh, come to politics, they are going to be,
this. Thanks. But that burns really fast.
I'm going to start there and begin to update his things so it'll be
no useable. Good morning. Good morning to University.
Good morning,
everybody, hub. How's it going?
Good, I'm John D'Yuma, I didn't make a clear,
uhm, sorry, but it was, it was processing,
it was, uhm, pre-built load of score.
The most of them is, you know, it's a lot of the projects that
kind of things smaller. All right.
Yeah, we should put a game. On,
we can assemble it. Let's, yeah. Um,
you know, I'm really meant to go back in some ways over there.
Thank you. Thank . I had to
drop angles, and I was going to go and have a chest in it.
. . . You're gonna be better independent,
with some more support here. Say, you know,
I'm going to ask you if I don't have any final points.
And then, obviously,
I'm gonna make a shadow. Yeah. There'll be like,
smart sheets, and we're all, there's no- they have money to get.
I don't know who's still getting used
to that. Uh, so it's kind of,
it's kind of like,
this is rather than another video game.
. Yeah, so let's,
I
was gonna say, well, you want us to, like, prevent,
see, there's a lot of cost in Canada, there's a lot of time to
do, but I guess I'll go up there in the next week so I
don't week a minute. I don't really just want to reschedule those events and
all that. No rest. Thank listening.
Yeah so, so with the bonus integration,
I'm hoping to get that, that,
again, on the announce edition as well.
Yes. So I did for training today, uhm,
soon again I was thinking, what are you guys about? What the process can
contain all the evidence? Uhh, uhh, uhh, uhh, uhh, uhh, I'm guessing a brand
new number of I.T.E. because it's going to be something that's attached to the
server, but they're not a promise it's going to be easy.
You uhm, post it on a nasty computer,
yeah, and then it's, uhm,
right. So that I'm going to be doing a little colleague minute.
with you in the process, uhm,
some nice parts that come into the system for you, you know,
so, you know, with you at all the events. Um.
Bye. Now, I'm pretty sure even the plugin,
you know, you know, the integration is the applicant,
the promise, and the innovation, and then you just point it to,
well, they should set that up. Uh, for you to hopefully cause the,
the promise that the integration is a little bit complex,
it's gotta, for lot of seconds,
you gotta set up in there. You're here. and so many variations of their
new site aren't all in the biggest games.
There's a little bit of conflicts, but like, get me to uhh,
uhh, uhh, uhh, uhh, Get back into the desktop version and go into a
production control job and life.
Get it like you're going to get into this in place.
Here, oh, and then you'll click.
Nest with grown-ups and then you'll generate a file and you'll shoot that into
my phone right now. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. So,
when you do that, you choose progress integration on that optimization,
and it spits out that file, it gets in the- It does everything there
pretty much. Thank you
You're playing him into where he will then be controlled by produce,
which is nice food. You'd
have to do it before there's something nasty in the stage,
so you want to go combine it.
It's where you want to Okay.
and optimizations down out there in
plate nesting settings. So there we're supposed to take the power.
you know what I actually would have, uh,
when you run such a little bit. Yeah,
yeah. We used to use field projects and now it's just the same way.
Yeah. Okay. Now it's gonna be hard for us to achieve and play that
game and, uh, it'll be like, more.
Keep an eye on this. Give me the magic spot, right? Bye bye. Uh,
it gives, uh, uh,
the impact. Bye bye. Yes.
Oh, I made it.
Ah. I love the mission of the company. I love the name of the
software. I love the area.
And still projects have people in the same area.
And it's loveless ride with us.
It's, it's a huge road.
And I would always set the trouble with, by setting up all the steps.
Thank you. And it's no problem. It's like, I don't care.
You guys figured that out. If you're somebody who thinks about it,
you can make this thing alright. I'm ready for Again,
I'm gonna concentrate on it. Well, yeah.
That'll be nicely done. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, and then we'll see them at a scale of their efforts.
Umm, I know, we don't know each other,
we live in Bitport, we have here, various adjustments.
That was good. Umm, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
. Yeah. And have that, excuse me,
I promise, play a lot of results. Yeah. And then with these,
they're a full label. And that would be fantastic.
Yeah. Yeah. Alright. Oh.
No, I'm not a logical sucker though,
I'm gonna be able to guess a little bit more efficiently because yeah,
I sense all of our units, so I'm gonna toss them to the,
I feel like I found one chat, and without any more space,
I mean, there's so many things that we can guess. Yeah,
this is a space, I'm 16 years old and the part of it is
so, that's where we're going. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. I can't even go out on a trombone line. Well,
let me know when- I mean, it's not the first one,
well then, yeah, yeah, yeah. So, it's not, it's not the first one.
Yeah, yeah, it's the first one.
Get that, I'm sorry, that's what's going on today.
So, uh, swing a little bit, I'll get it cold,
we'll get that order, hopefully, get that, that,
in your face. So, yeah,
and then you can do it somewhere else, but maybe it's not.
So, let me see if I can get it turned out.
Please. . I mean, he doesn't even have a gun in his head.
Mine was like a human. We need to have it. And I'll see the
next Staying down is superior for two reasons.
I know it take more. It's 35k women.
I've got no sawing. Okay. Sir.
What do you mean? Do you know what I mean?
I told the movement. Yeah. John had, like, 100k and now he's done it
by 75k. Oh. you Out, something like that.
I don't even need it. But we have massive shit out of it,
you know what? Basically, we're just staying in. We're going to volume,
take our trucks, and then credit companies. I'm gonna go watch.
We're going into a four-wheel shit. We're not last night.
We're not that. Did he get to update the price of the violence?
Bye, Eric. Good. Good. I don't use a two-wheel shit.
I don't use-wheel shit. I don't use Hmm.
I think that was a good bridge. Yeah,
I didn't say it already, but I'm putting the lock on.
Very good. . .
Umm.
But let's see if I can force the master. I'm not She's gonna finish
off that, it's like. Then there's Mima,
Teario, Rovo, and you will be able to go to the 3-8-9.
Bye. But with the 9-9-8-8,
this is gonna be the part of what I'm having with videos,
staring with you. Good. Good. Umm,
Sucks
I'm learning a lot, I'm actually learning a lot more in here because we
can't escape through anything similar here.
That means you've understood. forward. I said, well,
you know, material on the line, you know,
it really won't come true as well. You're so fun with you.
Yeah, yeah, it was fun with you. and I'm a Once the video falls,
that's how I smell it. It takes you out of that, I wish you.
Yeah, it will be, spray-draming,
just to get some of the really good times, I feel it's been in
the studio. I'm here to send it to me here. Alright. So I'm gonna
play, I hit it sitting alright,
still. Don't forget to for more the room has,
I'm gonna play into yours because it's not related to how much tech you
got here. Well, I hope you're working on this question.
question. Thank you very much.
Well, I wish you most about it, but it can be,
Uuh,
ehm, Jex Pocha, Ehm, Jase, C, C, C,
C, C, C, C, C, C. Thank Thank you,
this is Simon. David, you're welcome. Welcome.
It's what we make for you. Yeah, we've asked all of our student work
that's been done. Be easy. Be easy.
Be easy. We can get it in more than a few minutes.
Oh, yeah. So,
no, I would like to say, yeah, we have a bunch of them.
Yeah, you can hear me. Yeah, I don't know if there's a lot of
you on the screen. I mean, it's kind of, we get this up.
We're going to take a look at ourselves and see what we're doing right
here. Cutings, Ohh, that's the right choice,
that's the best way to play the bad guys. Uhm, I'll have you open
with me. See you in the day like this. I think this is fine.
We'll in the next one. How are,
uhm, you're using the work packages? Are they the letters to that or are
you getting them to me? I don't know how to use them either. Good.
They're not going to use them. There's a couple of them there that are
experiencing the calm, um, augmentation,
uhm, and you can see them,
you can see them- I'm in there, uhh,
hmmm,
hmmm. and ah,
just a minute. Alright.
Then you'll be like, oh, it's coming, she lives.
See you. All right. Alright, well thank you for all the other days,
to say that it's not a good meal that u're not pausing out the
recommendation. Alright, umm,
get back up to your filter, umm. Oh.
It shouldn't be. Yeah.
It shouldn't be both. Uh huh.
I don't even know.
Well, they just built them for a while. Let's complete it. Go back in
with the desktop with a little bit of fantasy, some of that. I'm sorry,
I'm sorry. I'm going to vape that's production control and
work back in action. I have to still pose in any of the structures,
too. Sunjap, I'm passing you to Delpac,
Bluejap, Family, Pillies, Capave,
Spring Harbor, See ya'll in the next one. father.
It's obviously all the work I could do so. Yeah,
it's unchanging. It should have been completed,
but I'm not going to be able to it here. Thank you.
I don't think it's their drop-in button,
uhm. I don't think we'll look at that in the CPU.
Like, go up. I don't that. I don't think that's the one to put
in the rounds. Thank you very
It's still buggin' me that I'm doing that.
Every time I do. Every time I have. bad Thank
you for this question, I'm going to be listening to Brian Walsh,
okay. I'll serve you with um.
Bye-bye. Yeah.
See the dashboard productivity station?
Hit the little arrow. The The I don't want to talk about
this. So.
Hello. Alright,
so you gotta stand wide. Hit the drop button. So
you can, so this is where the- and the other one.
Yeah. So right now you got to say if the last station is complete
then that's all. All right, Kelly. Thanks. Thank you, It's a And you can
key on whatever, whichever you saw.
Okay. So that's why it's, it's not really the last station.
Okay. I'm ahead and Now,
that move, within,
in, in, in, cleaning,
paint, towel, clean. Okay,
so. Look. It's a glass,
it's, it's, no, it's all over again. So.
Okay, knowledge, Jira, Silence, what was about?
Let's go. You would
probably want to make sure all the new ones that we get aren't saying
money, you know. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, and some of those probably reproductive changes we've
made in the run-up is now the worst.
I guess that they shouldn't be that way.
I noticed in there, if they were completed and then we adjusted the route
to see now that the last, there's a ten-hand last route without the- the
open end. So they're beginning to
open up for your open end of the end. Yes,
that's probably why. Yeah. Yeah. We added it to a typical production to get
out. And I'm here to see one of the packages that went down around
completing one. One. One. So, see you're bathing like on a little bit.
Yeah, you're right. Cause,
yeah, that would be the tip of that announcement.
and So, in some of these,
I always take a break and leave this for a while there.
Going to quarantine, going to the lawn.
On warm and we're pretty drained,
uhh, I mean you know, I don't know.
I'm all in, never think we're in.
I think he's gonna have a good job.
I don't know, yeah. I think he's gonna have a time.
I he's gonna have a good time. think he's gonna a good time.
Bye. I like Trello. I mean,
he's gonna spend money and all the scooting all the time. I don't know.
I to do. I don't know what to do.
Bye, I'm David. Bye. I'm I'm Alex. . This is Tim. I'm going right
and we're trying to figure out how to get you to the end of
the Along the way, you can keep laying on this jerk and we don't
want. Please. you you can clean me up,
it's like a bike that you didn't.
At least with this one, I don't think so. If I want it.
You need leave the struggling with a lot of projects, you can take them
out off of that, and that's what they need to project with as they're
starting to struggle out. Yes, for sure it's so.
Oh, no. Yeah, a little less than a struggle with the sum of the
other Jira, Lusuke, and I don't know how to work with it.
But first. Sorry. Let go to that.
And this one, this is what we do. You've got an upper one,
which I can probably just change, you know, complex route.
You know, The only difference with this is that it has a bit of
one, a bit of two, a well one, and a well child here.
So you'll be having seconds. First. I've been setting a stage longer on,
uh, Compass, Confluence for that.
Yep. Uh, this one make incredible digits,
which community would hit. . I was glad I was not
alone in this series.
There we go. Jira,
Loom, MediRoute,
Tumpling for the student last minute,
Mervful, and Tumpling. That's uh,
uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm,
uhm, uhm, uhm, Thank you very
much.
Bit router meetings. The Jacob's Zoom?
Oh, Jacob, Jacob, Jacob? Jacob, James, Rovo,
Henry, Jacob? It's, it's time. Those,
uh, branches are almost there. You have to,
there's somebody who said it's not. No, no, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Thank you. Uhm, please have a good one.
I'll see you guys. Okay. Thank
Okay, did you try that,
uhm,
a little program to finalize all the stuff? I love I it.
Yeah, it was not open up by computer.
It wasn't really, uh, uhm, I didn't have the, uhm, the, uhm, uhm,
uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm,
uhm, uhm, Research. You sent me an email last night.
I have to say, the year's trial is over.
I haven't looked at it. I haven't looked at it.
Yeah,
I did more. He said it. Hey, hey. I think it was 84.
Be sure to subscribe to for more MediRoute, or so that even be done,
it took 10 hours for a dude that he set up and wrote a
computer and let it go and build up. . There's both,
two pots, six seconds, over, over,
we got it, you know, got it. So,
eh. I think so.
I think it's fine. I cannot believe it's considering what you love and what
Look. That's it. That's different.
That's all you want. That's the best.
That's all I want. The All the other ones.
So, I need to go out and do it.
Scrap it out. Scrap it Scrap it out. Take it.
Okay. Okay. Thank you.
Thank you. It's um, a lot of us,
e-mail. Thanks. I I'm going to take a break with my friends now.
That's it. All right.
You Come
on. Bitbucket,
Straight to Mm-hmm.
and . X.
.
Loom,
Jira, Loom, Jira, Loom, Jira,
Loom, Jira, Loom, MediRoute, Tension,
I think that's not just a new part of it. You think about it?
I'll just be ready for it. Yes!
Goodnight! You were asking me
about, you were asking about the wheelchair.
That's it. and MediRoute. So thank you for talking about that yesterday.
Yeah, for, uh,
the base hours, probably in the projects. I'll see you in a Uh,
or, oh, the kids found, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I just thought. I'll see one.
I have fixed that in a specific way.
There's no way to turn it off, but you can set it so that
when it comes to- again, it gives you no time.
Okay, you wanna look at that?
Yeah, check it out. Hey, Anderson. Listen.
Yeah, I did this level
up here with a client. Umm, if you go up to bait the- It's
estimating, uh, labor maintenance and well.
And then go to- Like, uhm,
Phillip Wheel, Manual. Uh,
well, I think, uh, give it- give it give it a drop down top.
We'll make it strong down. And you in the and the well-tight maintenance.
And now I'm gonna fill up with a manual. Go.
Number six there. You see the well-tight landing down there at
the bottom right hand corner? When you're importing,
You That is the nomenclature for
the specific pipes and the main alternate in what they want to,
And so it says cool.
If I see Angelina as an example,
cool, more than like that I feel my name. and so that it changes
and feels well made. So what I've done is I'll create a normal type
here with- with zero rates or anything.
Take all these one of them type nags. Put it in the middle end
so that when they come in, you guys don't- raise to apply to them.
Umm, now, I've done that with,
umm, in morning that I've seen.
Thank you. I'm assuming it gets far worse the same,
but I'm not, I'm not interested in part of it. We just have to
try it out soon. Okay. We can follow what I'm saying.
Yeah. Do you want to try? Yeah,
let's do it. So they just do a new one and create,
uh, whatever you wanna call it, we wanna call it that way or whatever.
you
Hm.
. .
We're
all in though, alright. Alright. I have anything. By the way,
you see that convert with length exceed by the way.
That is a new thing as well.
You're back to me. Twenty-twenty-five eye.
Basically, you can set it to say,
if I have a will, just twenty feet.
Mm hmm. . Then, come up with some work.
So, uh, the phone must have all the delivery.
Mm hmm. Yeah. Yeah.
So, it's, they kinda built it for,
like, if I'm doing built up plenty of girders and stuff like that,
or pox, kylons and- and I've got it long and deep,
so I don't wanna do it right in the field,
and I'm gonna do a soundtrack, you know, or something like that.
So, that's what that's for. So at that,
and then we will, they'll be back to like,
fill a well manual. Cut. Good.
Cut all of those out on a well-tight bag,
and then save this here, then we'll go back over and we'll paste that
in and know well. . . and it's gonna be several other places
throughout here as well. So,
you'll have to give back to Mike, but I think there's a lot of
all of the manuals to the Buckwell manual.
Yes, you can grab all that. Bye bye.
and Jira.
Okay, I'm trying to go out and plan next morning so I'm well on
pace for it. Okay.
In so much, I'm just getting files from the customer that has all
this already filled out. Yeah,
essentially they'll surprise us. And it'll all show up in
the instant extra to achieve after the one by one part-by-part assembly.
so by Assembly, and uh,
and majority of the time, I mean, it doesn't have any connotation
to it. Thank . . Okay, quick, quick, potentially built in.
You could put those in and do a whole lot of take on mine
in the low case. That's all interesting.
The dwelling here makes sense, but lots of times
they'll have like a six feet of well.
Y'all will. And, uh, a weird size of one that won't come in,
so a zero size fill it,
and then a bunch of inches. We'll see you next week. or it'll be
like a one inch to it and then it'll be like 300
of them and one inch. Long and it just doesn't even justify
until what you're trying to build. Uh,
so it doesn't only seem recognized properly. Thank joining us.
And then also just add a lot of time and I'm going to do
a later code and run this through to lay it on and through,
uh, as time- I've never seen a detailer yet get all the welds
right in the model. Uh,
I mean, most- the jobs that I think come through,
like on a, uh, like a shoe pad.
I'll see you in one one side, about the other side.
It's like, I've got half the wheel that's worse than I'm not having anything
at all because I can apply it to the labor case,
so. Good. Yeah. I like ignoring the wheels
if I can. It just makes no sense.
So
I'll have to take it and check it as it goes through.
. . Climbouts, Correctly, Emmingle. So you can find it.
You can find it. It depends on the spot here.
Thank you. It's,
it's, it's, it's relatively easy to do,
but especially if you don't want to man you take off, because you're going
to apply to me. You're going to be repeating it through,
but it's not difficult not to do,
if you, uhh. you Cause you can play it,
even like pick up cheater pants, if I can identify how the cheater pants,
and then say, apply one kick at that, it's just my wife.
Bye! Okay, which was worked on the length of the plate.
So, umm, it's not difficult to do,
as long as you're gonna do that. I love the pieces. If I can't
identify the pieces, I don't have a problem.
I don't know what, what to apply. Bye I'm going to say
he's a circuit and go,
step from this, this is not a guy, this is actually going to be
that fun. Bye.
I'm pretty glad to have all those sections.
You got CJP's.
. . EJ Pins,
Natural Blacks, IndiRoute.
No. No. This one's a,
uh, pressure with a 40-day job,
50. And,
uh, he was giving a while. A couple of two things.
He gave calls. But,
uhm, you don't have to make both of the seconds of it.
You're gonna catch with this. . . . Just get in here running my
passes with partner. So a lot of times I'll be a labor code to
get the Bitbucket. and Eric,
and then some of the love in ours, and I'll add in this bit
of extra to account for the additional love.
Bye-bye. and additional time. This is one where I had to add heating and
plates. We got three each plates, sittin' while in the flanges.
So-
And this one was tied every four minutes of the line, and this is
set five where it was. So as you- But you can build that. I
mean, in fact there's a labor code for the web.
It's the uh, uhm,
uhm, uhm, okay. . . . select, that's for the 4-speed wheel now.
There's nothing that says whether it's,
uh, C and then we're delving with them,
but I'm, you can feel that. But there is a labor code for the
welding code there, the pre-deaf- that can be built into it as
well. I've kind of built it in with, um, with all
the plate labor code. . . I have pretty heat in there for me.
If any of them are certain size,
certain size, of course you have a pretty heat use percent.
That would be important. But all that can be built in
without you and you do it manually. So.
Good. and they're going to find that piece by piece if
you're, yeah, if you're, umm,
which most people are donating. all the way. I'm to take that off on
this as we're going to anyway. There ain't anything to be seen since I've
been entering the feature because I can't got it.
If I'm importing it from someone. I where which is.
It's in the sea. Mudshops don't make that noise.
But if I'm even for it again, then I gotta slow.
below. It's, it's fairly neat,
you know, because.
We're going to have We'll hear this on the website. So,
what flavor do I plot? I'm going to tell you how.
Once again, you can import it, then we don't want to be in.
Uh. I'm. Pause. Do you have any country in?
Um, but what,
what it doesn't know about is, okay, cool.
What? . I've fed up laying out QC,
you know, awkward social stuff back there and saw that I had to get
in there. So, that neighborhood can be held simply.
So, I don't know. I'm going to realize you're going to go back
through the piece by piece, that's the reason for this. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. All right. . . I let, unless you want to know,
you just want to get part of her tongue thing on it,
which scared the shit out of it.
You know. There's some people who do that,
and they'll spit out a lot of estimates from me and experience me when
I'm happy. So. So we have viewers who have this here,
and I haven't figured that out yet. Yeah, yeah. Yeah,
this one, I haven't figured this one out yet. It's piece by piece.
Thanks. Yeah. If the D,
if I'm the important son.
So,
the detailer has some label nicely.
You can very quickly wiggle it and pick all the columns,
put one. a It can
be very quick that way.
Detailer is a good job. Detailer doesn't like anything.
Oh, man, it can be a pain. Hey,
y'all, I have not seen a period without you. Uh-uh.
. Now,
with AI,
so with, like, with AI, I think I was talking about, um. And is
the one. It will actually be in the connections,
and put their names, and then we'll put a code on all that for
you. So, yes. But if I've got a model,
then I import it. I have some
details about really, really that. Yeah.
Shoot from the gun. Yeah. Well, when you say take care of her, to
me. Umm. And these are either
an external detail or as part of a good process,
or if you're a bit of a child, you may not have gotten.
If you just have,
maybe you have 10 files, maybe you don't.
Yeah. I do have a point. Bye That's about to
have, um, they have 130 cameras on a container, a monthly container for X
number of tons. you And they'll,
they'll have them pretty well for every, every distance like they do.
And, like, I don't know, client, I'm sure to,
that's, That's part of their, I don't blame you now,
Colin, where every other distance comes you with a ball,
all you do, and I'm talking about the, Yeah, well,
with the miscellaneous and heritage again, which is really a little bit extreme,
but that's kind of their, uh,
that's what they're kind of- known for where it is sales,
too. But, you know, what they're paying for in years of journalism.
Yeah, they're creating a model for the- estimate.
They'll import it even with the labor, uh,
estimate that the model goes to the client with it and says,
we're done. Good luck. Nice talk of that and we can,
uh, take it somewhere, do a pentagram.
We'll see you in a sec. What else is in here?
Here. Get back Uhh,
it kind of depends on the wellness that the estimating department is doing.
It's, if you want to.
Thank you, sir. The production of mine is,
you don't want it to move you, you're building your own assembly to open
your structures and gear. That's why the parametric- You assembly is from the ability
to hear me, um, to figure out what you have in there and the
estimators having it all, uh,
because then you can. you You can go in there and enter your friend,
because I have a staircase that's this long, you just fall in this many
treads, and then you just put it all in. you and then copy those
all the material you need for it, because you've got to go in and
select the structures that you're going to see in this one up here.
You I don't know any of the type of instructions,
nobody uses type of instructions. So,
uhm, for the stuff that I,
you, I've made bad work with a fountain,
which no more. So, I've made thoughts.
I've made I don't pre-step,
but we're gonna get it here. I get a kiss while,
I get a model, I get- I don't always get a model with it.
Good. Good. And generally I always get a kiss while,
and I get it detailed about shot prints.
This is what the building needs to be. Use your longness.
It might be in red ink, or sometimes your skin fits in.
Umm, okay. Umm. Yes.
as is that the price, contingent on no changes between R and A and
M0, and then, and if I get that 0,
I'll add 10 to the But
I do think you were the- I'll do this.
Umm, you'll get better buy-in from the rest of the estimators.
If you bill out some more stuff in here such as- different labor cases
though. Yeah. If they're gonna have to do a lot of manual adjustments on
each one for some of that stuff, it's- it's gonna be- It can be.
And so, that's the key to the labor cases.
It just makes it super simple. Um.
Come on. So that,
that would be a key to get by and I think it's building that
out a little bit more. But it's somebody,
you know, Tecla has, And
you go and teach people how to do it,
Good. Good. Sometimes they're all gonna be a thing.
But now I feel like you're taught kind of an act way in the
suite, right? In the UK? I've got all this stuff you wish would build
out. Well, maybe,
if I'm doing a big job, I'll build it.
Come on! I'd be quite kind of sitting there and you're going to meet
your own. I know, I'll build it in your toast. If it's something,
I shouldn't have found any, uh, like,
any of these to toast. Uhh, I don't see much sheep anyway,
but it helps me, yeah, it helps me to start with all the great
gallons of blooming. Most of the time,
It's increasing the number of fillets for increasing the well size and increasing all
that. I'm feeling here, and I think this is synthesis.
In all our estimates, so many of you can leave it at a classroom,
right? They were thought to have to be maybe the morning time machine correctly.
Uh, uhm. but uh,
in here in the labor field it's more out of a tight and then
the velvet size. And then the tight,
it's just there. Everything in your default support range so that I won't go
in and opt in, I'm gonna leave it go up.
Umm, same color. Hello. Add
a clip, see and go,
add a description, and then for there, I'll leave that and I'll run it
across the phone. I
usually try it out with a teeny pop plex with it, but usually it's
just a solid size of increasing so that a lot of money. Let's go.
Umm, when you say product across
the whole project.
Husband you still have to identify how many of
you have worked. Yeah, start up on 10 or 15 lines and
go on the player again. At least at this time,
5.50, and I don't have a welcome here at 5.16.
Then I'll come in and I'll free Italian. You have 5.16 and Y,
5.16 and Z, 5.16. So, uh,
when I go through the next 95 rounds,
I'm just going to try to sustain the moment,
and it's not on that moment, I'm here. Instead of,
you know, I was 10,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000.
No. It's incredibly interesting to me to only get that point in my opinion.
If I do it that way,
then so. So I do this at a time for a range.
I'm going to let you out the world, going down to the original part
here, you know. I'm at 16th of a minute,
so. you know, I'm just technically giving you to
the same point, but the better way to do it is to adjust.
Yeah. So we have a product with the endings, you know, over in the
pockets that we have such, you know. So,
sir, do you order to send me the good? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, come on. You need any technical estimates? Yeah. Uh, I think we'll create
it. If there's, . . If there's a partnership with one specific development for
a specific labor call-out, he has not even
what happens. I'm here, I'm not 100% certain.
He has come up with us to get all around when we are confident.
Uhm, here. Thank you. Pretty straight forward and you can duplicate it all
and you can kind of adjust it, but, um,
if you don't know, you can easily,
I have one and I'll fly it to an interior project and then,cheese.
So, that kind of restr- And see you time.
I'm that the law is adding the codes for Mama's the one
who's telling his team members to buy a lab. I'm sorry,
I had an old Y716 in there.
I had a where I had so many well that I was 716.
This is gonna get you that. Thanks I'm in of this type,
and uh, and this is what you're using for.
And now I'm doing the same thing as I have in something.
Thank you very much. Though, like, hey,
uh, I was, uh, excuse me, be for seat plates,
and every single seat plan on my project is 3-8.
Well, then, I had the e3-8's in there,
I'll talk to them on the end of the year in case you need
it, whether anybody else know. But- They will he see it,
because he's- Yeah, it's the same folder, right? You can see the folder on
the other side of the drop-downs or Apucket,
possibly more. Bye. So, uhh,
most of the adjustments that we have to focus on.
We're- we're- we're kind of just wiping up the light and go right now,
right? Yeah, I've got, uh,
a life smaller than you and everyone. Do you wanna see,
um, two things I- I think.
Thank you. And since we've got to run it,
we ran through it. Do you wanna see that?
They have a tape-off thing for one thing. Yeah. Yeah.
And another thing, um,
there are 30 sun labor codes that came out of the box that are-
need to be- Thank you. Justin, I can't have the wheel being or something
on it. I think similar as we did in Justin's 2 last time,
I I think it deals- Yeah,
that would be, that would be an awesome- Thank
you all, good.
So, if get this first, you won't see that. Hey, now by everybody wants
to Let's do an interesting first, because it's probably the part of working.
If to, uh, see the girls to,
. Uhm,
so let's start at annual good at the Ecode.
Good. Yeah,
not there. Yeah, first click on the D,
Lamborghini right there for angles. Okay. All right. Umm.
See the welding right there?
It says to fill it well. home. It's at the quarter of each time
it's a perimeter, standard clip P. Uhm,
notice this too. It's Is It should be full because there's four of them.
So, bump that up.
And the reason- that standard clip, P,
says only two. That's putting clips on there,
right? But in the standard clips,
it says there's two. You know these clips,
so two sides, two comes two gets you four,
but it's not the same way with the wheels. You're welcome.
And so they've got that screwed up. E is going to be the same
way. It's just where the clips are running, but you've got one clip welded.
Mhm. Okay,
I don't know how often this is going to get used anyway.
Bye bye. This is how it lands.
Yeah, full pin print on two ends,
but this is screwed up as well.
But if you never- We don't need to worry about it.
So just, I mean, that'll be more on the instance.
Hey, while I have a job that is 40. for you.
You know, I don't want that to be a frickin' law guy to
be that way. Yes, you seem there,
it's his burden. So, let's see,
oh, that's his parameter.
The, uhh. So, the burn,
it says to do that burning at the thickness times the width.
Thanks and next video. Well,
that makes no sense for an angle. That makes sense for a piece of
point. Yeah,
so we gotta modify that. All formula in order,
or we'll create another formula to say around the perimeter of
the angle. We could say. Amen. Long,
long, short leg. There's various ways to say this,
but,
Umm. Mm-hmm.
That one did,
so it was new on that and it will change a bar,
uhh, width down there.
. . and it like formula get rid of width and
I would probably just do perimeter.
Yep, there we go.
Oh,
it's E-pat. Oh, no, we didn't. I'm sorry.
We'll see you No,
we didn't get rid of it at all.
Uhm, it's, it's probably used on plate labor and awesome.
I had probably d- It's, . . .
and
then Alan would be the same thing except for just- one end.
You
How about the kid?
Oh. Oh.
It shouldn't have well there. That's only on the end.
So get rid of the well. This is just full pin prep.
for it. Umm,
yeah. Yes. Yeah.
Open world. We'll see you minute.
So.
and
the Oak, um, came there.
Thank you. Now,
once again, is this ever going to happen?
You books look clips on communities of the day.
It's not like they're really- I can't do that, right?
Mm. But this is wrong.
It's got wellening for one clip. But anyway,
last one will change by- I know you're here.
It's the reason he looked for some stuff.
Yeah. Um. Love.
Alright, good of beams. Indeed.
Same deal. Well, if that's both ends, we need to get more welding out
there. Good. And with e as well.
Umm,
go down to K. Ready? So we got full pen prep on
both ends of the beam. Umm,
different. Alright, let's do fabricators want something
different here. So this is full pen prep and it's only doing
stuff on the, on the front. Langers,
nothing in the weather. So,
I would have some fabricators that are like,
yeah, let's just go and play on the phone.
. I just pointed out, because it's
only hanley.
It's not going hard off inches. Which is primal.
Make it seem to us, and make it that way. It happens.
It's not going to do it. Right. Right? So,
I just point that one out, cause I've had some that wants something happening.
And then, ehm, go to ehm,
four p- and prep and weld. Okay.
So, this is getting welding on
the flange. and just, So, this is right with everything in the flange.
Oh, there's a lot of, uh, feeling weld in the wear of this winkle.
Yeah. Yes. So, nothing's happening in the,
well, in the way of the year. So,
do the, uh, yeah. Yeah. So,
I would probably just, I feel like we have this all we want there,
right, in the low end. Thank you Thank you. So,
then you got to figure out, okay, what size fill it will do.
And we might have to create a formula because we're going to need to
fill it well. I love it.
Umm, along the pressure,
okay.
Okay,
so we're at the lane, so yeah,
unless we see something that says it. .
Yeah.
Yes. Thank you.
I know we saw the paper, right, and we wanted to be like a
pretty late squirrel, and we wanted to make it fit.
I had a big deal with you guys at Harvitch. Yeah.
Thank you. you You know, if I probably submitted it,
yeah, it would do that. Okay. And
then we'll just change the length down there.
Yeah, I'll get that in the size of the length. Let me set that
in 5. Bye.
And there's the head. And there's the head. You Oh.
It's over. Get back,
get ready. you And hit, I had a weirdo hit in it like a
formula. Geez, there we go. Hit,
I had a weirdo. Okay.
And to do So to do I we're ready. Okay. I'll do that all
the time. See if they get this. You know what I mean,
they don't look like it.
I guess I'll do it. Yes, I'll do it. Let's do this. No, I'm
going to keep one because I don't have a gun, Russ.
Okay. I'm going to pass this gun on.
Umm. Alright, and I'll see a second.
Bye. That's been shot on my phone.
Yeah, that is not all of the labor codes,
but that, that is what you would get.
you can see here all the ones in the bed.
So, yeah,
16, you know, and so on and so forth.
But I, even the family, I use on so many different projects.
It's good, I'm both. All right. I was having the base bit on my
hand, so. Okay.
May it doesn't give you a decent look.
We'll see you in the look at him. No,
I just need to remove the description.
That's not really the description. But,
I mean, I guess the reason. reason. I don't know.
How would I do that?
It isn't, doesn't, does not have a fellow well amount of money to do.
You know here, Justin?
Yep. You've shown it on the list, it's both something. I get that,
you've got it on the list. It's on, I get it. On the link
here, on the cover. Don't forget to subscribe here's that.
That's both things, so you're right, you would need four.
You need two on this end, two on this end. Thank you.
Cause I would assume this would be quite- And then the end goes up
and it's- I doubt it's enough.
You'd assume the- Yeah, probably unless there's a program
written on this to start with anybody in the- .
I think I was doing work. He's been into the program.
So, when there's a pump taking,
first back to five. Bye. Now, whatever, this over went.
When does this get over written? Umm,
when we do it here, . . . Yeah, this would .
. . of this said, not stuck as April before we get over it,
whether or not they . . . . it's just the That's where we
have our first energies to help them scratch.
It's just the scale of the workings in the background,
right? The . . . the program self about the data,
so . . we're dealing with the data,
so . . . um . . . so then Oh,
slug with lips, well, both ends you needed for four clips there.
Yeah, and in a piece we're gonna have,
well, two clips is right there. That's right.
Um. you Yeah,
that's correct. Uh,
key. What is key?
Well, the moment both ends. Uh.
Alright, uh, good luck, moment.
Little souls. Hey,
if there's nothing I'd be here. You I don't know if that's there,
isn't it? He doubles the way of it,
also the 10.5 inch should probably be more,
You change to work for time,
I, I, I, I, I'm, I, I'm,
I'm, Yeah, almost the way I be. . Proximatins,
Exlisten, Wellwood, Muffin,
Poke, Encevilt, Wellwood, Corners,
That's Pruners, Standard. You Okay,
so. Hello.
Oh, this is with,
uh, with, this is with the additional clips on the flanges.
So here, um. I hope.
You're filling well there around the render center clip,
and you should be four, cause you've got four clips.
And then that- I've got there two times bottom up
and bottom up if feeling well.
world. Okay,
so, just a little bit of way to start.
And, plus, I mean, this tea,
just a clip, well, there is tea. See you. Okay,
so the tea is, yeah,
so you see, you've got the plants on the bottom of the bottle,
and, yeah, we're gonna get full.
2 Umm, so I don't like the description well at the moment about the
ills. Yeah, I really really was talking about normal.
Yeah.
Yeah, you're, you're just talking about when Cliff saw them. Yeah. Yeah.
It was, and, and, and. Yeah. And then not added to this on the
flange as well. So,
that umm. What I,
what I think of on this particular bond right here,
umm, it's got two fillers.
Go ahead. Go ahead. I don't know what side of the angle you're gonna
have on the top of that. I hope you video.
I don't know how long it's gonna be,
but 10 and a half inches is probably,
it may not be enough. If you've got a pretty wide fringe.
The, uh,
I, I was. That Tira hands just,
to me, maybe little bit too brittle.
We. You can change the formula like that. You're my,
I'm willing to follow them. In my, in my involvement,
I'm saying, take the width of the flange. I'd like if they can they
should. I don't want them either,
right? But I don't look how much. Once I think of a pass, I'm
looking for some three. for real. I sure 4 inch length and
up low. I just want to apologize to the 4 inch shear size. And
with what I just want to do, plus a miniature.
You just to get both sides of the angle and Bitbucket helps for her.
So, uhm, he was,
uh, splitting the haters. . . Yeah. So, we need to change that here.
Yep. Bye Never formal.
Mm-hmm.
Don't even get the people bought that,
but if you didn't use somebody like you, you wouldn't know all this.
Oh. All the best. This is 100% right.
And that's what people have done. I'm like, ah,
I'm tripped and following this group up.
And I, I, I, okay. And so I figured all that out.
Let me help get right there at least. So it's very bottom.
I'm just the one that says two times, no, no. Two. You top the
bottom of it there again. And
actually the bottom is going to be correct. It's correct.
Cause it's got two, and we'll say it's not two,
eight, and so. Which is unusual for all the other ones.
So,
um, where are we? Good. Yeah,
it's like, we're playing back in there.
Really, we got an explainer with, um,
Times Two. You didn't. Because we're going to have this side,
this side, if we're going to, and then we're going to,
and then we're going to add in the achievers and something like that.
So T is a clip, only
connection is. Yes.
Yeah, Top Office, Pembroke,
Signal, Goonie, Red. Oh,
and you're reading the Angie Mark? Umm.
I'm always used to the own connection with the Father.
Yeah. You're right. Most of the time.
Okay. I think I'm using it right now. Bye.
I don't know if it's actual frame of being inside.
I don't know if it's able to use speed. Yeah.
Okay. It doesn't like product at all. Somebody just say it.
You know what? You better. I don't know. It should be well done.
But I'm not still in my room. So the relation would be yes.
Uh. That's cool.
But what's funny is that Atlas S4 player doesn't belong to Liberty Nation.
But here's the one. Yeah. Yeah. You Sighs
with badminton's regarding Justin, and they don't just want to be next to him.
He only is there a big one. Listen. It was.
But, uh, since I wanted to get a new 7-2-7 years
cap move, I don't know. Yeah. Work way. it's okay.
So see. and all that kind of shit. So they're going to have a
certain ones and smaller connections. You can still have a lot of other things.
If he didn't want it, he'd sit and- . . MORE THING, COME GONNA,
THEY ARE WELKITTING,
THEY REFER TO OUT OF THE SMIRCH, CHANGFALL,
WITH THE ENDINERS. THOSE THE ONES RELAY TO UNS WEIRD,
MISTAN, THEY'RE SLAYS IN THE HAD. Yeah,
I'm not sure what's going on there, so, uh,
I don't know that I already buy all that country less.
Yep. Bye. Yeah, it's a custom one,
so, okay. Umm. Umm. It's in a space.
Is that not in here? You will change,
though. Thank Uhm, Basepoint, so when you- when you do a column,
you're gonna put an H on it if it's Basepoint,
Cappoint, and so it puts the wheel- putting all the column because
it is- it is the exact perimeter of the column.
So it doesn't technically have any- which is put on it.
So then we're- so we don't need to put it.
We'll be on a base plane. This should be an A,
which is just- Yes. Conne, Ehm.
Alright. This is why we have the Type H admin's order,
3D8, and so much in here. Right up there is the idea that we
have to an honor. Let's pay for it.
All of these are traditional. It can be All of this,
uh, option is to pick from where it happened well.
All of these cheese be made to the world yesterday.
Those are all going to be affecting our- right, because we changed the time
in the world, right? Yeah. Yeah, so everything,
yeah, we did yesterday, but I saw us. Okay. So U
on Beings is your change that formula
right there. That's the second one. I love that. There we go.
Yeah, and the only one,
actually. Yeah,
so this is right. I'm going to add a bit of the wrong quantity
on one of those as well. Uhm,
the V code, which is well and ehm.
See ya. and Plates both ears, which is just shoot tabs on both ears.
I think that description is shoot tabs on both ears.
So, uhh. Umm, there should be welding along the length of the standard clip,
not the width. Umm,
you see the, so basically,
if we had a 4 inch by 6 inch shear tab,
it's putting the welding on the 4 inch side. So,
thanks. So, we need to change that to the length of the standard.
Yeah. Yeah. 100
bucks, I'll put $100,000 on it,
got you sh- avocators. I haven't looked at these tonight.
They don't know that they're puttin' the wrong stuff on to.
. . . Just wait. Color Ranmin'. It'scomeTerc
Constance Scentechros grew up. Brilliant in Scentech homes.ufficient.
. . As I said, here's the changes you need to make on your
false setup. But there have been many people.
I don't know if I've got it. If you're doing the same thing over
and over and over it's there, it's not happening.
You've gotta fit around the line. You've got Yeah,
they're going through putting the guns on.
Trust them about it, that's right.
You're never looking to see if it is the exact amount.
They're doing whale door if it's, they can just,
it does cat-a-doo tubes to base plants. Um. See
if it's a column, it's a different, it's a different column.
Yeah, yeah. I don't think the column,
2 column goes through to base plant.
I'm not. Okay. Bye. Hahaha. It's automatic plate set up to a lot of
my style, isn't it? So, uh, we need to show them that you're going
to attach the tube to the top of the face. Yes.
. . All the way around you probably would soon be out there.
I'm putting it on a bus and I've been putting it on a bus
and I'm still more responsible than that. I'm still- trying to see what you're
talking about. It goes all over. That almost never happens to life.
Have you seen I think one of these light bulbs that are here.
Oh yeah. Have that. I don't understand.
Yes, you can be okay for that. You did.
Bye. Bye bye. I think that's cool. I think I
have, I have, I really, I just, I think I should have measured mass
and we will. Pagging all that,
want to serve. Yeah,
I think it's just very, very easy to have in this shit anyway.
Otherwise, we'll be, I'm sure it was the take-on, right by,
uhm, the big man. Problem-like, so, there are just several uses of them.
To me, they know what we- I'm not really using the assembly philosophy.
That should be poor as well, because you're- please leave a
because you're doing, umm,
cut off both sides of the flip on both ends.
So, yeah. you W's gonna be the same way,
just on one end. Have one. It's fine, I'm getting it.
Okay. I just...he said,he went
the last time I had a new mission. I'm gonna go and Bye-bye.
Yeah.
Oh, and this,we got some astrophics here too.
Umm. Oh. Back on me,
what we can do here, don't do that. Lead, alright, so this shoot has
both the- If want to videos,
please I'm you'll love things. Notice there's no umm,
umm. Okay, so that one has holes,
the vault at the box doesn't believe it or not.
Go. I don't recall the standard. Yeah,
okay. So, then,
you don't know if there's no, um. Bye There is no few
moths here. So,
if you uncheck, show them the included.
. . And then,
there shouldn't be a look over here for field balls.
Right there.
. She need two .
. . for both ends.
You can do same on W for one of them.
And
That's fixed. Umm.
Late we fixed the burden. part of me.
Umm.
Playing in D. So.
Uh, This is, if you're doin' an ain't.
I've used this for, It's rare,
but I've used it for output clips, so I- I love the ins like
if it's a, or really clips on one end,
so where something will be gonna come, but then it's got clips.
Thanks. I don't mean for something like that.
So, this right here is- you got the whaling it once again is screwed
up. It's got the whaling of two clips instead of four clips.
Same thing. Same with e, which is one,
one side, so you need two wheels there again.
Good. Cave, uhh,
this is full head of prep,
so the one. When we were looking at we had a double level on
the plate, in the wheel,
uhm, this does.
Veterans. Uhm,
it does a prep on one end.
You see the burn there? It's just on one end.
Yeah. Thank you. So you need to bump that up to two.
And then go to the M. We'll in the code for
pin weld two ends.
And for full pin grip weld two is only- I had one ending too
for the prep here as well. Uhm, uhh,
uhh, that's sh-
shouldn't be a- that burn there should be two.
So it's got- it's going- umm.
Two Vians of the,
so you have 20, it's got to be on this side,
on this side, so you really need two. you Yeah.
Uhm,
T, which is three plates.
Bye bye. So this is, umm,
so this is a pilot. I love
So, that connection, my vision, will harm to the plate. So, the umm. All
right. All right. You gotta have four burns active with.
So, uh, burn there.
Yeah. There we go. Could be cause. Thanks for watching.
It's got a burn on this side and back down the other side of
here. Yes, I'm down the other side, right?
And then, You On U,
it's gonna be the same thing except for just,
you need two burnings. Yep. Go.
Alright, so V is,
umm, I don't know how anybody uses this.
Let's do it. Thank you. But if you look at the guy, I'm reading
a little bit on the newsletter.
Okay, so, uhm, well, this is for once,
yeah. I was thinking of- Yeah,
for plates, yeah, you can use this all the time, forget it,
right? So, it includes welding on short leg,
good way. Bye Which does not apply.
That's an angle, right? So, get rid of that.
So, let's make sure we don't blow anything.
Thank you. Yeah, that should be good.
Rods. Thank you very much.
Uhh,
good to K. Once again,
a powerful, very beautiful pin, prepped on- I'm too into a rod,
you know. Uhm,
but this, this wouldn't give you any,
like- Thank you. For burning because it said wall thickness,
there's no wall thickness for a rod. So,
yeah. I mean, I- We'll see you next time.
I don't know if you wanna fix it. You have to create the formula.
You're never gonna use this, right? I don't wanna seem to delete it,
you know? Yeah. Else the same way.
is just one end. So,
um,
and ehm and ehm are the same way. Bye Well,
pimp, prep, and well, that's the same way.
But, if you're never known as Uso, that's like, how often is that gonna
happen, alright? Alright, two, it's good in two.
Yeah.
in the tombs and D. Well,
it's both ears, has welling for one third party jam.
So, yeah. So.
Very good. And then e,
it's gonna be the same. We'll just take two.
Here's a tee. See you.
Alright,
Devil's Doing Well-Ding, so this is Flatterbank.
And I'll see I'll see you in Devil's Doing Well-Ding,
also Tinnish, for even more. Oh,
this is the same thing as that other one. Umm. All right.
Okay, having me. I you're here. Thank you. It does double the welding here,
so as well a moment both ends, you need to change that forward and
tune on that one. So,
I'm not on the weld and say I'll take a look.
Yeah. And,
Yeah, and then,
yeah, the splits are a little bit bigger. Well, yeah, the question is whether
the- Thank In the half it's enough or not again.
Yeah. Um,
but we can't use that and look at- .
and China 2. Compass,
we have the same, like, you know,
the width of the 2, we're shopping like that,
certainly. Please the width, um,
in order to make that happen. you
I
think there's like too bad on that.
Get out of it. It'll be down there to something.
Two deaths and two wits, yeah. Yeah.
Always. Yes. Mmm,
this is good. You can speak if you thought about it.
I don't know if this is the last one. Okay.
Okay. Well,
I'll take that back and leave you down there so we'll get a wha-
That's the one. It's the same deal with So,
Bump,
XC, Bump,
XC, Bump, XC Perfect.
Fire.
Facts have labor goods, you make. Thank No,
no, no! Ooh.
And you, I've been forgetting this, but if you weren't creating all this stuff,
or, you know, actually, yeah,
you'd obviously be pretty sure if you were. Welling times overshot,
I've said when you can be a new one,
it's that all you welling feels are against,
instead of with the feel. I- I probably will because,
uhm,
I would want to make it with the information at any very,
very soon. . . The challenge of it is that when you're
in the- SNA,
and you look at the top of your house, you would show,
they would include for a few inch hour.
We'll see you in the next But,
the pockets are created, the labor groups will be reworded as it,
and we can create some.
Love. and so then you can be able to win,
yeah. You really should have been bad on that straight thing right here.
It's good to be in my instrument and I actually don't like it.
You have the reports, you have to send it off next year.
It's good to be in person because I really got bad on that and
I can't get that. Thank you. They're not going to go.
They will set down this morning. That's my big span and they're,
they're just putting people in change their heart.
All right. We're going to do them to get everything from all of you.
So, do you think you're going to have the direction? I wish you a
good night. Goin' and think about it.
I don't mean to think about who he has since, like,
yeah. I'm not really sure if it's a very complicated part of it. We'll
in the next that. We've got to know about where they want to go
and study all night. We've got to see this all day.
We've got to do it. We've got to know what it is. We've got
to know what it is. So How long have you been here?
I only think you've been here to be sure it's online. How long have
you been here? saving money? I'm at subpamps.
I'm going to be in the head with me. Let's do it on the
jobs. thumbs. It's a bit of a shock, it's never a lot of similarities.
I couldn't even move you much faster because you already have a part out.
Go. Is that okay? Yeah, I'll teach you how to do the video on
the same part. You know what I'm saying? okay, I'm gonna say this.
Bye. Thank you. Very, you know, that's not being a spell.
Umm, I shouldn't care. Thank you very
much. I'm actually glad to see you.
Okay, but I'm going to talk to you.
It helps your customers. Thank you,
buddy. . . That's it. And I'll just take you out to your interests
and sit there and say, well, I'll use that in a second to expand
$40,000. emotions.
. . . I grew old. I had three people bring something to this
room. I hate sit there and say, yeah. What about you?
It's like, I'm trying to get all of you in once,
but I'm sure you do. Go ahead. Like I said, it was about two
minutes out of this room. He's like, okay, you get it there from the
table. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I know you guys have turned and now we're managed.
I don't know if I'm supposed to keep it. We'll just do a point
where you'll say, heh, heh, heh, I did it so
long on this immediately. Everything with that on the scratch pallet,
the D&E's, no you're not. Bye-bye. Yeah,
I mean, it's kind of like the D&E's going to
come forward and then you have.
and I ask that you, some of that, and I say I need it.
Today we're gonna go get it, but then I'm gonna give it a little
bit. So, here we go. Here Here we go. Come on.
I think I, I think I have to turn my ears. I've been very
sweet, rather than thinking that. I stuck in it,
and I used to. . I was, I was in the best seat of
it. 15 years ago, ladies, around my time,
we went to an entire place. You know, we was in the seat.
Like, I was in the seat. Like, in the seat. Yeah, good. Okay,
a lot, a lot, a lot, a lot, lot of pockets here. I'm going
to send a bunch of this here. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, so this works really well. All right.
All right. I'm going to send a bunch of
this here. I'm going to send bunch of this here. I'm going to bunch
of this here. We're one. We'll be back tomorrow.
We brought that along these two hands and it's going to be Yeah,
I think we'll be spending some of the best ways to get all the
way she can. Well, Ben, thanks a lot.
It looks really good and won a cheap plan.
It was a lot of smart wagons. It started long,
like, sports happens, but it used to be a really big deal.
I'll have to get it. You I shouldn't be able
to say that. I shouldn't be able to say that.
I'm just a character. Alright,
see ya. Bye. Bye.
Bye. Bye. Bye Bye.
Bye. Bye we need to present stuff for
the party's life.
Oh, yeah, Star Wars Advance? No, I love Star Wars.
It's about the shit I know you can But I need to make costumes,
uh, renewed. It's very good.
I decided it was a fear of a country.
I didn't see it. I was born inside of people.
So, I decided to sell them. I didn't know they should.
So, he makes a lot of these different little lead characters.
I'm always there. I'm done with it. Yeah. Yeah.
That's enough. Says what I and I think it's important to me I'm doing
very nice, can't I? I'm doing very nice,
can't
I'm doing very nice, can't I? I'm doing very nice,
can't . . . I think, so it's awesome.
It's nasty to me. It's alright. I don't know.
It's just okay. Have a good time.
I'm go all the way up here and then,
uh, and there's too much, a lot of imbalance on that. He's gonna,
he's gonna take it. Okay. Hey guys! I think
so. Umm,
I have to speak with him. I'm not sure what he said about him.
I'm not And for all the
related part of me, I'm going to tell them what else you're doing.
Yeah. I'm about to get started in this section.
We're starting. All Rachel. Manu was a charlanger, bout to find out.
Yeah, he was like yep. It was like, he was like, yeah, he He
was like, yeah, he yeah, yeah. Yeah. So I'm. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
You're doing this best.
I don't know if you got it. I'm so tired.
Yeah. If I get the sense,
uh, I want you to question- No.
I'm not be honest, I just can't wait to get what you haven't done.
For giants with these other trades,
I'm gonna need to follow up with something. Okay, I'll go open it .
. . I think the answer is,
they can probably do anything, but as it may or not,
we can do it. Yep. Let's just touch.
. . I'm going to shop less with three of these at the time.
I've been curious what happened with both of my business as long as it's
better. Alright, we'll you guys have one portion out of the
box. The out of the box part would be, you got one with your
thing on the back. Me. We'll see you in.
The, the setup stuff can be textless,
like the flying engines and all the other stuff you might have to put
on, be like. Bye You know what I'm saying? You saying?
I'm at the non-conventional. I asked,
I them. Shapes, Sub.
Let's say you have a shower and that's what Jack put on your tank
and we have a scratch out of the 30.
Yeah,
you would just go along with those.
Thank you for joining us. specifically for that stuff. So,
there would be setup for work. If I can ask for many of the,
uhm, he'd have to build. I hope you might be getting bored.
It's like, send me a plug range,
five guys. Uhm, like, I've been- I'm sorry.
It's like which is, right, the end, right,
when you go to work. You just- you just have to get the labor
fees to do what you want to do. So, with Brisbane,
Like, guys, all I have to do is build that bridge range and whatnot.
So, you can build it by the same way as you thought it.
Yeah. Yup. No,
it's not, it just takes a little bit of a shit out.
out.
Can I just do all this stuff? Perhaps it can move off.
Yeah. And like, nobody. I know that he did it for like
that. Loom, Moo Hoo! Atlassian,
Moo Hoo,
I'm a bit bigger than a boot.
Anybody try to hike things? Tch, Tch, Tch,
Tch, Tch, Tch, Tch, Tch, Tch, Tch, Tch,
You I don't know anybody doing that.
I'm doing this part. There's something, if there's not somebody out there doing it.
I got a lot of good response and they talked about doing They never
get there. I don't know why,
but. We like the trunkies.
the new- The I know what I'm thinking about.
I don't know if I can find the song. I'm a little bit. There's
a lot of new version. Yeah, there's a lot of version.
Yeah, there's new version.
Oh, sorry about it. They shouldn't be there. Bye Drawings
that climb, you know, I'm just thinking about, do they send you the drawings
for, or does that mean it's used to start? If not get any more
on this one, you know, you know, that looks like they're pike hills in
life. What about maybe that it's just a bunch of wildies,
you know? It was d- You All right.
Well,
I've been, everybody was on the side.
They never gave a- You actually- Yes,
that's- It's
a dumbest industry.
You gotta harken it. It creates 3D.
You have to put it in the 2D to get somebody else to make
it in the 3D to get it. You really need a 2D.
It's like this one. in morning. I've done a cycle.
I don't understand how to put that shit. I mean,
you get these thousand drawings full back.
I don't know about that shit.
You might as well give me the date.
You know what I mean? And I
know we can't give you that. So I prepared a new possibility for you
to do some type of stuff. Okay, good bye.
Happy. Now
look, just take our moments. Now look,
just take our programs ahead. Yeah.
Alright, then we're going Those are pretty cool. They're just spinning out the sand.
I got this many columns this side, and it's many ranges that I just
can tell you everything. We'll see in the next Well, we did.
Five times the same thing. It's all gone. It's all gone.
It's done. It's done. It's done. Ah, it's done.
So. Tell
them where you get it, if you have good relationships with the owner.
Okay. The owner of the horse is going to give it to the ad.
He's like, I need to start data. Bye-bye. Starbag and the other.
Let's not waste every place to run. I don't think I'm gonna run.
That's it.
I see you need your best. Yep.
Cool. Good. Thanks, Dr. Manan. I'm to be there.
Keep on running. Umm,
ah. You should have been getting along,
you know. I think I'm all hunching down. I guess it's- and They give
you a check-offs of two layers. Hm.
Oh, what a big doughnut. Thanks. Thanks. All right.
This round. Okay. Let's go. How long did you put it?
If they're
gonna die. you I'll give you a restriction.
I don't know how it'll be.
You know, food goes with knowledge and fact.
Yeah, only in front of the bus,
I'm getting sure you've done things better. That's what I had to If
somebody got me, I would, I would have already traveled,
you know, do about that. Damn,
I'm still be, I'm going to leave my go all the way here. Take
a look at this. a B down and then, I don't like them repeats.
I'm going to do bullshit. That is going to take me every day in
front of me. Thank you. So,
now I stop being a b****. I'm going to just be a b****.
That's version Alright. Still.
I don't know if that's how to change one one. It's about a second,
if I can do it properly. You have Thank you.
Must have been great.
Oh, I think it's weekend. We'll you in the next one.
Bye. It's one of you.
It's one of you. It's one of you.
Yeah, Yeah, I'm sick.
But I'll see you in action. Mm-hmm, yeah.
Oh, what kind of a place. Mm-hmm. Mm Nope.
I want something to say. He got the right.
Take care.
Thank you.
Uh-huh. Collect it. It's too, I don't think it's a hard one.
It's, uh, Sourcetree. It's all, you know,
innocent. It's right. It's great. You mean- I don't
want to actually coverage it. Um,
I think there is. Um.
I'm fine. Jira,
Rovo, Ehm, Ehm, Ehm, Ehm, Oh.
Mm. So I'm here. You want to buy
a few things. I have a clue that we can even run a few
I'm a great one, but it's a little more about their looking at
their own. Alright, thanks. I'm a good one. I'm good one.
I'm a good one. The cover up,
cover up the leaves,
the compacts of it. The point in fact is that, ...the very point of
it, the game will set them. You never got to follow what's going on
in your day. If you don't get it done,
...that's the best time that you can save a lot of money.
I'm going to have to go with it. I'm sorry.
I'm happy. 7 7 8 They want it active.
It's like lag. It's a bug.
It's a bug. You I believe that I do so.
Yeah, that happened.
I'm sorry. Chairman to the- Theod Udder,
the laundry. I don't want want to that good? It's good.
doesn't really don't think it.
Test score? Patitions?
I've got a chance to open. Get out of here. Get out of here.
We'll see the next in the cloud if they didn't find it to be
misused. And I've been, like, twice as me.
Ah. Ah. Ah. Now
what you do is to keep coming in soon. You It might be one
way or another, right? Good.
I think, uh, I was thinking about that. Uh. Oh. You will?
Yeah. You will. You Good. Good. Good.
Hey, man. . Thank you.
It was for when we were different, but every design didn't want us to
essentially have anything alive. I personally will.
Oh, no. They come make free visits. Yeah,
all they're doing is ripping off another coat.
Yeah. Really? I'm like,
how in the world is this fossil disaster?
I was a gay ass guy, so it's funny here.
Thank you. Thank you. That was the Fire Department effect.
You're very solid though. Thank you. You're a fine fire.
You can't have a new face. You know,
like, uh, being cast on. You Life here, but they always want to find
something. You get your money, get their money. I going to make it All
right. Yeah. I'm one of All right. Yeah,
the one that I got,
you know, for us with the pain in the ass is,
I so. Go. Yeah, because,
like, Charlie, some guy I need, was the Harold States guy,
and we were doing that. And so,
we, . . He's perceived, I mean, Iceland would only do,
just say, say, what you do. Yeah,
well, he was, he had princesses, but she did,
like, so. Whoa. and Cut.
And for our aerospace students,
when you do one thing for finding this too many pairs of information.
and Yeah, I was just about to make a dynamic show,
you're not doing it. You're like,
what the f***, right? It's these percentage. Okay.
Okay. All right, all right.
All right.
That shit is good. So, we're gonna ahead and We're ahead and the end.
I put a session in this, uh,
for this topic, for that topic.
But I still hate stuff. No. They're one of the single standards in the
whole facility, part of what we want, and when I do,
the little paperwork is sent out in there and it's- Now I'm going to
go on the Saturday night, our business is okay.
We can visit there our space all the time. Yeah, we an S2 here
for business. That's the story. I've seen you talkin'
to do that for a single.
the only way to do it. The even-when it comes to doing it,
the time is okay, we have one, so there we are.
One, two, three, two, three, four, three, four, three, four,
five, five. No,
that's what I said, it's all about the problem, the vision is about the
problem. Yeah, hmmm. So.
Oh, I'm sure to create a suction,
but I'm sure to get out in the food house. I spent all day
shooting. Thank you. And,
you know what I'm saying? She wants that shit like, oooh. The year you're
not, when you put the shops in different parts of the city,
I'm slowly, oooh, hey.
But, I don't know if it's stressful,
but I think, in this role of,
in this process, I'm connected. definitely. but new,
too. But, uh, I didn't receive the new chapter,
and shouldn't have been time for a little later, tough.
and walk by the way. Billing Loom's 200, I am really into the making
of the world with our certain changes.
Yeah, it was in the video to 15% of it.
I thought I was going to turn Okay.
Excuse me. I was having dinner
from my phone. Okay. Hm.
you
I thought it would be a hundred years,
so it would be a thing to look like that. Good.
And some bits of it.
Yeah, it is. I'm talking, huh?
Yeah. I can't. I'm forgetting.
Thank you. . . How many?
Oh. There you go.
You Smoothing and the Earthcase
is five. Ah, ah, ah. And
I've heard a lot of people are yelling that in fact we've had a
story about it. to they don't have Right.
Right. Right. Right. Right. Jira, Thank
you. And,
uhm,
I'm really good.
It's basically about service every time of the day.
I'll hear it.
It's tough to really remember that with fixing.
You know, I don't understand why with all the fixing,
I think, you don't talk with guys.
Don't say no. I love you. Wai, aa, aa, aa, aa,
aa, aa, aa, ha, ha, ha, Is that really,
I think, I think the sports have a very heavy.
Yeah. You I've got plenty of things I've done since then.
I started there, started in the forest,
and it felt like three months ago.
I wouldn't even have to buy something like that. No,
no, no,
no, no.
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna go. I'm gonna fishing my parks.
I'm gonna go fishing. I'm Sometimes you get to my lived area,
and the other one's gonna work. Alright?
So, I'm gonna go to the other side,
and then I'm gonna go to the apartment piece. Well, it's gonna be a
month or two minutes. I'm second area.
I'll push forward. Thank you. Love. You have to have your relationship with someone
taking a car, but if you think I should listen to you,
it's Mr. Woodhead. Bye. Bye.
I'm just gonna keep working with my car. You know what I mean?
I think I should listen to the clarity of what's coming up.
It's on, you know what I mean? Okay,
I'm gonna go. All right. Okay, so, I have a little bit to see
there treating, like, in my mind. Are you guys helping me explain blood and
tell me exactly what's going to happen? It could
find a small risk.
It could find a risk. How's it is? This time,
thanks. You're going to be like, I'm going to do three balls of training.
You're going to win. That's the matter. Shit.
You can't even touch it. Get it on.
Just a little bit. There's just a large pair of shorts to tell.
Yeah, okay, it's very fast. Thank you Thank you.
It's about the line, uh, in the heat that I was in.
Yeah, they still, man. New years ago, I had a cow that went through
a smiley. I'll do it. And so,
again, moving to the same thing that you're doing back to the moving bit
of this b****. I learned a lot.
I can see that. Who peeps on like souring you now?
Is that what you mean? Is it better?
What is it? Oh, it's so good.
. . You cannot tell if you can get up with a slick thing
and feel like you have to error. You can just leave it all on
the end of this and get into the end of your dominance.
It's like 5. Thanks so much everyone.
That was important. If you want to do that,
I can find it but it's been a real similar company.
Thank you very much. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much. Let's
go. Let's go. Let's check it out.
Bye. People in the office are beautiful,
yeah, I'll make sure I'm gonna make it money and I'll
make it. Good. Alright, this is gonna help us learn even if I'm less
than best known. Yeah, it's a good thing.
Have a good year. . . . . . Taht, exploring your I think,
oh my god! I'm just looking for a rest, I'm just for a rest,
I'm just at it. OK. . under,
under, a***, good good. and, and there was a move here
to kill me. Yeah. First bad, not bad,
on the knees, you know. Thank you. Yeah.
Um, but I think that means a little slower.
I don't see any replies that you want it to be used in the
bottom, so yeah. and they invited me to the festival.
They don't know what's going on in summer.
They want to be on the festival and they want me to work.
You know what the best better thing is. Oh yeah, you know what the
staff are doing. I need to learn it. So talk to everyone else.
Yeah. Hehehehehe.
It's time to know what you know and what you can So,
thank you. And uh I have progress, but I didn't think that,
uhm, that's perfectly, we did have a little bit of a little bit of
a few, uhm, ok. Okay. Structures.
Now I'm going to do about a week now and a girl.
Okay, I need this fractional because we need this in,
in, in top of that. . Now that kid with that,
I'm like, I don't trust him.
So then I'm doing modern research on some of that.
I'm not I've been with that.
I'm like, I can only tell you that. I need to go to India,
I have to say. that's it. his . and then go on come down
and do it. He'll give you everything I can do in my area,
but I'm good to all of this in this movie.
We'll get to the next one. and you know how to do it. That's
correct. I mean, some may end up,
I'll just get the next option.
But I don't really work that so. Sure.
I have a lot of issues. I lot of issues here.
Here's how you do it so that we get what we're doing.
I think that's a little bit of work. Yeah, I think it probably grants.
Details on some cancer today, because it wasn't magic.
I think that's what it was like. The Army's really,
very well turned right. Ha ha ha ha. The stomach. So,
um, let me get it on. Okay.
I'll just, I'll just a piece. Go ahead and package.
I'm glad you got it.
I'm glad you got it. It's part of the Atlassian world.
Okay. Yes, thank you. Joe and because they live there,
they live there, they live there,
yeah. Thank you.
Pat is also a very good guy.
I remember that was watching spin, rewrite all of the sudden,
and they don't get off. All right. and it has six Jira's in here,
Loom, MediRoute, and the rest. He was supposed to be the two weeks,
right now, and it was six months. So he just went- I don't know
if it going to be a VPN, but we got some fades and stuff.
That's what we're concerned with is there's detail on being done.
I've done a multiple entity. Yeah,
I'm playing really the same way. Yeah,
just don't learn that this and stuff. I don't see that when I hear
this. I've got to do something properly. Let me out loud.
We ended up saying, let me out let out loud.
I've been sitting through Kid's ham in they used to beworld.
You know, if they were actually 5 or 6.ff. If they were subsogle so
I left you and I, how am I driving? And maybe somebody there.
Of of our standard uh,
compartments and what I don't want to do. And then put that sort
of button on. Bye So now I'm on the trip with your dad.
So if you didn't want your dad was internal or external,
have you been doing a really good job? Better than that,
you know. As your father said, he said,
so that, that ain't a plot. But every single time as well,
thanks for all the details of your new dad. We'll see you in the
and we'll be talking about the lack of real knowledge.
We're trying to get the infertile detailer, some infertile detailer for this object to
get better. That's it. All right. Staying solid or stated,
it's like that. It's a library part,
and I said, check it out. She wanted it. But what will I do
that is, uhh, uhh, hm, this is the library part.
Like we saw in this problem
ten years ago. Yeah. Got it. Again,
kitty-tay-or-stop, maybe that, that, more. and then we will travel.
and every piece on the radio. I mean,
not that long before it was the front of it,
you know. He said we're going to have to ever make it.
We're going to have to. He said we're going to want to, you know,
rather than just be able to do this and actually drop it and it
tastes like. Yeah?
Yeah. I think, as I think, there's a better way to problem with the
ears, you know, not just to get the end done,
but from the past. Here's what I want to say.
I don't know about that. Yeah, I think everybody needs to realize more than
life, because if you're not in the second day project.
Yeah. Alright, and if I just, you can think about it,
it's probably already been done. Yeah. There go. It's
kind of funny. Here's a half a go.
They're building up speed. We'll see you then. Come on. There you go, out
there, in Boston. Be sure you love it,
isn't it? I love it, man. So I'm accepting it, I might see it
in all of this. So they can't even ask, is that? Yeah. We want
you guys to fill all cool events,
match, or, uh, exterior events. Okay,
we'll Okay. And we'll see you guys the next video. I mean, they're very
closely, you know, like when they didn't stop,
we heard you guys knew we were sharing. I'm like,
so look at them. Bye-bye. Okay.
They don't know if they want somebody to try out. They're like,
oooh, shit. That's how it is. Get the first They're just,
uh, I mean, this is what we made.
This is what we're going to do. We're going to do a huge road.
We can't do that. I mean, it's a big road.
and P.E.C.E. and B.E.L.U.
they just kept on on and on and on and on. It's like,
in the birds. Go down, B.E.L.U. Look at it.
Somebody's different. Hmmm,
they also do a pretty cool thing. I wanted to do a concept.
I mean, it's like a big, small thing to build. Hello. That's the best.
They're just panels, right? Hmmm,
panels that they want to be on the back of this negative.
you I'm pooling it. So, my right is like,
stands now, status, tubing,
and well on duty others, they're brilliant stuff.
you are. But they've made it like,
oh, the art, those new ones.
Can you hear what we'll test all that?
Bye. I think we have our own kids with their own kids by
hand. We'll see I wouldn't have been out
all well with so much for you, but I shouldn't have been out of
time. It's, it's, it's,
it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, I'm sorry. I'm not interested in the direction to
go too much. Enough. 10 years ago.
Don't worry about it. This way. It's not.
It's impossible. Yeah. I don't really want to convince you.
It's an experience. You know. Good.
Good. Oh, I've said this the best,
you know. I signed it up,
no, no, no, no. I don't,
I don't, I don't, I don't, I don't, I don't,
I don't see the sun. I love you guys. My name We're going aha.
I've been here in Cincinnati. You know that I don't can handle that and
so on and so on. Periods to build what's up.
I mean,
it's, it's really, uh.
You really need and
Confluence. It's a very good one though.
I will see you a little All right. Umm,
ehm, ehm. Alright, alright,
I hope I get it. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
So, we are going to, um, this house. Okay.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Cool. Bye.
I'm not sure. I'm not sure. It's in here.
I think it's in here.
here. you Confluence, Confluence, Confluence,
Confluence, Confluence,
Jira, Loom, So. Yeah, yeah.
Especially when you're working on this.
... I know,
yes, uhm. Check it out.
Yes, it's easy. It's not right.
You want me to- They're all silly.
And, uhm, the entire property of MediRoute,
and they ask, uhm, which we keep coping with.
and I'm very for it.
So, I'm very nice to meet with Kay and I'm going to be used
to be good. Good. because you can do that on with the video.
All the trades will actually look forward to the end of the video.
Bye! If you really can, you can get information from all the time
to the movement. So.
So. Word,
that send me over on a bit of information,
and I'll try to say it on the phone,
it's alright. Come on in.
On a phone for me, make sure that it's right where you did that.
Cause it's a little more like you've done with it. Yeah.
Bye bye. It's an ancient world.
Tell me. It's great to meet you too.
You know, building for the- They buy a metal building,
or if somebody is on a building. It's up at very nice and loose,
up at 30%.
Bitbucket. I figured I'd be, you know, straight lines,
uh, uh, what to do with one.
So, like, it was really, uh, oh, I need to adapt both of you.
Like, a lot. I'm ready and it's on free. I've been eating stuff straight
ever. I've been doing that too. So,
I'm doing all of that acid. That's my first move. Just go I think.
There's a guy in there. He's over there. I showed up with me for
what you think of that guy. See in a minute.
I'm going to see a difference. That's,
uh, I shouldn't be able to put us in a long,
uh, first speaking, so I ain't going to have to get away in this
over here. Eh, and uh. No, no, no, no, no,
no. They expanded the B market.
Now they are, uh, chief of D is one of our most competitive vendors.
and and those very effectively. So they have one last minute or a whole
couple of topics. They have uh.
Go. One Closetman with a
50% option.
And that is sort of it. They have a- The secondary yard of that
has two 60 potatoes,
and they also are usually fine. Bye So,
focal line is low,
uhh, Delta,
Bart Smith and Loom.
So, now Delta, Dot, Reliance.
Umm,
now Delta, Loom is all of it,
which is why they're trying to- I couldn't really renew that facility here,
uh, I'll try to get it in one of their lives over the deep
so Yeah,
but I hope not to have the token, so it would be in this
huge literally thing for a whole lot.
Good. In general, I want to have the token,
and cut it. Yeah. You don't need to do that.
So I can get lots of links on, um,
super easily. in the sky. Nice. Yes.
They, uhm, they've been through a couple of months for everything,
and we've all- Requesting to them. Even on one and a quarter,
at least they do a special no-one for all of those.
They brought everything in. That brings me,
if you mind, the first part, you have a kiss. And if we use
that moment, it's here in London. I'm done.
But it would be only put in the small,
say, you know, hat the truck or whatever.
Oh, yeah. Go. Now the,
uh, I'm going to grab you from the small,
snip. Just make that boxy, you know.
Yeah. Yeah,
that'll build in. and then they have a cable board
with them in front of us.
this. . and, uuh,
no
That pretty soon the service
centers are gonna do the people doing the beam line and stuff.
Love. Yeah, you don't think it's gonna be,
yeah. So I have to do the first line for it.
Just follow your head, click first. The person's gonna put a pipe processing center
in right here, across the bottom there,
just a little bit more. You I
got land, everything, I got a super center right next to it. Take care.
He's the move. I'm going to do it. and so that's going to be
good to look. Yeah, it's sad. I'll go ahead and I'll associate
it. So you have to get the- I'll associate it now and
I'll make it as a mission. It's size,
but it's a lot of paper. It's used in shafts,
it's- these are service centers to bring in anything,
partially finished. It can be.
I
just had a little bit of a scary. Good. Hell, they call those service
owners, you know, one company that bought a lot of service owners.
Well, they wanted to go out with a positive guy,
just like me. Alright, guys soon. Yeah, I feel a little bit.
I will be very close to the
trial. Last one, Compass. This All right,
I can just see it. I mean, you're trying to knock it out,
but not. These days,
they're going to just have 5D months there and just be here.
It's costless. Church. Yeah, I'm fine.
Puffin. Atlassian receives,
uh, ehm. You Sam. Yeah. So, Rovo,
this is where it does.
They can kill the shear. I mean, all tariffs.
I don't see it on fushion. They can pass through and look through it.
That's right. Okay,
I'm close, I need a sec. Alright.
That's Umm,
the price is ideal, the maximum amount is quite cheap right here.
Excuse me then, we will buy an unstructured pen.
Thank you.
You know,
it is totally right, it's a pursuit.
Oh, you're back on the text. Don't go, don't go, David. Stay
with us, The crazy trucks come on the rain, so it means they,
uh, didn't sound like they're seeing what was driving them.
one. All right, let's see.
Alright, now we have a shop in next, in next.
Next couple of guys we have, and then the brand new factory,
we have something. Okay. We're coming across, yeah,
and I'll put it. Oh, yes, I'll put it. Um,
let's just say we got, do we have it? you. and certainly,
you know, you can have more, like, you can kind of publish it.
If you have 10 minutes, or you can- I believe it.
Chill on this side, chill on that side. So they all have to be
on money. and we will the next but I said,
you can't much, you've worked it out. Or it was all ends up business,
it's always done. So. So.
I can't see how the U.S. ever competes for us.
I can tell you that. Thank you. Share
in the rest of the time. Compass appeal.
Thank you. Twenty years out,
seven, batteries, period, traffic.
I'm going grab OpsGenie,
ehm. There they are going to be.
I'm going to show them what they're doing. There you go. Okay. My leggers
are not saying it's free, but it's, you know,
hyper. I didn't know why I didn't do that.
I know. Uhh,
that's good. Try it in a circle, don't go. I mean 17.
You'd actually think that you're not happy about . . Okay,
alright. okay. Great. It wasn't that great around,
I thought we'd try to help put the earlop next time.
No. Go ahead and try it out, and check out his lip.
I just got out of the period of time about Tira.
They went, they went so far, like,
we had new, umm. includes before we're getting some thoughts into the bushes,
like all the bushes were fighting for punkers, right?
Hmmm, and then it then popped. That's it.
and I have this footage of who is getting them in thermal oxidizers and
they put thermal out, then you can repart the brain through the staff that
are on the thermal oxidizer. You know, the rest of the strategy is,
you know, within the pool is where, uhh, it's all in that, it's something
that really is interesting. Alright. I
don't know if you can look at this video, if that's in China,
you can see it in a certain way. Okay.
And,
I'll just pop them up here to that.
there's G I don't know if I need one of my kids.
People need one of my kids. I'm just gonna go away with my kids
better now. That's my soundability. I'm just going to do the same thing in
our sounds. Yeah! An idiot is going to be a sample quality.
I'm going to give you a f****** million! I mean,
shit. That's how I make this Pause!
Pause!
I'm going to show you the hair. It's under 55. I'm not going to
end up. I don't know what you want. China is,
uh, very good.
Geez, it tastes hot. Have a good Call to
Jackson and beep on business cards,
you should pick up his name. He's selling,
I'm just so glad I didn't make it go. That was a big deal.
It's been amazing. It's been amazing. Thank you,
sir. It's been So, somebody looks at the print.
No, I'm going to use it for a shirt.
That'll cost us a long time. Okay. Kisses.
Uh, that's uh,
that's what I'm tired of. th th th th I'm tired of having
that. Step. I'm Umm,
standard chicken. Cool.
Right? Yeah. Yeah. Seam was interesting.
Probably. Yeah. So, we're having that. Here go.
Alright. Cheaply Cheaply Cheaply
I'm going to use the best. I'm going use the best. Ah,
so, period. It's having a bad look at my house.
I'm going to use the best in my house with this in the available
issue. Thank you for your attention. Hi, this is all of the standard locks
that was shown by my gave up my title, I gave you my stops
and I gave permission. That's all for this week's occasion.
You'll never miss them. Go ahead, And I I've got the option to serve
through the, uh, the use of the email,
the fact that this name is, actually that it has some time to go
through it. I think,
I uh, I think, right. I think, I'll set up the latest insurance thing,
I'll be reading my own signature back to the launch. We'll see you in
a minute. 10.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I was looking at like, you saw the highest ranking person over here in
the United States Council? Well, I'm not going to do that status.
Yeah, umm, mail wrong. We're going. I mean,
stand up, or you can say something about,
umm, umm, umm, its an overall company thing and it could've all dated or
whatever. They're- Suck up here now and it's- It's a good one.
It's what I just- There's no big event, right?
Hahaha. Okay,
move it up and just pull it in my mind so you can see
how I like this. Yes. Okay.
Oh, I can, I can't even, I can't even, I can't my hands to
start out anymore. I like that, I like that.
But you go through it, we go through the style, we go through the
PDN. This is still cheaper to go, yeah? I do it quicker.
And we're going. I'll in the Hola.
Okay.
Let's see,
yes sir. Thank you, Chairman. Okay.
You're not gonna lie.
Bye I think that's a big thing.
If you want to take care of it, no. It has to be.
I'll right back a It's a little bit dark in here,
so let me look at the image. We can see that we have the
only video. Come on.
? You'll be here with the other one.
It's a very good amount. It's a stand in prison. It just came under
the house. It came under the house. It under the So. Because all probability.
Six from Beethoven. Umm. Umm.
Umm.
.
We'll be right
back to the end of the day. Check it out.
Bye. Alright.
Sit. Sit. Okay. Well,
put your foot in and into it. Alright. Okay, good, let's go Atlassian.
Oh, they're gonna be listening out.
Okay. And there's the-
I'm sure they're different. That's what I'm talking about.
. . . Bixx. Bixx.
Bixx.
Bixx. Bixx. Bixx. Bixx. Bixx.
Umm, so I'm typing the words,
you know, twice as soon as they're in the media fashion.
Or to ask them, like, me and Mrs. Bixx. Pophead,
I'm just hearted in the name, where I should be.
It's, it's like a $7.00.
It's a $7.00. It is important to me,
huh? I should probably, uh, put this in some food,
so that you can eat all of me. Yup, it's the dollar,
it's after printing, the door actually,
it's one side of us and all of them. I think that's it,
shins. and next Thank you.
Thank you, Mario. Here's
another. Okay. It's out.
All of you very much. I'm not sure what you're giving me.
Two minutes. Let's I'm hit it.
She's not going to show you that.
She's not going to leave it. It's not what I was going to do.
Basically, great. Yeah.
Mmm.
Mmm. Mmm. Mmm.
. . Alright,
so we need to believe that we need to do
some of the things. So we have a variety of things we like,
but we try to make that do a little bit of stuff.
I didn't look at it. You know what I was talking about.
Umm, you can do that.
Umm, it's fresh. And speed.
me. There's that 3-1 of the iPad, 4-1 of the Galaxy.
Plus, they're not. It's going to be able to come in next time.
Now then, we can look for- and almost ready to look at it.
Umm, I have made a big video,
it's it's, it's been happening professionally.
I'll see I'm going show you the answers. I'm going Yes.
Okay.
Mm-hmm. eh,
hehe. Ooh plasma. His phse size.
I'm not if I'm giving something else there than he see.
lip must be. . . Gee, you think about it.
What's your answer to that? It's a fine thing.
It's really horrible. You can say anything and say one. So, it should be
like that. I don't have time at the time to see if I can
share it a lot. in
my sense. It's very good on the side.
I'm doing I don't know if I can share it with you. See you
in a minute. Bollywood, Swerve, MediRoute, Umm,
Ejisha, Umm, Junjung,
Statuspage. Now, back here's it.
. . It's a little bit better, but I'm not going to still get
hurt in this thing. I don't think we can talk about it.
We need to invest it. And it won't be as far away as it
can Have a good day. I don't think we can talk about it.
I don't think we can talk about You
don't need to use apps to do it either. Whatever the clock is.
Umm, I'm gonna shoot the salad at Tonya's and then Jamie's food.
Thank you. I think it's not only because it's not for the Bitbucket,
but it's not for the Bitbucket, it's for any cheese.
It's strong. You right.
But, no one's trained on that. It's almost as long as there's something in
it as much. much.
Come on back shall. Time to be back to No,
no, no, no,
Abhay. In hella with the E-VOC,
I'm not E-VOC.
I'm not in love with the E I'm from.M.
I've seen people in the U.M. but where to Nah,
it's going to be going to be negative. time. Not We'll be increasing. You've
used aially. I've got my, No. The details in when I use this chit
chat, I don't know if it might be a show or it might not
the time to act for more because it's time to work up.
Mmm, Mmm,
Mmm, Mmm. I'm in. Mmm.
Mmm. Mmm. Mmm.
I
think that's part of the reason.
Stop.
So if I were to stop, I would have to take it.
Hit that button.
It was a spin, and you should be listening.
Uh, it was a lot closer than I expected. I don't know. I've never
met a company. I've never met a company. And I love to be there.
So I've been finishing this like, eight dollars in the day.
Oh shit. Language Tider.
No, you need to be on my burger. Umm,
it's good. Plus I was good.
Good. But there should be a separate one.
Or back to double check that. Because that's the case.
For old. But. want to talk about market
market. Yes. That's good to see many.
He might have been strong with 100 mayors. That was great shit.
I'm going to put it somewhere else in here. In and out.
It's 17. 17.
He hurts me. Heh.
Heh.
I don't think
I estimated this. Yes, I mean the third. . . So it's fine on
the earth. That's the big thing.
That's the one they have, ehm. No.
I think you were supposed to be pushing on your back.
That's a, you know, cheater. Yeah.
So I'll tell you how to get Umm, just go back and take a
GIC and see what, uh, what are you want me to do?
I'm going to buy you a little.
. . He's still big with him,
but I'm just not interested. He's still in the car?
Yeah, because they have both there, so they give a feel.
We'll next Worshoot, and MediRoute, Apple.
It started playing with Apple. Now,
let me see if I can get some fun, if he's in there.
Yeah, I had 29,
450 from steel, and then 15,000,
150. Yep, he gave it a lot, so yeah.
you Okay,
so he gave you a, what? He gave you a total of 31 bucks,
31 bucks, 31 31 dollars.
I don't Some change. Whatever,
what I don't mean, that's it. You've earned up something,
earned up cost. I'm gonna bet I should be. Go.
Thank you. That's because
we can see coming back on.
you It's the one who will make a loss,
make an F3, and pull it in at once for a higher level. we
will catch you for the, uh,
vlogs. That's what I'm going to show and
the people. Keep down
the question. Excited,
buddy, keep up. I said, why don't you? Oh,
no, respect. Atlassian,
why don't you? Eh? There.
and it's
the minute. Okay.
Join me. You This'll be weird,
it's gonna be in the package,
probably. Working on a person in question. And it is- You uhh,
uhh, uhh, hmmm. It's like an eraser of a fridge.
I just thought I could put a lot of ink in it in the
morning. Okay. I can't just find an interesting reward.
It's available at the same time. It'll be sure it's ready yet,
but it's my month. It's a pug, so it's not my month.
Uhh, uhm.
Bye-bye, music. See you. I
mean, 5th country is one of theest parts of the country in the country.
Yeah. I'm sure you will. You know,
she's wearing eyes. you and that,
I'm gonna say if I'm gonna need to, so they have a great bunch
of different uh, options to be gonna go.
Ok, so let's go work with them. Let me go.
I don't know. Well, uh,
well, it indicates what it meant to be. Well, there's some lines,
different ones. They're just kind of, they're actually gonna ask for you.
So I don't really do any more. Now,
I start with a market, and it's going to be a really good design.
You want to make a problem? John, John. I'm going you a bit of
the video. Yeah, do you want us to draw us?
Yeah, we should have a sample at any time. Which we
saw in the original video, at least we called, So, it's not,
it's not, it's not really what we didn't, uh, uh.
Sure, so, okay. Thank you. Thank you.
So, I mean, what else kind of what's here?
It longs that light, and it looks as well,
as well as then. And, I think we're turning into
a year-long pipeline. And so,
there we go. Jira,
but, you know, they said make it sound because they're probably in the same
with TJ's, uhm, so TJ isn't that stability.
So. That's all I Like, you know,
how do you look at that adventure? And somehow I don't have an adventure,
so we had an adventure. better. better. Stop.
Free. Better to solve.
All right. All right. All right. Okay. Let's see where all the effects are,
and then we're going to solve first.
So we do. I didn't want to keep all of my senses,
no. But what sucks is, inventors,
I don't care about it, so a lot of it all- I'm just like,
hey, we're auto-capped people. And so,
that became a problem, and commonly,
auto-capped license. Thank for your attention. So, to me, keep on going to the
rigidity. I mean, these licenses,
like, we are auto-starred. But,
I mean, if you want to do some- Brimes, like that,
by that. But, I mean,
Bitbucket is a whole, more solid,
it's a whole thing to mark, it's a thing. We'll be like,
I have a temperature for a little while, man. We need this,
uhm, this, uhm, this, uhm, this, I don't know if it is going to
cost a question, but I don't know what it, it's not like for the
way of designing that. And you're going to use it for the feel where
it appears. Yeah, we wanted to do it here for the shop,
and I was like, I think that'd be great for the night,
so I was like,
what can you draw here? Jira, Loom, MediRoute, because the bellows end up.
Oh, they actually draw it down. Yeah, they,
uh, who's going to come up? Go on and view it.
I'm going come up and show you how to do it. And Jimmy started
doing the, uh, um, um, with the bellows.
And I'm like, there's just, that's- Turdike,
you know, real time and impact, you know,
where your brilliant money is, it's, it won't process as close to getting rid
of you. So do you want to get rid of me?
Yeah. Sorry.
I was like, I'm tired for that either.
It's a lot. Bye bye. I'm just somebody,
you know, you know, a book? No.
It's like a website, right? You just go and job it's somebody,
you just like shit all the time. Contact.
And then, what we did was, um, for one of the buildings,
we did a demo of building scanner.
And so. you We're all walking and I'm doing a training mountain,
and they said, oh yeah, we'll send you the file for free.
You know, I'm a part of it. Just demo so that we can get
started. So we're going to start with our model.
And I'm still like, in charge of it. But I just want to do
this for a little bit. we're going You It's
definitely genius, all the rich and rich. I think it's very honest,
all the rest of that. Yeah, that's the generic. back. Yeah.
But I, I'm okay at 2000 or less than at home,
the company I work for, bottom. Thanks watching,
and I'll see you in this so I haven't had it,
had it forever now, but it's, it's one of you,
but. Good. Let me know how I start things with that software,
okay, I'll discuss this. Thank Listen,
they can't do you so good at it. Exactly. I hope you enjoyed
So we're gonna wait for the electrical should we do it again?
Hey, I don't have something to find.
Must be in there, it's all built. No. No. No. That's the one being
called. That's the side of the wheel.
Greatness. guys. In a calm,
dizzy, 12. I wanna be crazy with preference.
We'll see I to go round,
right?
Heh, heh, heh, heh, heh,
heh, heh. I did just again on a
long idea. I'm going to do an estimate of,
I'm going to do 13th of the paper, I'm going to do 15th.
Thank you. Yeah.
Do a chance to buy a kit? Mmm,
not unless. It takes me, my own,
if you want to get into it. Yeah, that worked.
It was that way. with. Is that a boost
kit? No. No.
No. No. No. No. No. No.
No. No. Yeah,
I used to walk in and talk in terms of you guys.
Gays, Nettges, Pimparker,
London, England, I don't know what's going on.
There's Office, you know. So lets go. I just love them.
Like, ah, oops, oops,
No. Good. Good.
I don't know if it's being in a field site at the end of
the construction It's
our technology in that environment. This is I'll make
So that is forward, kind of forward because of the yesterday,
so that's what we are feeling now. I'm good.
Yeah. Good. Good. Thank you,
thank you. We'll you
in a Umm,
it is. I was not that impressed.
I just did a one here. I didn't even get I
mean, we're bad, it's like, I think thought it was gonna be fun to
hear, well, you know, you gotta remember, I've come from other places.
Thank you. I have all this really nice equipment and I hope,
uh, Space Girl,
you do that. Uh,
I'ma- I would purposely use a really good set of drawings to
kind of see what it can do, right? That's throwing up the most difficult.
It's called. So,
they've had this thing. They've had about 75 recorders on it.
for about the past six months, just as a,
uhm, in Mega Mode,
just to get things working. Welcome. So I'm gonna upload a set of drawings
here. Umm,
I'll just put in today's data.
is the project number.
Fill out whatever you want to there. So it's gonna upload the drawings.
Let me, actually, let me- I don't open that so you can kind of
see what I'm uploading. Umm.
.
Uhh, duh duh.
Thank you.
So this is what I'm up on just,
you know, just PDFs, yep.
And what's good, what's this program going to do?
It's going to, so.
I love it.
Once again, it's up there, I've done it in the last few years.
Yeah. They'll take off the columns, they'll take off the beams,
they'll engineer the connection. It'll spin out the next more to,
to bring in the power time, and it can reveal the model,
calling them shy. Bye-bye. Wow.
Yeah. A lot of the tech folks have said for you,
impressive. It's crazy.
It's, Alright,
so I'm in there. Let me go here first. This configuration.
The duration of all the planets in section.
I don't think no other plan. No,
it's, it's, you, you don't have to upload everything,
like, this page is going to do not. Thank much for Alright?
Sure. Uhm, but even with the sections,
it's not gonna really look at the sections right now.
There, there. Okay. It's actually working on it where it will start using the
sections to get more detail and to get other information.
It's But. I pretty much, these are all the pages I care about.
So, now, I can write here on this config page.
Yes, You would want to get in here and look and do all your
settings for how you wanted the deep connections.
Umm, the B-M-N-N and Reaction Method,
Seismic Stuff. Umm,
do I want to default to double angles or shoot hands?
Yeah, I'm sorry. Right? So, you set all this up in order to do
the connections. Does it actually understand your excitement?
Have a good one. I'm not,
I don't know that I don't fully, it's going to be quite honest with
you. I, I haven't, you know,
I've used a simple. Dutshill, it's, it's,
so I, I don't know all those announcements,
you have to get them. I have to ask them about that,
but. So. So, What I'm going to do on,
so I'm a foundation plan, so.
What I'm going to do, it picks up the- Scale,
and the, um, well,
give him pick up top of steel, cause there is no top of steel,
alright? So, I can do zero.
I could do minus one for that.
I could do whatever I wanted to there for,
for this and then I'm gonna tell it by hitting this button to go
analyze it. So now you'll see that,
like on this one, you'll see it,
it'll pick it up here. ... second,
see how it is now highlighted in blue and has that overlay on it.
At that point, I'm just making sure it got everything.
I love you, too. and make sure it get and get something that I
don't want like this over here. It picked up stuff here,
which I don't want, so I'm just going to holla Thank you. like that
and say, don't, don't do that until it will read me a little bit
with that, with that out of it.
So, you're pretty.
Pretty much just letting it do its thing to make sure it got everything
and cleaning it up. Now,
I'm gonna then go to the next set.
It picked up top of steel, it picked up my scale.
So I'm just gonna tell it to you go.
Hello. And boom,
it got all that. You can see the red though it didn't pick up
like if I zoom in here. You're,
It didn't get this one here,
this 10 at 12. And it didn't get this 10 at 12 right here,
so if I were to select both of them, I can then
tell it it's a dead, oops, W10x12.
So And that has six studs.
It is picking up the studs by the way. So I'm safe.
Thank I've been telling it to re-deal.
So really, I've just cleaned it up, right? Like I picked up all this
crap right here thinking it's a beam of some sort. Work.
So I would just be going through cleaning all that up.
I'll go to the next page. Same deal.
Picked up top of steel and my scale. I was t- I love the
screen. I see you're going
floor by elevation, elevation,
current. with it. So,
yeah, I haven't really cleaned up anything,
right? All right. But just a few, a few things.
But as I'm doing that, I go here to my 3D view.
You're gonna see this. This is where
I think my- Modeling is going to be a,
uh, think of the past before too long.
All right. And
so now I've got my model with connections in it.
Live. Hm.
Interesting. And that crazy? Yeah, it is. Keep watching.
Now, we'll be right All right.
Absolutely. So,
I got my model. I can come over here.
You see that building? on the material. This is actually the,
the import, um, template. I'm with So you
can see that it's,
it's picked up my quantity, my shape, my size. Don't more videos.
Thank for watching. I think the grade, it's got my labor code in here.
They're working on this being customizable to your own labor code.
Alright, so if you want, it got camber coat,
coals, studs, and it's just- I'm just picking up a I've got up everything,
right? I'm good at PDFs, I'm good. Um.
They were fine. I'm in love. Oh, whole lot.
We can get that in one of them. We don't want to throw it
up here. But that's one thing they want to know is staff are getting
someone there for one of their lives. And get along there.
It's free. Yeah. Yeah. That was good. I mean. I'm to make
it Now, got it. I can come here also with my columns.
You see that it thought that I'll go back up.
It thought that on the upper level it was a 14 to 74 minutes,
a 14 to 68 actually. actually. So
what it I'll get rid of
it. So now I've got that fixed.
So you want to check your column schedule here. But like,
if I literally did want a column splice here,
I- I can do that, and then choose whether I want it to be
welded or bolted or what type of connect splice I want there,
right? But. I can build. You're a starter?
No, this was a plywood mine.
Um, so it's a fabricator that wrote this,
which is a nut. . Another big checkbox, right? That's a good thing.
Uh, a fabricator it is.
So, this is pretty awesome.
and then I can also,
right here, they're going to get it set on the apply that.
That's it. They're going to get it set where the bracing just,
it figures the bracing out and does it.
If I get a brace as though, I can- I'm going to open my
bracing in here if I wanted to, by saying I started column C1,
get a column C32. I'll you in the next video.
I want the bracing,
I want it to be welded and cool,
and I want it to be HSS,
I I made by,
oh, uh quarter. Waaac
Chr! Fricked out on me. Thank you. Oh,
man.
You're bad. I'll see you Something freaked out on me.
Let me get back in there. But I can,
I can build my mercy if I wanted to.
Then once I get on- All that done, and I had the model.
I could import the model. I could also,
by getting the IFC right there,
there be- I don't think it's so that it can go straight into technical
structure, your history as well.
And just build the bottle in there. But I can also do this.
This export is PDF. And it
marks up everything that, Took off now and got to do the rest of
the jump, you know, the genobrist,
uh, all the perimeter stuff,
my miscellaneous and everything. So, I mean,
yeah, you think about it.
I mean, how, how much savings is,
is that if it's picking up the drop? So, I know how to write.
I've got, uh, one part of Texas,
who was, if you go to, um. and see you Ah,
what's your name? The other guy's here,
Lyft. If you go to these guys' website,
you're gonna see- the, uh, sketch deck.
You're gonna see one of our clients and biggest user on it.
They've switched over to his. Umm,
uhm. Oh, my God. He, he says that he's getting about only
percent more estimates out what it is.
We'll have the same people. you I mean,
they're strict structuring. Yeah,
industrial grounds don't even, you know,
like, uh, strict structuring. Okay, so that's what this is going to look like.
Look at the strategy of what you have in your strategy.
We're fine. 10%.
10 10%?
10%?
10% of the dynamics?
Thanks. We'll see if I can ask a question this one.
How many yes, I'm just going to do the restraints function. I'll see you
in Yeah,
well, I mean, we can throw some airplanes up here. Hi! That's it! Well,
great day. I you enjoyed. You all What? Let me read the right thing.
I don't care if you use it now. I didn't have to really do
it. I just like sharing the tools, uh.
I don't even back up, see if it'll be back up. It's for the
needle of how, uh,
you know how much it's going to be. It's,
uh, nearly sound edgy. anymore. First.
So, like right now that we talked two months ago,
you'd be able to do this for free. Uh,
as long as you- But, yeah,
conjugate a recursion. It's, uh,
they're not taking any more data control, sir. But I'm not doing the cost.
All the guests, ladies They know what sketch they're past,
so I would imagine it's going to be a really short sketch they've used,
so. Yeah. We'll see you which was pretty expensive,
but, yeah, it was pretty expensive,
80,000 off. I've heard all of them in the place for s- catch back.
Uhm.
They were included in the red to be based on a lot of kind
of like, well, then they stopped that and they started doing it part of
life since then they started doing it part company,
then they started doing it part yesterday. I don't know how you're going to
be planning on this soon, but it was pretty expensive.
Thank so much. I also
knew the $20 dollar exchange, well, I said you should go in that way.
But, erm, no, I don't know
that. I'm going to see if it's cheap, probably the most in the subscription.
You know, even what likes that over there.
But,
I guess my father was flexed in 25,000,
and I don't know if he could have a poor ship or a ship
ship or a or a I'd be all over. But,
ship, three of you guys from others you hear that this is a 25k,
it's done. Yes, but- .
. . ...the credit cards together. Yeah. And I'm- .
. . I'm tossing my number, like, the board of the people,
but the kids, the way this,
this- . . . people will stay a hundred- . . . got from,
like, a hundred- . . . that came in,
and he started detailed, but, like, he's got a program.
We'll back around and leave you. He
started working a little bit,
He just, he any guy that sold his buddies from back how the third-grampers,
uh, start helping them all out,
so they've been working a little bit. Thank you about two years. So,
yeah, it's been actively used in their shop citizens.
So, it's been fun. One. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Cool content, bro. Yeah. Cool. Almost another. Learn more
at www And I've got sketch deck.
I haven't tried them in forever.
forever. I
could throw one out there too, but there's,
it doesn't do as much. Thank you. you So,
didn't I?
Do I call?
No. Mhm.
Mm hmm. I
would be just a child of the girls later. Let's see how much.
So, on. Go on. We'll go on. David Rastikz. I've done some and it's
like, okay, well, uh,
ah, so. And they've had slowly.
I believe. The estimators don't hear like that.
I've, I've done it. They had them fixed much of that.
Like I said, drones, I'll put up there. Thank you. For a client,
and it didn't really need anything. And it, it should have been so I
sent it to him that night. I came up back here. He said,
okay, good shot, Mill. I picked up everything.
So, I was kind of pleased with their response here.
By their crowdsourced data conditioning, that's not much of their performance.
Don't worry Don't worry.
There'sangers to work Yeah. Exactly. When I saw it,
I'm about to go. Like, as you guys said,
it's now. They're like, it's not really. And like,
you're way farther than anybody else. Just tell everybody what it came to,
what it came to, what to, what what it just was selling.
And they're like, where I'm going to tell us how it's ready.
. S My okay. But.
There he is, there he is.
I want
Alright.
. I
can't even hear you serious, I'll get- Or
the other side of their own. . . I don't think
they got anywhere to get to.
I'm sure
that we all want to start sailing into it. Yeah, I hope that they
already had. Good.
Ojib. Thank you.
Subscribe
to our internet, not heaven. Bye-bye. Yeah,
that was the key. Yeah,
there are interesting videos, cool. That's what you've got to show,
right? Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
This is so the drums, I'm looking at it right here.
Here has, umm.
Atlassian where the building is. Yeah,
Yeah. You got half the building on this one, she got half the building
on this other sheet, and so now that's the part of those two together
somehow. We're having trouble with that first but- And the short.
All right. Hey, they got that taken care of everybody Yes,
go over to the end of the video.
And, uh, this is what we really just need.
Let me take a peek at this. Coming at our
agenda versus. Jesus. Give us an instantly.
Yep. So,
There is a way also to uh,
action draw stuff over here if you want me to. I'll see you I
don't have a big hat for someone. Good
I mean, it's called the enemy.
Uhh.
You made the coupling of notes, still, really? Baby. Master Steel is the,
is the steel company, but they kind of formed their own company.
I need to sell this. .
So there is a
company called D&D that does conceptual models.
All right. So, hopefully you know what, I know that I'm going to ask
us what's through instruction. Hello. Hello. It's,
uhm, Captain Lewis, OpsGenie.
Thank Well,
I think my search for Steel Genie.
Yep. This came up. you There is another,
uh, I'm trying to think of a name. There's another one that I have,
uh, a long year. I'm trying
to think of the name
. . . But it's just, ah,
it's a little bit frustrating, isn't it? You have little drones on their side.
They did the- They did the take-off on their software to send it back
to you. You have no control over it. So.
Sutter.
It's, it's all good. Don't be a little bit frustrated because I don't,
if I'm gonna give you a little help, pick out everything,
make no- the type of the insublier.
Kinda weird that in a,
you should be- You
It's like nothing about contact information,
anything that you may discuss in the video. No.
Hopefully not, but guys, don't come.
I don't know what we're doing, what are we doing, tough love.
Umm, I don't see the importance towards that.
I just want to do for all these truck
eases. Yeah, I can cause- Oh my gosh.
I can't even scroll here. Uhh,
this is fun, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm,
uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm. Come here,
go back out there and leave the link in there.
Umm,
I will just call them shamelessly. So now, you got an import
on the electrical studs, that's what you say. Please.
I'm pleased. Okay. Amen.
Good. Okay. Okay. Everybody go on in like this.
All the way. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Very good.
We'll see you Yeah,
I was just, I was just beep out about it going.
Oh, man. Yeah, that, we,
we helped him with estimating. They're wanting to help.
But, they're wanting to help with production because they're almost It's a good
minute and it's great in the hair, it's a bit challenging,
but it's great in the hair. It's a bit challenging in the new structure
of them, in the new creates, and they do all right now.
Don't let anything go the other way. Thanks a
lot. Start with the structure of the vision about,
about a better scale. Thank you. There's,
uh,
a lot of other companies out there I haven't done anything with I've done
to. Good. Good. Hm. For some busy,
uh, but, yeah. Everything
booked out. Go!
Yeah, booked out. In the April right now. Yeah. Yeah.
Thank you. But
that's, umm,
I'm planning one week a month not.
Traveling, so that's a little bit
artificially inflated from what I used to be.
See you later. On the road? Yes.
How many people do you have, like, Jason,
to the same community? Uh,
what other, I've got other than yours. Some rich markets.
Yeah. Two. Oh, there's probably so many structural shops,
so it's just there. You are trending. They are posted in Lava,
out there in, uh, in the U.S.
Yeah. They they have, they they have. We'll see the next hundred thirty at
three. I found like eighty seven.
I was looking like the rest of the pie. Yeah.
I found eighty seven. Thank much. Last. Yeah.
Not even, not including Kellogg from one year,
not including the cost. Yeah, thanks. Most of the pie is starting
to- Most of clients, I don't know why,
but maybe there's more family theaters, but most of my clients are
Easter-sized. So, I'm in the United States,
more southern western, which I will,
I will wish, yes.
Umm, like, there's all of the green dots
on the clients, but you need to say that,
uhm. Oh. I'm tired of concentration over the middle of that.
It means that's a little less, uh, for what to agree with about any
title matters. My culture, my aim is to,
Yeah. I know that you're an audience. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, we're fun,
nice to know that you know we're looking for a job. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. Let me know. Ops.
Uh. I got a chance down here,
down, and then we bring the house rather than just This is my So
yeah, I'm going to, like, bring it down to the sales stock,
bring it down to the, the interest rate of stock,
which, eh, that. I think I might have bound one today, so,
uh, to figure out, this is what I like to run out of,
like, to say. Good. Yeah.
Wait a few minutes of the sun here. We'll see in the next
video. I like to feel like I'm helping
you now. Yeah, that's the biggest issue you can make with work.
The last 10 years, that's the biggest issue.
Yeah,
I think my goes to this five to five thing. I was hearing all
these different opinions and finally it's going to happen to the feelings.
Thanks for watching. I love this morning in the childhood. It's like
everybody is thinking, okay, I'm off.
I'll have a move. I was like,
got in. But because you're going to set your partial
story. All
And this guy basically has to go do the job. And I thought, maybe
there's going to be a guy. Bye. I could see that's not the
case. So. Like,
the check, the most often really on the first episode of Compass Manager.
I think he got pulled in, too. You wouldn't have thought of him as,
you know, but, uhm, there's nobody that's really good in killing
us. It's- It's- Okay. It's a- It's an easy job for some of your
experience. Go ahead. Uh, when it comes to film a reaction from-
I'm I'm sorry sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm I'm out of the lane.
Go ahead and try to help with it. It's a well-made thought of the
hell I'm in. That couldn't be any right to tell me- I'm going to
follow across- I'm going to ask you guys- hmm.
And we can get this in the battle eyes. I'll end All right. There's
welding together on actually sassing the corrosion science.
We can give that stuff.
Until I have an order to work, I'm going to also
open it up.
Try the babies. Cheers. I'm sure they understand. He did what matters.
Don't like that, Mr. Welling. He needs to get him tested.
Let's get started. They're gonna really hate it when
it's not gonna be used like a really small stick rod.
I'm stop. I'm gonna fast.
I don't know if that's not the most efficient way. It's like,
yeah, it might be the only way to pass it, but it's interesting.
If there's no commercial test,
yeah. Yeah, that's where Bitbucket's at,
they've got, uhm, Cluffins, he's in the air. I will.
. . . with the comedies. Anybody who just spoke in the world,
they're making good love about it. They just buy us some new machines to
do that. I don't how it's going. Of course it goes.
I don't know how it's going to go. Yeah, it's going to completely.
I'm just going to pick up. Go. I'm
out by spreading the ingredients.
Don't be into it. I love this shot.
Bye-bye. So,
this is all like a hundred sixty feet in the air inside a slide.
Yeah. Yeah. Ladies
and gentlemen. Yeah.
Can I have a step a little later around?
Yeah. Okay. Touch it. Machine?
Yeah, it becomes going to be more and more popular. You have a little
bit more. See you pretty much in the back part.
Yeah. Okay.
And go. Wait a minute.
They have machines too. Yeah. It's a good question.
God you. It'll be a state
so we can not go after the big interior case.
And there's all kinds of cool stuff. Okay. We moment.
I mean, you don't need to float over here. The question becomes how long
it will tell us what's going on in favor of the big difference.
If not, because later well,
you can use it in all instances. Yeah, pretty much.
No, uh, yeah. That's the answer to me code. That's not a lot.
I'm not going to be talking about I'm not going to be talking it.
I'm You know, it talks in the slot with the interior. Thank you very
much. Thank you.
. . .
That means our ticket.
Very That's
That's a good question.
Umm.
I still think I can find my website, so that's the end of the
video. Umm,
I'll find it. Good. Oh,
video, just didn't let me go, right? There aren't so many fun.
Sorry.
Seal.
So, it's okay,
I take a few seconds to this one more time.
So, I'm gonna, Ummm, reinvent.
I know what kinda Everything can Do not count.
There is a whole function. And so I'm just gonna have to give you
a thousand kind of a plug and check it over. It's gonna be a
thousand plug when you say it. I'll see It's frozen,
but I don't even say it. I just need to put it out so
it's not heavy. It's everything. Thanks.
It's, it's, it's,
it's, uh, what's the main place?
I don't know, so it's what you gotta find. Yeah. We'll see in the
just not done. I can't, I guess, probably more,
you know? No. Like, it's not done since.
Thank you. No.
It's done. It's done.
F***. you
Here's more. Uh.
Uh. Tipo,
check. Mmm.
Mmm.
Well,
the, the site just takes me to,
uh, the Rovo site. Sorry. I should just
be still GV.com.
No. Umm.
Thank you.
Yeah, well it works.
If you want the dedicated website,
it's master. That's steel.net. That's something.
Good. Good.
You areitive?
You structure. talked various ones and developers?
yeah. I'm good. yeah.
I'm gonna do the same thing. I'm just gonna go and get it. All
right. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very
Well, that's what Umm,
uh, yeah, that's what This place is a long match,
but it's pretty Yeah,
it's pretty good, yeah, it's pretty Dude, here,
I mean, I can, I'll throw it into the lip.
I should be able to finish myself with that model shape.
Thank you. I'm not gonna it. I'm not gonna do it last time.
No, no, no, no. It just said it did.
So, JFA, no. Bye-bye. I love I love you.
I love you. I love you. Do what's in your
head. I love you.
I love you. I love you.
I love you. in the most important. I love you.
I love you.
I love you. .
.
I've got two of them.
It's quite a bit. It's nice and you have two of them.
You have two of them. Kick it. You have two of them.
You have two of them.
You have two them. In the meantime I mentioned that,
so I'll be understanding them. Cheers. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I'm gonna be feeling like that for you.
Cheers. just. Alright. I don't know,
I don't know, I don't know what to do.
Okay, I'm in focus.
you.
hffffffffff,
Loom to other people? Uhh. Uhh. I'm in the civil You
know what? There's And,
I don't have a pen. Shh. I might say,
but if you think we're more in, there's better photo- I still got it.
Anyway, I will not hear its mention of it,
it's everything, not anything. It's very- It's- It's-
It's- It's- It's- It's-
Okay, go ahead and look at this.
I don't- I'm gonna get you. Thank you.
I'm gonna ahead and look at this. Umm, I'm gonna look at this.
I'll to do the This example of Thank you.
Okay. I'm going I'm going . I'm gonna this.
I'm gonna look at this. I will teach
you in five minutes. I'm gonna teach you in 10
minutes. Alright.
You see ya.
Could be a post-item in the hours,
but uh, a minute. What about me?
Thanks for being here. . . You're welcome. You're I'm
Jim. You're welcome. Here's how it's considered.
I also need to know that story. Enjoy. I'm going test it and see
if it can get it. You're actually going to know that. Jim,
in this message, you're going to answer it. Please,
Ernie. Thank I'm going to say,
what? I'm going to say,
David. Good.
And I'll be able to be able to be certainly the input so it
needs a simpler input. Yeah,
it needs to just, this is the better. at least.
We need this to get a really good test to see it.
We've got time to, uh, talk Okay.
But I don't share it as long as it becomes good.
And, you know, that is a lot of it.
But, uh, it's a lot of it. Mmm. Gotta get in there.
Charles, I've been following this, and she's known this, and she's known it by
30, 30 years. Yeah, absolutely.
Thank you. If you don't like the reaction,
don't worry. I know it. But,
that's enough. Okay. Alright, let's go.
Well, at one minute, there,
I thought that was one of the few ones that wanted the iteration to
begin with e-limits. Class of 2020. Yeah.
They've all been some projects since Naira did. Listen. We it.
We I have a Okay. And we're going to go with the project.
So I got my projects in the money. Isn't that the same? Do not.
Don't let it be individual trade easily.
Thank you. All right.
All right.
So, yeah,
I hear it from me. That's not the key.
It's the same thing that I was able to send to Like,
yeah. You know, you have three head to come up with your spare camera,
so. As I've said, I've never used any of the skins.
I've lost, nor, I've only, I've asked you.
You know, I mean, getting Chris to your side.
See if someone can do an import for us, uh,
like, at least you know that. Sorry.
Okay. I'm going to say thank you for that.
I'm gonna do that. Thank you for that. Talk to me. Does the outcome
include issues? Yeah. Yeah. I'm gonna show it.
And we let the industry is important.
Oh, there's that no problem. So, okay. I'm gonna, I'm gonna.
That's it. Okay, alright. Alright.
Successful in programming, I like to show it.
It's not. It's exciting.
I did it to suddenly modify the file to handle a different file for
growing. Bye. I'm not sure if but I'm just important.
I don't have any. Oh, sorry. I shouldn't have seen it.
I shouldn't have seen it. Oh.
Could've been sick now. But keyboard can have me play.
Bye. Here's a bit more news. Umm,
I guess I'll go over that sentence.
That's it. Later in this,
I have one question. What ever you have to
make a new project. Good. Shoulders
and weights, but it's definitely different as you're thinking and in the summary.
Good morning. I don't know if it's something that has a
key talk to them. So I can't,
I can't grab anything with you. . . Do that,
on which you see. Like,
if you're doing it on the other end, I'm just gonna click on it.
25 foot 7. You have 25 hours of school
or an admin, you know, we see what the cost is,
and then figure out. and yeah,
later it costs to cover the part,
you just see the one that I think is. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah,
because most of that, we factor outside of,
outside of the system. Stop it.
Yeah, I actually wish it was going to touch that.
But, it must have been to, uhm, over city.
and we'll see I'll see you.
Bye.
Umm.
Oh, hmmm.
It's one of these now. I love you. Umm.
Okay.
It's- It's- It's- It's-
It's-- . Yeah,
the varnishing set. That's I'm going to you
I'm going to go by Oh,
so. Oh, I'm
going to go by that thing as I'm going to go by that thing.
Now I should tell Okay.
Oh.
Here,
we'll manage it, and so I'll give you a side draw,
do we? Thank Thank you. Yeah, there was,
uh, there's one, one column that was in your shirt.
I, uh, I had it. Good.
I was his main art column to begin in the dry wound.
Uh, I've been, uh,
important to you to go. you It's not really,
it's definitely not really in
the process. That's Time to get a single day.
Just make sure some of the- nd, uuh, vuuh, wuh,
wuh, wuh, Say, ask why did he buy something that we
can't buy from here. I mean,
you do as well. Thank you for having us sayin'.
but I will too further. She is kept down as my pal,
you know, taking off all the parts,
you know, the representation in the story, my son,
I was in so, . Yeah, probably going to have a little bit less
sort of optimization,
but at least a table of,
Yeah, like, fighting. So. Right. Yeah. And it just does. I've got Glasses on
it. We've got Super on it somewhere.
Considering we are excited, what was going on is this one.
I- That's it. I can barely just combine and see it all the way
to the home. I'm going to get a 2-1
minute set. So, what do we just want here here?
Uhh, I don't know if you can escape
or something else. So, thank you very- I'm keep working with some good about
it right now. I'm get to the beginning
of the year. I thought they were only,
virtually waiting for it to feel. I'm sure we could just tell it to
help, depending on what the surprise and engagement is.
It's kind of a part of the second time I've played.
Umm,
I couldn't make it seem that way, so. Thank you. Depending
on how much work you need to do in the back when you get
that XF on the look that way is,
whether or not we're gonna- we are a natural and benefit to this and
we are. Well, I'd have to be looking into those cars so we don't
know which other quantity you're interested in.
Trying to be all this long without the cars would be a tight pass.
house.
Probably,
we think we're doing this by hand and we have a show just on
its eye on something. Yeah, the next Well,
there's of this. I've our window, of course, I've All right. You Yeah,
yeah, the shots made more intuitive.
You can't sit and do our same to my shot.
So, go ahead and let's- do what it
makes sense. You need to grasp it and get it suddenly with their cards,
and all that stuff. Uh, please. You just drop the parts and the rest
of the the rest. See you later. Let's go over
any of that bit. So it's the same. I don't know what it's doing.
I actually don't know what this is happening. you
I need it.
It's uh, the only guy who's been here at least in a super simple
but subtle sense of this room used to be. We'll,
uh... Let's we Yes. Oh, uh, This room,
excuse me, is an L-shirt, burp,
and then you're just going to be down through this house and near this
house. And, uh,
why are the words in the pen,
my table all used to be that I'm all looking at.
Thanks for watching. We installed a new role in order to,
you know, shout out to all three leaders. This is it,
just now I'm back. I'll leave. You It's gonna kill a facility with all
the facts. You can't do it. You know what I huh?
You know what I'm gonna it into this? It's about to- .
Back to the door. So,
that used to be just a quad that went- .
. . . . . . . . . And late,
because of our personal satisfaction in the internet,
it's not. Just
everything with my monitor. And I want all this monitor.
And I know it. Subs by.zeoranger.co.uk So,
three time I'm in the zip, three or forty years,
I wouldn't have said it was back here. You know,
we're going to build an office above the shan- I don't know I'm
removing it, but that one's uh.
That was a good idea, I never looked. Hello? It's a good stage.
See you in the room.
See you in the room. See you in the room. Move.
All right,
that's it, you know, I don't.
You can link me to me to me too. Thank Oh,
you're gonna see me. You gave me a better way to run that.
that. My last day.
Oh, yeah. I think I did a video,
son. I hope that it was I'm trying to look
at it, and it didn't work, but that is probably my computer,
the one you- I think that it didn't, it was a weird spot on
the bottom. And I almost said it was fine.
Yeah. After a while to go. Bye-bye. Well,
uh.
I'll have this one last week, and I'll have this.
It's been a lot.
Yeah. and Alayah,
Consider it.
So, as soon as you're in the tricky house,
we're gonna go. to the Th-in-the-g-howamcamister.com.
It's and which, you saying?
Yeah, yeah. I'll ya. Bye. I had my own record,
but, well, I didn't look at it.
So, uh, this is the only one we got.
It was the only one we Yeah,
that was great. You know what I mean? You You know what
It's nice, it's nice, it's Solutions, Volcanic.
I'm not self-evitation.
Thank you. Okay.
Umm. Uhh,
uhh. Uhh. Uhh. Uhh.
Uhh. Jira,
Loom, MediRoute.
Take a look Thank you. Okay,
mmm,
mmm, mmm, hm. Hey, can you guys, I don't know what you're about to
snare around like that? Go ahead. Yeah.
You know what, BoxGenie, you put the shine in your nose,
cheetah, float it. I'm saying that I hate to die like that.
Nah. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Peace to me.
All right.
I don't know if I'm going to see any
letter. Uhh, I'm going to carry my knee going to,
I'm running everything through the show. I did a bit of the editing program,
creating the code, the story now. I'm welcome. And if the editing work,
I'm I'm going to be taking a tutorial in a first, with the speed
visit. I'm making the cut-ups very now,
you know, the environment supports, and then we can smell all that in the
end and say. ... Jira. And go around and go to the gears,
I want to make all this documentation, fire, if this is what you want,
I don't want to say do get active. Thank you. I actually want to
know that the electrical database portion is working and I'll take this exactly,
you know, to calculate. Good. Put it in the Jira,
and it'll be enough so that they have to go along
and you can see that it's soft, you know.
. But, I'm
gonna send you a second.
Bye, bye. So, I'm going to give you some of the answers.
I didn't think it was going to be a mess.
No problem. Let's do it. Okay.
It's really, really,
really good. It's chut this in a second. I know it's really good.
J-1-0, it's like a wire.
. That's 5 10 7 10 12 10
I'll
sit with her in the morning like this. I thought I was going to
sit there and tell you. Thank you. Thank you very much.
Let's go.
We're going be on.
Ehm,
a snowman on blue and red and a bat.
Perfect. Okay,
so that's it.
Stump.
Mm-hmm.
Thank you.
Come on,
let's see what Good. Good.
Bliss.
you Yeah,
I have to recap.
Some people don't want to say to be honest, where they have a type
of care. . Jira, Loom, Confluence, Jira,
Just staying with the staff. Yeah, I was cutting it,
but people broke it. Yeah, yeah.
I am ready. I am ready. I don't know if I was watching her.
And,
I think I'm not mistaken.
There are permissions there.
There. There.
or maybe it's covered,
uhh, uhh, uhh,
you can set some bodies. Place.
Default, uhh,
workshop. So then they don't see their show.
Yeah. In many campuses,
they have been watching what it was today. Thank you.
Steven,
continue to work on the speed. Thank you.
from a better distance. Okay,
it's a day before you end. And then, You
want to start? We'll
Have
a good week. MSWordDoc Word Usually they, uh,
usually they have each other and you have to spend some,
it's just clogging. And that's
the best that one for you. Come on,
people. That's it.
You Okay,
let's take a little box. Thanks.
I don't know what type of music I'd expect of you to do this
to me. Haha, what were you expecting? I don't know what I'm expecting.
I don't know for electric park assignments,
but since my case here days, let's do it.
I was building a park, even though I barely like all the stuff.
I like the car. There you go. That's amazing.
You never really know. Oh,
I'm not sure you need- In a country, you need that.
E.D.M. and the other kids.
There's only two kids, visit Patrick Foster.
That's Good. Yeah. I said, I can listen
up, you can accept jazz. I just don't get jazz.
It's just like, how can I play it as off as
possible, but still, it didn't be considered.
Zoom. I still like classical art too.
Yeah. Yeah. I
want to see you change, David.
Oh, and you're at Red Rocks, whoo,
Denver. It's like I'm here to be so whole.
Oh. But it's not a good story to me. I saw him last year.
He thought through songs. I didn't get her tape back in the book.
Okay. Uh, well, he did a big concert again.
Uh, so, uh, it a big thing.
He won. He was the one over there. He played 30 more.
So, I was like, he I it's, you know,
wherever it is, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's,
it's, it's, it's, it's, it's with.
And this. It's, it's really good out of here.
It's, it's, it's,
it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's,
it's, it's. Awesome I'm, I'm really,
really, really, really, really, really in the top.
That was fun. Bye so all of the Eagles last year
just for you. Ah, that was really good.
That was good. That was good. I'm really,
really, really good at that man. . . I can see you by the
time. In the spirit, you've been inside them and have you got all these
custom, more than little pants,
metal panels. That's it. The command I just left,
they didn't want. Oh, okay. That's what's going on. I haven't been in my
shell yet. We'll to We easy for make a Okay.
That's it. And if we're going to make It's a, uh,
it's a production, you know,
it's, we might not have a response either.
and then I'll be in my club in there.
They won't let you stay in there in concert,
if they're afraid. You don't get to be on a toilet or something.
It's going to end. You know, it's your point of view.
It's your point it's your point of . .
T8 Spy is like,
I'm never gonna ignore about some of you people, because if you're not around,
watch and make it. Thank you. Okay.
You're getting all this dumped in here from the city.
Like. Chemical sites, and he can use a test-made man project
with that then. Now,
it's fantastic. So, there you It's the process in Compass,
I don't think it always, okay.
If all that was said, it goes for a person.
. . Yeah. I'm sure it's the best thing
part that it really- Hmmm,
that's
That's what I'm surprised me was a bit
of just room in here, but I'm exactly there,
isn't it? Power Flow,
Nurse. . .
.
Once in a total of a test year,
I think I'm going to do
this. . And, uh, 2005,
1971,
ehm, ehm. Nice. Nice.
Nice. Nice. Nice. Nice.
Thanks.
Okay. Two thousand pounds of making brackets.
Yeah, it looks just super simple. Thank you.
Yeah, that's why I was wondering how,
yeah, can you run this? I thought I'd have to put it in a
really good way. I'd say this. Go ahead and I'll end this if you
haven't said it. So what,
what would you guys do on your song, just change or play it?
for this. Umm,
I think that's, obviously, for running a specialty metal and a stainless steel.
You know. All of, um, we'll switch out,
um, I guess we're about on cutting,
right? We're going to have a first play too, so, um. You are the
likely guy. But I would imagine that the blades you use for a beam
to a good job cutting, you know, structure.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm probably going for a little bit finer,
but she's like the subject,
initially have. around.
Okay,
I gotta get my look on the part, it's just, that saw was working.
Bye. Bye bye. Hey, what's . Interrupting here, y'know,
I better just, uhm, for a day and change the blame,
go ahead. Good. By
the way, there is a limited thing about this.
Oh yeah. Okay. Yeah, I've had a few weeks ago,
so probably closing out some of your television projects would be good.
Good. V. Ehm, V.
Ehm, V. Ehm, V. Ehm, vignettes, and the filter list reveals all the jobs.
Nice thing. Good. Yeah.
You
So I
guess give you a question and job don't automatically close the nation.
Be sure. The jobs they are there.
So, if everyone seems to want to do it,
but how did it cause a little p- We'll see you on the I've
got a change. That's what I've used to be.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, I think we should develop for that.
We've got a long note. Thank you. Yeah, it's an amazing system we use
automatically to build on shipment, the most important people would have to open it
back up soon. You need to do the final thing with
it. Then we can set the clothes on where to be on to clothes.
...
I don't know if this is good or pickling.
I'm curious, pick that product and it's just one lot.
Right there in the blue bit. Good. Yeah,
this one, uh, will be certainly, it's, we're talking like,
yeah. Good. Then
open up one of those and uhm,
or hit the eyeball next to one of them. Bye.
I'm
curious about, uhm, okay. you and
hit the process. The last
year before the morning. You might be the only
thing is,
you Thank you. You can buy no cat vegetables,
you couldn't. So you've only waited for that.
It's really gary to the eyeball.
a lot more. Over there's a process like we did that it tells you
a ton of love over. Yeah. Thank you.
Yes,
and that's what, that's what we were able to You The
logic's not in here. Here it is. Make sure that it does that.
There, uhh, cause, you know,
when they pay up, it's like the actual one,
man. Bye. Yeah, it's, it's not often you don't,
but I'm gonna get it on there, and so,
but it will allow you, so if it's- the Jira,
Loom, MediRoute, Loom, MediRoute, Loom,
MediRoute, Loom, MediRoute like one forward.
So, You can say I've got four of those in there,
right there, to process all four boys.
Interesting to take that time.
Bye. One, two, three, eight, five, and I don't.
Five and five, eights. But there must be some little slope in
Something.
Well, I guess what I'm saying is you can really get done very unusually
in the mix. Thanks. Stuck, because they're just so slightly different.
Yeah. Yeah.
Now, if you add- Have a nice day.
I've got lots in your nuts.
You can probably eliminate all those different blanks.
Thanks. And just let the extra stick out and blow your nuts
on a 74mm. Yeah, that, there we go.
and then we'll, we'll get some more help.
So I think it, you know,
somehow identify. Bye Oh,
I haven't figured that. Did you see how close that worked?
And what? Ls are the rings.
Oh, that's the drop. Bye bye. So, can I go back and
go here? See,
these are 10,000, 6, 3, 1, first. Never.
If you're a bar and it's 21st,
we can bike through this channel. If I need it,
it's easier We're going to talk back to it.
It kinda got here, it just drops.
So, yeah. So if you,
You You can win for 20s,
but is it, You can create a stock list that lets you win the
films in 12s? Thank very much. Yeah,
yeah, I combined the next 20s and 12s and 22nds and 20s.
Support. or, But it's always looking for the,
well, the message factor.
So, it's gonna try and, uh,
I mean,
that's the worst, it's the best possible.
So, what's the uh, 9-5-9-5,
and 7-8 should drop in there? Okay. Yeah.
Yeah, that's what you're going to be talking about.
Yeah, we're in, and we're going to start ahead for it. Just come through.
We're going to pay back for this, and take it for the sixth.
Yeah, thanks for- All of my accessories are dropped in way too much.
Yeah, we're gonna be followed.
That's, that's our problem. I'll see you in the next video.
Please be sure to hit the subscribe button for And
try to leave a leave. If you need any,
you know what we have when it's ready to work.
That's an odd one. Give it a little finish. I'll see you in the
next video. Jira, Sennie,
B. Go.
Team B, uh, Team B, um, B, um.
... Yeah,
at the city. Only thing at the wall at least. . . I was
like, did you have a little bit of a check?
I don't know, how will that be like a monkey pet?
you have a little bit of a spider.
Pretty big, but it's quite a long time.
Uh, this one was- That's what we wanted to ask Jimmy is if it
was- Well, I was the threaded end.
Is it a drought with the threaded end? I don't know,
it's a double sh- Shout as a prayer. Have a thrill at the bottom
of the correct space. Umm, or,
cause it needs to be bought and resolved for it, or,
Uhh, well, by that endowment,
it's not right, it's not right, it's it's not That's what I believe is,
is tuck and stone. I'm Nope.
Uh.
And I'd be surprised if they would spend the end and be so much
leverage. that is a. . . It's just been an offer. You think you
have full of trust and okay ability from that.
But, I have seen great new things,
so. Hello. It honestly,
you would think that there's a supplier that just supplies the store out of
the grass, and it was your own- I'm pretty sure I can
find some videos.
It's so small. Almost.
Oh, maybe that's the least market we're getting into.
So, you know, I never really helped.
Thank you. They got a hope that somebody looked,
uh, see if they could buy a hat,
and then they said, well, for this part, We can do it way,
you know, for after price, and,
For the lead time is,
Three months and we need them in three weeks.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't, I don't see any issue in the middle of this thing.
I'm only one of the educators, but,
I mean, this is, We've rained on the initial projects through here,
in our eyes, in night, day,
for anything to run. Yeah.
Yeah. That's, I mean,
I guess, I guess, I'm not even there. The XLM protocol.
I've given them the examples, the XLM policies,
same. . . So, would you take the time in their
database to get rid of that?
. I've been trying to put the right stuff in so I can't afford
it. Yeah, I mean, it was all throughout. I think it's just going in
and switching to all throughout. Good. Good. It's going to keep the same,
it's going to keep the same logic so it's not even going from a
linear to a plate. you I'm going near you,
just have to operate with a rod and go.
Don't. Have an inch.
It's going to be a massive amount of length,
and we're going to keep the same length,
so it's going to be all closed. that is, I was saying that I
haven't been across the border, so,
and that, I can get a 140% hand.
So, but. But, Actually,
it's one of their songs, but it's different.
Did you make the head of peace tracking on or about?
Watch. Uhh, I think it's the people.
But yeah, that's the people, the people for that.
So, peace tracking is on for a- everything is all around me and sending
me roads and the apartments. Okay. So, and then, uh,
so now, Okay.
and on there So have to Okay. Now we have cut saw and burn
routes that are just for parts and then we have,
uhm, I'm faking wild for the main assembly.
Gotcha. Gotta change that symmetry.
Thank much for your attention. Beep, Beep, Beep,
Beep, Beep, Beep
Perk? Should I have this
shit? Thank you.
Big confirm,
alternate way of middle,
you know. and It'll
be a long time. It'll a long time.
Yeah.
That's why I don't really use it for a tune. That's fine.
It's fine. It's good. It's good.
I'm mad. and Abatl, F.S.E.R.T.T.S.R.T.T but that's because I think, know, you really have
to ask for a part of this.
If I was ready to tell, let's show you the channel and,
uh, I'll never agree with the end of the fact that I forgot to
like piss off my toilet with you. Thank So.
Look at her. She's freaking making my way to me.
Piss up the courtesy for you. I'm like,
what you telling me on? So yeah, like,
ah. Sorry I forgot I was freaking moving.
I'm gonna pick up all of them then.
You He
used be my boss. Jimmy used to be, you know, Donna Stanley.
Thank you very much. Jira
was quite honest,
and Jimmy was like, you know, it's been hard when he came and I
bought it. But my
interview was, uh, I don't know where,
you worked hard. All right. No job.
Just don't even worry, you can go right in. Uhh,
we'll figure that out on Monday. Let's see it, 6 a.m.
Alright. Alright. That's when I got all the books for Valatrol and I just
started reading. Ha ha ha. Ready?
I'm here. Thank you. Thank you. I'll see you Bye. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I wasn't gonna figure that one out.
And this one was a lot easier. We'll have more uh,
more videos for it. Thank attention. And a minute. Thank you. Yeah,
yeah. So, look. That's very fascinating.
Well, that's a lot more flexible to the uh, 20 version.
I think it's a lot of the same type of paper to a model.
Yeah, no, I didn't. Here's where you do this.
Let's go right. They'll last me in business. Thank you very much.
Yes. Uh, you know,
put it in here. Especially,
estimate. It's hard to get this by you.
. . I'm sure if you know what I can.
I'm not sure if you know what I can.
I'm sure if you know what I can.
But, uhm,
I also have to do all my manual world paper apps.
Ohhh. Yeah, pretty cool.
Buying your stuff, your wash with 90 gums to calculate the molds,
everything else is easy. I get all the rest of the dust.
But the world take us over and over 90 gums to each joint.
Well, it's not the issues. Yeah,
and then. So. Oh That's the advice.
You have no paper tokens, and I'm over the shop next month that I
had a version of a separate opportunity. This is,
I don't know, two years ago.
And, there in the estimator,
one of the negative and everyone in here.
here. It's in the light of your kids,
let it do the kind of thing. He was adamant that you want to
admit it. But I have not said a list of letters and all of
it will be- I'm like, why are you doing this?
Why are you having that baby? So it's taking a look for how long
you're listening, you know. Well,
that's it. Exactly. I don't want to be curious to see what she'll do
on that night. I'm not. Hey, hey,
hey. Goodbye. Go ahead. That's uhm,
that's a, as we say, 3.20.
We'll see you in Okay, yeah,
well, 3.20, 3.20,
18.20, 19.00.
All right. Yeah, yeah,
When there was a phasing came over and then we got to the point
where we were like, pop up. We ain't sayin' shit.
Yeah. Dude, we can't do shit over and you're using that.
I don't care. I'm gonna say,
okay, I guess I'm gonna do it. You put people in a bigger setting
and we're working on that and we're facing the- And then they're not really
building things, I can't even gain that in school.
I love going to shops and then say,
alright, go My Monday, here's where we're shopping,
so I get it. I'll just run it down and then I'll feed it
out a little bit. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, that's how I wasn't this.
I, uh, when I started applying it for permission to make it every day
and it's similar. Yeah. It is, you like it.
Oh. What happened with that? Okay. Yeah.
Alright. I'm gonna figure I'm gonna fix it. And it's good.
Okay. Alright. That's how you do your pins out.
Go. I'm gonna get the benefits that you may or may or may not
work through. So, yeah.
Which, now I'm not even allowed to.
You to be a lot of different things in New York.
Honestly, we're introducing all the things that have been really impossible,
and that haven't really had the beats in town. Most people know,
I had to use it, but,
um, yeah, most people don't have to.
Um, I mean. You are invested by this stuff in this film.
It's all projects and running on myself.
the whole thing. I didn't want it against it.
Our break off was, if it was detailed as a production job,
it wasn't detailed. Yeah.
I figured that's where it's going to be. It's for some local contracting.
It's not going down. We probably ran a couple of million dollars.
And it's great for, you know, all the impotory and it would be a
week.
We could create the invoice about here and,
uh, so it was good for any type of stuff, but it's 100% paper
drive. B-I-T-R that you hate to anything.
I'll be able to agree. So, uh,
ask. Oh, I was gonna ask you how strong the invention is this year.
Yeah. Go. It's good. It's, it gets better in the,
uh, I try to get them to do more sessions.
I did. On 1 3 2 sections. Um,
but I figured, yeah, the more sessions they do,
the more people you come. Uh. And now let's go.
Let's go. I'm gonna get yeah, I'm scared. This is good.
Yeah, the problem is it's a bill. Yeah,
so they've not heard it yet. good. And,
uh, uhm,
uhm, uhm,
uhm,
and, uh, they have this to integrate with the PTO system. And do it
all that. Yeah, yeah. Go.
So anyway,
it's too long, it should be me. Then.
and it's not a woman,
man. They ain't, they ain't, they ain't.
The cool thing about it is, you know, they, they are a bit of
a help. No. No. I want to hear from you and what you want.
This is like, they did one session. We'll bring a,
we'll bring up the video on it, but. Hello. Hello.
I do one session where it's like, okay, here's what's coming,
tell us what you think. Umm,
although their thing was, here's what.
I can't really say what's coming,
I what's coming, that's,
umm, terrible. I don't know where you're going.
Umm,
there you're going. Yeah,
okay. Restarting these are Cutless. Close. Use them more back into the bottom of
my patient. So that's, yeah,
multiple shots. They've always seen their shots.
Umm. So I'm estimating,
this is, this is not a big hit for this and I have multiple
meetings with him about it. You umm,
there's plenty of estimating so that you can get a breakdown
vibe of it. Multiple different things.
I'm not sure about how we want to get. But what I asked is
in the, uh, estimate summary.
Great. You can get a summary drop at the top and choose Costco
and it'll get me over this and now I cost it.
Which, you don't really- I-I-I asked him there and I wanted to
have an option there to work category with some category.
and H, Indian Custom Peel,
but I need some. I didn't break down this. That's like, pfft,
pfft. See you. You Quiet,
it's like, I need, uhh,
I need a dollar or this building of that.
That's how I can say it. Good. . . . . . Yeah. .
. . and it's going to be able to do that?
You don't really actually have to wait doing that,
yeah. Yeah, that would be pretty interesting because
when you have to say, put it in active, building A in the EECI.
whatever. So, it's terrible there.
That's the one. That's the one. So, I should deal with 4.6 to 2.
I love it. Well.
Or, just, you know, say the D-SIS,
go back. Uh, you,
will be able to say nothing,
ships, or let's say- Nice and deep, which has never been a thing,
but that'll be an option just by a one for a long time,
and I'm really fascinated. Thank for your attention. Uhm,
we'll be able to attach documents on Loom's screen for your
share. Good. Uhm,
some of the numbers are b******. Can you access a bread over it?
Yes. Oh, no. Okay.
Thank you for going. You're going to be able to find the eyes from
you. She might get it if you want to. Nice.
us. I don't have any more more in them there.
I just feel like that's all I can do with everybody.
Yeah. Yes. I get stuck with every single one I've ever done.
Yeah. Oh, you got any of that?
Okay. it. Now I didn't,
uh, now I didn't, it's, uh,
I'm here to make a sin anyway,
so we have no- problem with it, as the way I've gotten in favor
of coming back. We've got a length,
a slice, and a little bit of 23rd make order.
We have a sin- So, So, the sin of the leg is going to
be all proper, but everywhere, you need to know that,
of course, you're wearing a QLQ next. So,
uh, for that. Well, you know,
they have a recession that works like it.
How should we be this, what should we be a lot of this,
and, uh, a bunch of stuff, so. Thanks for watching to see you to
get your vision friends. Yeah, through your own,
what the real world's thinking. Yeah.
Yeah, that is, I can care.
You know, you're interested in Davis, that's a perk that,
uh, I want to, uh, I'd follow you until I go,
I ask, have you ever been to the community? Yeah. Yeah. All right.
It's,
uh, I'd ask you to expand some confidence.
They didn't even have a box of nourishment playing better.
I was just, you know, all about Atlassian,
it's work, but, you know,
it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's,
it's, it's. See ya! I'm about to, I don't know.
Yeah, absolutely. But, okay,
okay, okay, okay. I don't know how to say this,
I'm 17. 3 6 7 8 8 8 8 8 8 8
That's what we're going to see.
We're going to send an order to you now to speak. It's okay.
It's faster. It's better to send it off.
Yeah, there we go.
They're going to send me in now. And uh.
That's it. How's that? I don't care.
Send me no more of a beating on the ground over the ground.
I'm going to be able to steer you to this. Cheers. And then they
went to that, uh, I conventionally Chicago for all the equipment.
That's it. Yeah. Yeah.
And, uh, we had, like, five parents of a fat attack and then spent
all this motor phone ever here looking at the equipment we were never- gonna
buy. And they're like, oh, it's kind of single waste.
Yeah, that was a waste, we did that was a waste,
we got into- Terrible mentions,
wouldn't have been a waste. I would have taken notes out of it and
tried to have a good tip when it- you. That was-
that was purely knowledge, that was truly, yeah.
Bye bye. Just, let's see if you got a serious buy,
not for some equipment, before you go into it.
And being a developer, and, uhm.
I'm like, that's really hard, we should never ever want,
we could get it.
Maybe. Hey. Yeah,
I used to send two people out for a year.
Like, yeah, I don't think so. Yeah.
. What you already do, not to wear a bottle of bitters,
can't see you anyway in there. Okay.
You better than you are shopping for a bunch of,
you know, starting to shop. You see every bite of it.
Yeah. Have a good night. Bye. So,
that was the AGT that was here the other night,
was that correct? Yeah. Yeah,
that is, You Who's looking to find that?
Who's the, who's the lead video on that?
Mark. Mark, hear what I think. Yeah,
here's what you should, Here's a bit of something to consider.
Yeah, I mean, Dr. Mark, because,
umm, oh. Oh.
I was all made up of that. I traveled to their place at the
end of it and then checked out. I'd walk with the program and we're
just, you know, simple. all the time. And then it fully wants his,
uh, a lot of them. Yeah.
Who wants a good form? Um,
so here's where about it, man. But. Bye. This is the tournament.
It's not, it's not P.A. and well, sure.
They see that, that isn't.
And then. you You put a bit of this,
uhh, in space, but it was your case.
And, um, fair, you download from.
You don't think the structure is yours or it's not even their software.
It hurts, but it ain't okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. So, what's the best way to weld this?
Yeah, I mean, check with any guy in the video, or if you check
me, what else I hate to do. Thank you so I want to do
anything like that. You know, I gave him a lot of that.
So, um, uhm, uhm,
uhm, ehm, ehm. leave torsion piece that we ran on on literally 12 to
12, 5, 16, it's two, it was a few problems,
but he wasn't that like, I'm sure he wasn't that much.
And it took 14 minutes to run,
uhm, sir. Since, uh,
congratulations to you guys, uhm,
we had to- We had 6B correctly,
uhm, 6B per cell, that we don't see the lapping sport.
We did a 40- so the R
You put the uhh, unfamiliar with it. Yeah, you put it,
yeah, it looks like a witch activity, right? You put it in there. There.
And the other thing is that computers won't,
won't be able to beat that and love it, but, well, let's go out
and get it. And then the other thing, uhm, the other thing,
uhm, the other side, yeah,
well, you're not necessarily in the station,
you're just able to track the other side of it.
So, uhm, bellow. You know, I don't have tools,
I don't have tools like something like that,
and, you know, wow, that's well there.
You want to- the other side, somebody's setting it up again,
and the one that I saw were brocheting,
so it broke. room. I'm saying the PC and this thing would well
do exactly what you're saying. Yeah. On the other side,
they're blooming the next PC. See you Yeah. And then,
yeah. And to be like 180 and start going on again.
So they, they, we,
we got. One step to start with.
We bought a single cell ring, and so it,
it was a 40th book. You have 40 foot bag of those in it.
And so, one piece was edited.
Then that was better pulled out, we made a of a real MediRoute.
Bigger, Ramon, London, and Travis is a 2-7,
so you got one of these here. Thank you. One piece at meter,
so off-wind me of this case, you're ever you're tacking up on this.
And then once done it, it gives you another structure.
Then we pull this left. And then start tacking the other up.
And to me, it wasn't working then. Because,
like, we, We would tack up, we'd have a bag,
and the beverage on this side, we would tack up on this side,
and it would fall as well. you And then bring the PC,
pull this piece out, bring it up and PC into it.
I didn't feel like it was worth an extra.
Thank you. Bye. $100,000,
you should be at another area for us to pack up. Yeah,
I'm just going to see what they look at. They sent it for work,
maybe about- You know,
five minutes of time to pull a piece out of another wheel.
Uh, uh, uhm. How many pieces were you in front of?
Um, so there are, uhm, like all those trunks or columns.
So did that, and wouldn't it do teach a lot of that until we
read the subject show? Umm,
we were getting about, well, we're getting columns a day.
Don't worry, shit, excuse me. Can we get columns and shit?
Uh, uh, uh, so. Can we know what you have to do?
How do we have to do?
Like, uh, 10... Uh, uh,
uh, I mean, that was really the redder,
most of the country people, so it's cost me a little bit.
So, okay. Yeah. Okay, so, so we had Seth and he's,
we're giving him room. Yeah. Tryna,
I got a video of it growing, but, You Yeah,
I was always just, how many pieces do you have to jump by and
cross them with a crystal set up for this community.
Thank Something all the time, okay. They would do the working without further building
their hand to pull over the machine. That's it.
So yeah,
it was, it was working like,
and I think we made like, I don't know what's coming up.
Since then, but I think we made like, 600,000 dollars for,
uhm, hang on.
So. That's it. That's southern work.
That's a good machine. Thank you. I think,
yeah, there's a fair and real options out there.
They're gonna be double.
I love it. It's a trip with the money,
too. And we were striving on all pieces so they lay out it and
fit up as nothing, you know. We took a job for Solar
Farm on some of us.
Alright.
And we had one of those winter machines.
Yeah. So,
And we had a table that rotated on this side so we could weld
on this side, weld on this side. Yeah.
And there was table on this side, weld on. This side,
not on this side. I think it got into a 6 ring,
a column of columns, but Yeah And,
you're literally for us in the, as the welding was so.
Go. Quick. Yeah.
And you really just had it done all your parts tax.
You know, everything had to get. . . And everywhere you go,
barely attacking it. But the biggest problem was that it was spinnicky,
but the piece had- . I had the exact same thing in the right
place. Yeah. And I hear that the vision system got better,
and so the vision- It wasn't there, it stopped.
Yeah, the ACT will do that, too,
until it's- . . . it scans and partially because it's actually- .
. it scans and partially at the pace of the bed that they don't
stop. Wow. Uh,
simple, flat, but right here is popped in and it's just,
it's scaring that wall and it can be in the tube,
so you don't have to change the size. I'm gonna read this a minute.
It makes it burning. Good morning. Not
bad.
Alright. Alright. So that thing with,
umm, we had one within the first month or two.
I mean, yeah, we were just going to pull down with that.
No. And that, uh, well with this,
uh, then it was going down the other side of somebody's birthday,
and it hurt me, but you don't all stop. And,
And that big carriage was going down,
and I'll stop, and cool, but shootin' over a puff.
And so I talk to him about, I'm like, yes,
we got a big problem. And if we got a lot of work in
this, uh, home, we're at it. And yes, we call him nuts.
So, very, very, very, probably that's it.
I have a flight. We looked. I have a tarantining.
I'll give you a list we can make in your place.
Uh, maybe they didn't want to like this. . . Absolutely.
It's, uh, very good experience. And I,
uh, got us back with it. I also want to say good ideas because
it's not only a real tanger. You just like when we first got,
we, we needed it so bad that we're like,
okay, we're okay. We just want to read it. So we're like.
I'm putting it up on a box for now. So this was before we
had the, before we had the regimes.
You're gonna have to rotate. It just take four times.
Yes, so it, it's always worth playing.
Sure. It's, uh, yeah, it would rotate four times.
So. So. Yeah, so you can do it right if you have a no-chader.
Yeah. Bitbucket, this was quite competitive.
So, but yeah, they will not be ready to hit.
I was to want that to, you and then what's the reason to,
yeah, you should work in, uh, on its own. So,
uhm, how much was that? Six hundred,
that one? Give us six hundred. A thousand, we're weak on it,
but I'm hearing it's eight, nine hundred thousand,
something like that. I'm very much ashamed to be by those.
You just give the full cost back. I love you.
I mean, I like clean, it was clean, it was pretty fancy.
Yeah. I think
I was close. You was concerned about it, it was more than really more
relevant. How easy was it going to be to
get lead?
Umm, the software into their software,
from detailing it with their software, else.
I didn't want to put some money on some- Thank you. I paid it
all just to do that, you know? And it was honestly
seamless. It's literally an extra- or an import.
Then it was a once in a while, that German public equipment sent me.
I'm like, do you guys stop? Get out of the shit in the US
in case something goes bad. I'm not here, I'm
ready for a good suit. I don't know. But they were awesome.
They were awesome.
They were awesome. Specifically. Cool. And
this was pre-COVID when I was looking at it. Welcome,
everybody.
All right. I'll see you Bye. Thanks, Josh. I feel like I'm a smart
person. I think he was in here with a practical worklistening.
Um, so I kind of wanted to be coming to the,
uh. Bye. Congrats on the planet,
you know, future production, the entire production work that I'm going to do is
so that it's important. I think that's been a really good example.
We'll go. Yeah, I mean, too. I bet,
uhm, I'm sure it makes the most work of bad,
but I'll be his bad. It's good to be bad.
Yeah, catch. See It's the liquid use and set up already
on it, and get it to have a set of the departments and stuff.
Yeah, so yeah. Yeah. Yeah,
I know what we've created and what we've created and what and what we've
and stuff.
So,
yeah. And then combed. And then,
Emily cuts off right in fit.
Well, combed semi. I'm D,
Trumpet, Stone, and Umsen in the Lane in the water control.
AC Adler is going to allow us slowly to see.
Thank Future. So that's where you can bail into the future.
Okay, what you've got next job is 50.
Good. Five hundred hours, or at least a pound for any medical.
Plug it in there for the eight year savings,
but you don't have it on there. . . So essentially,
is this a second form,
form of failure,
I guess? Thanks. Yeah, you'd have to have the job in later,
better. I don't know what we're doing here. Compass,
how does it know the resource was- We'll see Yeah,
it pulls up from estimating questions why it's so critical that the estimated
they use I know your case,
I know your look at that because the advantage of all those different departments
and then it goes to spread out. So,
uh, it's- it pulls it for this, and it's,
uh, and Bitbucket also clearly must somehow know how many people you have,
and it's, it's important. We're going to send it back.
Yeah, so they've got the resource to say that,
so I cut sauce out of those with the hours.
I Nice and we approach control
and then, uh, application maintenance.
. , uh...…igh,
you know. Wimb a workshop,
PTorch. That's what he said. . alright. .
of your shots. Any of the different work areas,
do we set up work areas? Go ahead. Okay. I share my video I'll
right. I'll just go. Okay. Done. Alright. So,
cool. Close this. And then, yeah, I can go to the other part of
the maintenance. tuned more.
And in just a few Okay. And we'll One of the things you're trying
to do is try to go on schedule five days,
uhm, and then, so.
You can essentially do that here,
so. Yeah, right.
I hear it like handling is set for 60 out of a week.
Then, cutsaw at under 60. Stay.
So, so, you, you can build that up here.
You don't know the booksheets that you want about that.
Yeah. In different materials.
So. Like, you can have, like,
a single, it happens in multiple ways.
You can do work here. Later. I have different ways,
like, oh, no shock, don't be scared. I was going to have to work
with a shock and pop, which plays the deal with us and the guy
that had to do. We'll see you in the next That's my capacity.
So, they do so in different ways.
So, if you guys real-time, I guess, the wanting. Thank you for it is,
it does really look at the hours that you have been working.
It's looking at pieces that are done.
you So, uhm,
where the rest closed after. So,
deciding to look at that. This, this video was on you,
look at it now. It's looking at the hours playing in first and year
capacity, but whatever you work is,
whatever you work is history.
. Just planning to work this kind of stuff.
So the plan is now to plan- Bye.
Plan is, it can be done by my diverse war opponents.
Yes. And you could, and you could. Thank you very much.
I said both, and it will not cut out between the two so you
can see that one. Yeah,
our intention in- And we'll see that,
essentially, with our work back into this,
we build- bill. We build this to populate the hours to be here,
and then go into the construction planner.
You can be like these for a time, if it's only about a week,
only to see. I'll re-essentially begin to use that,
uh, however, so there. Thank you. Yeah.
Hey, that's why I'm
gonna be, Really nice to get it
linked up to you.
That's my, uh, link up this link.
So there's an average just showed up and you're about somebody,
and it's more like somebody having to sit there and say,
well, what kind of split do I think this is. You know,
that's very beautiful. And what the toggle that says,
this is the likely job to land. Thank Yeah,
the way they built this, initially it was the only work that you had
released. release. It's,
sure. Now they've got to deal with works like they've got to leave this
job and unwinds me earlier. It's time to bring,
and then add. That's where Lisa's, and so I'll put that on the stage.
It'll still be better than we can plan for it.
But as you get Lisa's, it reduces. Be sure to subscribe to that plan
more, right? So it will take a bit of time,
which is a revolution there. So let's say you've got a,
you're released for a bit later. I'm gonna say,
you've got your land in the work, which you're the release step,
but it's coming in time, you wanna say,
if I can take this- Yeah, so you can put it in a
future job as a- Go.
And put it in there and say,
hey, what else is new for me here in that apartment? Yeah. It's gonna
be cool. it. . Let me have a look at that in an Microsoft
product. It's hanging fast. Yes,
it's hanging fast. Cause you're going ahead and schedule a lot of lighting and
into you. Level some and I'll level up everything.
And some more like that. Kill myself.
Yeah, this doesn't mean we don't have anything.
So it's like. It's not going to be like, okay, I can stay here
four times or four times when I pass it in my luncheon.
It's not going to level up all morning. It's going to be time.
for you to make those decisions for,
you know. So, which is good in a lot of ways,
but uh, ways. My role is always to take a lot of future and
easy work if it's hard working better. Think about it a bit more.
Yeah. I In this industry,
it's hard to say, okay, just let all this happen because everything works,
right? Let all this sh- tippet, yep,
so that. Now,
in this part, we need to be adjusted.
Just because when we set this up we know how you
have a different place to get a job.
But either of us having to use this at all,
or if we're pretty much done nothing,
and uh, we'll ever get that. So that's it. Yeah, that's what we're
doing. Definitely. So, I mean, we can run with it right now,
and then I'd say that, and then we'll smart get to- and then we
can kind of go through, uh, like, gambling,
I guess, $60 a week.
Ah, I mean- I mean,
I guess you're not handling a week.
Well, the channel is there too, it's over for that next video,
guys. That's it.
It's not like you're processing that handling session for a job, so it's quite-
I mean, to have that on the schedule, so.
But, for me, I only never looked at I was
like, handling, well, we'll get our people to do the stuff we're gonna have.
Yeah. Yeah. And
from Will, you know, we could always cut it. It was cutting,
and the soap not cutting, and was not even mal-hard either.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So,
go back to your workout, and you can bring your plan right up again
then. Good. Or you can say the right time to talk.
Look. Look. Yeah,
so the idea is we got a week back. A week here,
then you're able to pull these packages over a drop of them a week.
And when you do that, it's gonna break out of the- of the- hours
by the apartment, so you go to the apartment view,
which is up there next to a rig's workshop to form,
yeah, or that way. You might hit the little square and get it.
So now we're going to break that by the apartment view.
You here. You
look at them. You know what works on them day by day?
That's a week, a week over there,
yeah. Yeah. And then,
so in that week, there's the packages for cut saw,
packages for burn. And then you're like,
is this action? I'm not I can. And so, like, when you first drop
it into a week, it's probably gonna drop cut saw,
burn, everything all in the same week,
right? Okay, bye bye. Now that's nothing gonna happen. You gotta cut it before
you fit it. You gotta fit it before you right? So,
then you might be moving these packages around to say,
okay, cool, we're cutting it this week and burning it this week,
but fit well, it'll be next week. So, you pull those down into the
follow-up maker or something like that.
So, in project,
you can have same starter,
you know. . . and after it's finished our,
uh, uh, I'm not going to logic anything.
And that's that's a reference. I do. This is.
The game chart not going like that,
which there is a game chart not going in here,
but not, not this schedule.
This. This is, this is very,
very much, you have to think through what's known way of.
So. So, And it's not going to land a lot out for me.
So. Please, well, here it is. It's a very- Thank you.
It's an way of putting blocks and packages in different places.
And then if you fill the volume up,
you better- Move. Adjustment.
Adjustment. Yep. It is.
I think, project will be faster than that.
Well. Well, You're telling the disconnect from the,
from the data. So, this actually does work well when you,
when you start working. you with it, uhm,
especially I think the package is here, but I'm not there.
I don't think you're in movement of the rambling.
Okay. Yeah, sissy, the stuff we've been
having now, and it's, uh, a hundred and ten feet tall.
A whole lot of baggage, you know, two hundred,
uh, baggage. So, this TMC,
uhm, Phatree,
uhm. So, that one will be a
little bit more.
. . I And now I'm in progress with the release
of the shop, and Monday and next week we have to have it done
by 12. . .
The band is here because, yeah,
I might have to turn that now to another week, but I don't have
to build the project, but I don't have to be in the sandal.
I don't want to build the job help. I don't want to be able
to add on a bit of a hero. I don't want to do the
accepting. That's what it means. I don't want to be able to do a
Microsoft project, but it's like,
you know, that's a win. So, I want to do it.
So you're saying like 12th of January,
you have to be done? Mm-hmm.
So you're basically giving yourself 15 days from your eyes.
Plus, to produce $69,000.
Well, really, it's $2,200. Outers Yeah.
Yeah.
Pretty work here, you sense? Next.
And, uhm,
unless the work has justified over the beats.
So, you have a 14-night career. Yeah,
that's fine, you know, just chill. You've got 20-night career.
You've got beats over the bars. Always.
It's Let me have more.
Do you think that's hard for you to do? Do want someone around to
buy them? No, I think,
I think it'll be good. I think,
uh, I think it'll be,
is that a little bit big, uhm. . . because there will be other
products that we can be living So what tricks are we going to have
to help you know?
I don't know anything. Oh,
nothing. I see it. Yeah.
Be the only one that we have. Hello. you We are getting more of
it than we do at Destiny's. We know that this is 2,100.
We have this 2,000,000,000.
I'm talking. We are more of we do Destiny's.
We are getting of it than we do at Destiny's.
is that? We have to get a couple of those never, you know.
We only do have to go when we do this together, but I'm going
to have to be a tech incubator. Alright.
I'm a little more upset about getting, they're not coming from Corona in the
hot, they're coming from either one. I didn't see the rocket.
I'm just going to get a dollar for it, bro. 96% of the world
that's, you know, on shop, it's going to be in March.
you uh, estimating, reaching out to our fun facts,
and we are both. That's great. I'm heading to L.A. and P.A.R.R and
P.A.R.R.R.R.R.R.R.R.R.R.R.R.R
I think we're going to be in the moment of being marked for biddies.
I think we get all of us over at ASN because we're going to
be able show up soon. you We're going to be interested in that,
you know, we're going to slow our opening.
We're, you guys are just having fun, you know, we're to slow our opening.
You're working with that son. You're other than with that then, yeah. That's it.
I'm not going to be asking a question again. I'm sorry. Yeah.
I uhm, I think it's been for a fall of, a little bit of
a on the United States for a couple of years.
Alright, we're. So the,
the stuff that come on,
you know, uh, is hot. It's your all-round country,
aren't it? day. Getting jobs, we don't want to hear it,
comes with the country. Sounds like it.
Yeah. Oh, okay. Yeah.
So. So. Yeah, I'm going right down this porch now.
He did look better than he did. If you have a bus,
you can do a good job. and that's what Muncha Ops, But, in the
technique, here you're gonna be! Hm, hm,
hm, hm. You better nest with us,
here you go! And then a minute. So, actually, we need an un-gardless internal
of an hour of spending. Let me have a minute.
So, let me have a minute. Please. Let me start with the guys at
the same time. I mean, like, one fifty, you know,
I actually got it. So.
But, uh, I don't- I mean, I was going back to that,
but, uh, yeah, it's been,
me and Mark, this and Baker here.
You if there's been a job eating the shop,
eating our, saw it out,
put a number of guests in it.
So, thank you. It's all the stuff I've invested in. So, a lot of
work. . . A lot of our numbers that are right now,
they're marked by annual take-out.
This is my take to take-out to be an us.
For you to be treated with that, that means we need to do that
for us. And it really does really check the line on the next meeting
department. So what's going on with the job,
like the, uh, water treatment fund stuff.
We've got those guys. These are. Later.
We're making those up. The PD is your day and themselves.
Umm. For a picture that can be,
be on. One. and I'm going to work a video down to work a
video down. And I'm going to release that with most,
most of the day, it will be accurate. On the set of A and
B, handbrails and canopy with gravel,
yeah. Family nose, canopy, swaying rails. Thank you guys.
Feathers, Vents, Nendways,
and the P-E, or are they using Tecua? That's what you want. And that's
it I'll see you in a couple of days.
Which has been given with a spreadsheet or something. This is where a lot
of them are using previous data. Never. So,
so that was it. I wanted to believe we fabricated this,
uh, 36, 24, 36,
48. We've got, we've got so many of those that they don't,
well, we're going to throw 30 hours in the mirror,
in the mirror. And we're going to do with 1,500 bucks in the cost
of materials, and we need to go forward for this product.
Let me know in if you know,
it's really all very surprising to me, you know.
It's hard to make a lot of money,
but it's awesome, it's awesome. What? And they can wear yourself with
that. Especially if you don't show yourself what you get.
See, you know. Bye. Kids heard about the hard job,
so, uhm, I made my job of tics a whole bunch of
time. And it was 10, 100,000 of it,
yeah, you know, hoo-punch. I,
I get mad into three, five million dollars. God bless you.
And it's not, you know, it's not like,
how would you say? I don't,
that's what it was. It was under 100, 100,000, yeah.
Good. I'd better be 50% wasn't worth it. I think this is happy to
have it. Otherwise,
it's not worth the stroking. Okay. You're very little bit business.
You scratch some attention from your eyes and stuff like that.
Some of this stuff ain't happening. I think.
But,
long road despite these guys, I'm Jamie.
Okay. I know- Good.
A big after-grant plan or something if you're not wearing it.
Big as it will. Well, I just sent out a snipe right here.
Thank you guys. I the very plan. I can see that,
yeah. We're doing everything in bed, white and blue, and this and then I
got all that. That's the correct. That's good fun.
you I forgot what I was doing now,
so you can find me.
Okay. Anyhow, do more work. . . . Yeah,
well, we're supposed to be the, this shiny star attempt,
but for all the other, shops. So,
we're supposed to refine our tech budget and everything.
Atlassian, new tech budget.
I love you. You know it there?
I'd like the idea.
That makes sense. But,
me and Mark are an active liver. Remember. We're living more in S34,
MediRoute. And best.
And now. And now. And then they'd still get a random attack,
a stroke, and a lot of them. And I was doing,
like, we're doing a lot of snicker. And Joss,
I'm going to get through the tackle.
That's the, that's the thing. I mean, it gives you so much.
There's so many. You even, even with,
uhh, even with the stuff you get from the next level and if we're
doing any structural for work that you have in your experience.
and I mean,
one of our biggest constraints is,
I get all this big. See ya. Materials and then I have to do
those sub data process and then they come back in and then they can
fit in well. I've checked, but otherwise
anything of their names should murder,
point and aim. . . and they went to go to third inches where
they went to go to third and being more level high in the car.
Thank you very much.
I'm gonna go there for a minute. This is just,
take two, one, three, and thank you. So,
bye! Lotta, we'll find it to be done,
but I, I, I, I think you think that the tech is gonna help.
Umm. So I was worried about that and now listening.
Hi, Jobs. Hi, Hollywood. We'll you in the next minute?
Umm, yeah, yeah,
it's like, if I really thought I was going to attack,
I'd get, went big job. Go! House.
They've got nothing to do with it.
I'm just going to buy, uh,
finally. I'm just going to shut the amount. Yeah. Don't right.
We will. Go.
Go. Be on and this work over here.
We're go there and we're going to do a little bit of well in
that here. Send the tag now against.
Okay, now that I'm going to go, and I'm going to- in a sense
that there's hexagonal field. Alright,
and I say, okay, in hexagonal field work,
we're seeing- I mean,
package is bad. There's this month,
uh, let's grab the work, uh, those I if we have any packages and
software. Yeah.
There's the other one that said, there's no other stuff before we gotta have
the equipment do that. You're in. It's actually going to be self-dortical.
Right. And if you haven't been on it for yourself,
I think we're gonna buy a certain notion.
I'm curious. Yeah. Alright, I'm curious.
I would just look at it,
what we know. I would do a- You know,
nobody really analyzes. Until Jack gave you just also analyzing,
that's why I knew these things because he's told me.
But I think Chris and Jira kind of were not
only winning 4% but they didn't really know the plays.
All guys. And so now the next thing is,
we need to scatter on this. What are we winning and what are we
losing? Or are we losing?
I a lot of the stuff that we should add a couple of dollars
in equipment to win more of that.
Yeah, I'm sure. Thank you. And I think stepping into the world of capital
is, like, three steps away.
At first we gotta say, Why is that? There,
there, there are many of them back to the job because the time has
been scraped in the, in the higher proper margins.
You think it's the other companies betting it hard to be able to
find who can cram it the other way. Could it be on front of
you to do different places? . . I think
that's what they- That's the strategy. Yeah, I think so. Yeah. The problem is,
is all the other places are actually busy. Yeah.
Get it. Cuz they're getting scared, they got to stay in the game too.
Cuz I really have to steal, but I don't know if I have to
be busy at the moment. Hey, uh,
bad luck. Bye I'm crazy, nice obviously I'm a bad guy,
I'm bit crazy. I'm just feeling welcome here being like,
I'm a good guy, I'm a good guy, I'm a good guy,
I'm a bad guy, you know I'm a bad guy,
you and all I'm not I'm
not better at a day than Disney radio.
Yeah. Thank you very much.
Oh, thank you. . I said my case and we seized that a little
bit of it. I think that's it this year. Yeah.
I got it. Thank you.
I'm gonna try to finish this year. So,
he said let's say they made a job in fact,
uh, moving and follow that stuff up.
Yeah, we're gonna do it. The release date has not fell over in the
next year. I know, but they got a certain portion of work that's been
done by March. Marching? Good.
Good. So the following year, 22,
27, 27, oh,
this is way in the future. Yeah. Last Last little girl.
Last girl. . . And everybody else is not. But if you look at
the schedule, so they can't do it good.
That's why I didn't do it quite. Bye. If I have a standard
team-minded company, it's not big enough. Maybe they are.
Yes, if it's near and halfway. Thanks. So, I would do so.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I think they are maybe a little more out of my head,
and they are maybe out. They are a little bit confusing that this is
more confusing. . . This March. It has worked for next March,
and it happened to the government in the next November.
That's why you only have really much. It's about 7,000 Suns.
It is from time it's then. It's not.
Okay.
It's having the parts of the kid. They're not going to go,
it's just going to make the member. It's going to be fine.
So it's a still very tight fabrication.
So that's why it's- They're making We're going to probably get- We really can't.
And the back of the skull of work, back of his work,
the right tool. You work back of his hip and back.
Staying on house is what I expect. Wait. Is that what's-
I want you to see your own. I mean,
I think you should have just run, but what's the- I to do a
little bit more for I'm going to and do it. I guess I can
make a question for like, on future work,
because session roll is,
um. Bye Chris
B. wants us, and covens,
too. You. Be able to,
you know, hungry. We've got a project that we
haven't worried. This is all the work we have.
Backed in the shop and it's scheduled out, and we got a new project
ordered, and we want to try and plug that one in the other system.
Or. All right. Even theoretical,
something that's not awarded, but we've got potential this many hours,
how to plug that. You kind of stuff in.
So, um, it would be a bit of our considerably
start to have me. Mm-hmm. Shob more in here.
And, something that's not,
it's just gonna money, it's just the most of these fake-out-the-jobs in the world.
Yeah, we're not, we might even have,
uh, fake-job that's,
you know, like, almost, I said,
you can plug in. Thank you. I don't see it as a body.
Yeah, I said one.
So, if it's within tech, uh,
this is the production line. You're not- I got a big chart,
that is a given me. Are they a main difference?
No. Uh, no, no,
no. So, I'm going to do that and then I'm going to do something.
you I'm to do that.
There's a phase. Will not want to get under and consider something
else. the There is a production schedule.
A little to the progress. Yeah. Umm,
that could be. You run as well.
So there's a big thing on just a more detailed and broad one.
And some people just want to be. See Bye.
I think we can look at that production scenario,
right? Yeah. So this thing only runs a week.
I'm going to say exactly. I think you can't do my own thing right
now. You guys already know. Yeah,
but you need to go over it. Yeah.
Yeah. Only one week to show it,
because there's so many, uh, guys. He's growing bad and we'll see you in
the other weeks. So. So, let's Yeah.
Yeah.
Y'allen it. So, yeah,
in the slightest one then you see there's two other,
you know, there's a can't chart one then no,
the- Come on. Project, schedule, all these opinions are,
umm, it's ever been a life of self-prompting,
like me. Bye. You know what?
It's right here. Yeah, we're a little bit, it's really right here.
Yeah. Oh, okay, I see. Yeah. We'll you in minute.
So, now, this can automatically build
a production scale. So. I love you.
But one, go to the drop down at the top, and go to production
scale. And, sure. Good.
Now,
then we'll get started at the research this year,
but, and then
just go further away. Uh,
so this is the product..
You actually stand with this link to the project.
Basically, it puts it out here and then you can scroll out to
the right. You see week by week, you've got a concacity,
like, first, a burn table, that's another 20 hour capacity.
Let's meet. I've never seen this really,
this is pretty cool. I mean,
so, this is, it's not a productive schedule for your watch.
Yeah. But I'm just going to confine area,
um, see, my head, cut area, burn area,
and all that. It's just kind of what we had over the years.
Are you ready home? I just wanted to organize it.
It's been a little bit more time. It's been a little bit worth it
with it. Yeah, it's cool. But this pandoon project sk- Digital.
This pretty much just creates itself.
It sprays the house out even easily for a long job.
problem. Then for all jobs. Okay.
We have to live for one, uh, but yeah.
Okay. Soon. Can you put a job in here then?
If you want to say hello. Yeah. Let's do,
like, a good option. Right.
I think, uh, it was early when I, That won't just be where it
said flat saw. And then it might open up,
or open up, open up, open up, open up, open open up,
open up. Which I wouldn't want.
Now there's all the jobs that are contributing to the welding guide source.
And let's say you haven't been hours. I'll stay over.
Before we get a great job. Okay, each week is just all right.
Let's say I'm, uh, these guys are running the sk-
I'm using this board. I'm sitting, wherever I'm sitting,
and I don't wanna, uh, point guys. Thanks. Umm.
And I had test challenges in the best of their universe.
Uhm, if you put hours and stuff.
that's what I'm saying. But you can do a, you can do a umm.
like, I used to put it in a fake job that,
I just had it in a job that said, umm,
whatever. It was like, umm,
I think I call it a disseminating or something like that,
and I might have, You It's a lot of times in the state of
it, we're going to be judging what I think we might be at,
but I'm still not even asking what we're going to do.
But when these guys spin their mind, ,and if I see the schedule,
... yeah, that I mean most of them are just sitting worried.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm kidding, I can send you for a play,
you know what? It's your name, they just won't approve that because you don't
want to. It's not like people can drop anything to leave for two minutes.
Let's go. Alright, go drop it in, you'll see what happens,
then you'll pull it out, right? Yeah, boy, let me give you this one,
when I drop it into your, your boss calls you.
and If you walk away and you forgot that you did it,
this guy's doing my most sketch, I'm just gonna tense it up.
Can you say, oh, I don't even want these charts?
That's good. I mean,
I think you said,
yeah, I don't want those. We'll just have one next time.
Yeah, we'll be sure not to know if that makes sense. Yeah, I mean.
I don't have my own schedule because not the schedule never wanted me to
mess with the master schedule.
Yeah, this is time to the project schedule.
The project schedule is each individual project,
right? Yep. And then the first one we're really looking at,
what's that called? So,
the production planer,
production planer. Yeah. So basically,
please, please, please give a wha- much more five nights greater
than if you want blue. In the production planer,
I don't think I'd use that. I should use this. Did YouTube? This one.
And thanks. They,
they had, they had this for years.
And when they were wanting the production plan in their life.
Bye. Wow, you got this for five minutes.
Yeah. I like that because I don't know how to, uhm,
this will spot it from where s- Shops. Yeah, I do think so,
Jira. It says, what was that to be called? Yeah,
it said. Yeah, right, yeah,
yeah. Or Microsoft, right? Yeah.
Yeah! Yeah. I like this.
And this thing has the ability to do a start,
start, or pick. Finish to start this particular program just like,
you have a surprise. Yep. Yeah, I like this.
That wouldn't be good. Thank and you can put total available hours
if you want it. And then, somehow,
I'm gonna tap the link. Thank you. I. Be. She.
Examine hours for all the jobs. There are two weeks from now and here's
how many hours of bed. Okay,
I'm sure. We're at Moaburger, but eh. Yeah. And one of the people that
I'm saying, you put this job for vloggers.
Yeah. And you have asthma. Backs,
it'll do what you think you need for it. It's just gonna fly.
Sure. Like it even, right? But she didn't have to get me a note
of that in April, especially- and then I'll move 500 hours under the first
week that I'll spill it out to a regular time. And you could buy
it out of this every week if you're thinking so I'll get in the
office. Push that. Yup. Yup.
And, you know, I'm like,
I don't know what you got.
you You guys are already doing what things you've done for this.
You're like, I don't want any of the scale. First of all,
I'm wondering if you can use this. I just wanted to see if it
would be better. But we're not using it,
right? Uh. Bye I'm not getting it,
yes or no. We right now there's only a couple weeks through the job,
so there's not really a reason. I'm gonna strike Bitbucket.
I'm wondering, but, yeah, when you've been really busy,
it's like one or two months. But the problem is,
if I'm really busy, it's, uh, home-like.
. . . 30 tiny packages that are going to be in there.
The total already has got it, so it takes me longer to set up
this 5 minutes. And do all this,
and it does, basically, 4 to 8 minutes,
cause it in the shot. Do you mind that case,
if one number be easier because it's,
It just has a word package bag,
uhh. It used to be 50 guys, I hear it down,
there's 20. So, what do you get,
50? If you have two or three months of work,
back that. Yeah. So,
the time is like that, it's gonna be really useful. So,
You have a little band, I shouldn't.
Yeah, that's gonna work anyway. Alright. Thank
you for having me,
thank you for having me with me,
like, this, to me, yeah. Yeah. What we use depends on what you try
to accomplish, yeah. Uh, if it's just,
I need to be able to learn this. . . I've seen two months
ago when I had my whole work job job and this and
this one I thought would be great, yep. Alright, a big if it's like,
okay, this week, while the package is in my work job and what about
you work up first in order to press your phone?
. . Umm,
Medi X. Yeah, we're looking back,
you know, it's a dope, it's a to me,
birds and what? I'm allergic, yeah.
It's, it's, yeah, it's, it's, it looks like. I saw a project only in
some way that could explode better because it's freaking out like,
you know, like, you know, well,
hit it. Yeah. you automatically come when you have it in your fascia.
Yeah. Yeah. Or, so what,
what, yeah, it is. So, when you get it,
that's the- and you get the job. One of the things you get to
cross out of the line, one of the mistakes is transfer.
Wouldn't you get a job, so you got a much better job. Thank you
very much. Thank you very
much. much for
watching. the person
on It's tough to have people who are an estate engineer with the
9 hours from overall opportunities in person.
I think it was big on that.
So, if people get their job,
they've got things in the system,
but there's no step. See ya.
So, then, you just go into that problem, so you can't get anything from
any sort of up on this. Carehouse. Get us in the hospital.
I need to take a look at Umm,
yeah. You gotta put in,
like, stickers that kill students who are having.
So, they don't want you to do that. They don't want you We'll find
out if you're sitting in the box and you will need, uh,
lost. Oh You'll be familiar with all of our screen visits and we actually
have audio in there which is here, uhh,
well, and our screen sequence. . . . .
. .
for the police. Yeah. hmm.
That's a sudden leadership. Mm hmm. Yeah. That's true. We're just having to say,
to say. Mm hmm. S. All this in one giant seat.
It's been good in your class, if you're not still.
I've been sitting here on this and I don't think I'm going to say
this. Hey. Ah, I thought I was going to stop this work,
man. Yeah, I think it's a little bit easier when I was born in
the south. Listen, it's- It is,
uhh, it is a Microsoft project that should be greater
than a lot of people are born. Besides- Well I don't know if she
got it or she had it, but I don't know what it Yeah,
cuz this is what C1 takes in three seconds. So I've got to cover
these boxes up here, here and here.
Okay, bye. I don't know how to use it,
but I'll say it's been more than a dollar just for a minute.
So it's been easy to use this spreadsheet. You But,
this one kind of does it automatically, it's more over there and then it
sits down directly. It's already there.
Yeah. That's So hopefully it really does
appear to me on your golf or stadium.
Yeah. Yeah. Depends on my views.
Uh, we used to look and see what's happening this week and do my
packages and write them and figure it out. What I mean.
. This week and that week.
Yeah, I'm the flatter as a tool for that.
This is the, I'm staying around.
You I'm thinking about a part of thousands of people, even though I'm saying
that. Ten thousand people would be happy to Yeah,
I'd be happy to be here. Yeah. I'm feeling this guy. guys, pretty small
amounts of work can do it in their head. But I'm gonna get sick.
Yeah. If you've got a bunch of 2009 jobs,
you could. . . and the, uh, sound like,
I've had an arsenal in a couple weeks,
very nice. Probably crazy. It's amazing.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, actually,
I'm gonna write this up a little bit again. I'm gonna find more work
in between here and there. Bye bye.
So, yeah, I've got a second of a matching position for this work,
you know, all the better, the better, the the better,
the better, the better flow. Yeah, really. You I'm here getting something coming to
you all the time. That's good.
Yeah, me and my friends are far out of luck. I mean,
they're far out of luck. 2 6 All the fabricators in that, I don't
get to buy it, maybe that should be done anymore,
but we should have a room big deluxe. And that all,
all that work if you're getting shipped to be done.
You Paint to Me. Y'all will sign the work for another guy who's getting
his face. That will keep my head above water,
but I will- I think it's a little bit harder,
yeah. I don't think that I'm going to get a sales fee or a
charge for it. I think it's exactly- All I love you.
I love it. What I was saying is the P,
you know, cost engineers and that.
Yeah, that's what it sounded like. Thank you. You know,
pretty much an opportunity falls in my lap,
hard in my life. You're thinking about communicate, you know, basically,
I ain't gonna be on the shoot. You you you . . . How
come tomorrow we're getting, are they mostly getting work for the company that stayed
down because I'm getting much better over here? Thank Umm,
I don't know, maybe it's not getting much work out. Very false is energy,
but nothing very false. I don't think your caster doesn't,
No, you can't say that much. I think the yesterday's facilities are severely
underutilized, and they would like to change that.
we'll more time. Okay. And then,
in Mexico, they can't keep employees,
but go. Good. Two to four guys later.
I think I'm silly. See, there's a bunch of hesitators that need to figure
out how to build and work. Perfect. That's the money so we can get
you more jobs and be more competitive. Yeah,
that's right. Okay. That's the money.
But, uh, perfect. Yeah, so lovely,
and that's a good thing man, just like,
we were so busy all the time and we don't know what changed.
and we'll see the next one. Well,
we all certainly haven't started thinking about the stability that you could be listening
to. How much work have you done,
sir? Yeah, I mean- I guess
I don't know how to break it, but I can see. And I think
that makes me
proud of you.
It's very, very somewhat percent proud of margin. It's how I mean.
You be involved with call frames,
uh, not somewhere around the world.
I mean, just one year. Just one year. one year.
. And that's, well then you can also, you know,
probably gettin' around the ground.
Alright, well then we're gonna have it founded by just kind of the necessary-
Any question? Huh. Will you like it about the same questions?
Heh, heh. But
as far as tech was concerned, the thing would be just show us it.
It would be very helpful if it had long. So no The last one
should be you want to hear. This is Kingdom 1,
2025, 224,000 come and ship to job sites.
and I'll see the next one. I didn't think about Q1 in 2023.
Three. I've
been 68,000 months. Should we know how much I don't know if we're done,
we're done, we're still 4,000. Go ahead, coach.
Q1.4, Compass,
and
Well, this is a horrible one.
So, Q4, 20, 24.
Yeah. Yeah. So, I'm gonna see,
500 and 86.
And where are we at now? 25.
And, uh, Q4 goes in the data. It's better.
7-1, Q3,
634, Umm.
That's all about 5-6, meeting North. So,
uh. You What are you so-o?
Uhh, 50. Thank much.
That's what I'm going to do. I'm going to put down this stuff.
You know, it's, I mean,
the, Look for me. In my different facets of work that we're bidding.
I don't know if there's a truth. I'm sure there's an average that I'm
not giving to you. Thank very much. and other shit.
It's not. How about handing the jobs and you make you know what I
mean? Hold on.
Or you not look- Okay. Nice. For bound and rest of the time.
No, usually that- I need you to look for this. Someone- this will come
in the- Okay. I guess we'll figure it out. Okay.
Who'd be in this tonight? I'd like a TSM Steve job that you're not
going to do. What's the cell for? Do you know the call- cell for
it? Okay. Let
me guess. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank
We don't get, we don't get, uh, canyons to like,
or even the whack. We don't want to talk about- I about cowlings.
I don't want to talk about me, yeah,
and then we'll do that. you have
a little bit of effort,
and it's like a 3.40, so. Get to the new one.
Yeah, the only one with the new one, ehm, ehm. I don't know how
I'm just, uh. You have to,
uh, tell him, uh, tell him where he came from.
Like I said, bye. Bye. We got their,
their Confluence department at time 13,
and we got a favorite. Yeah. Yeah.
So this is a one-jaw ready, 4.6 mm,
and, uhm, chee. Okay.
Packard, what is this?
Uhh, what is your question? What software are you looking at?
I see. I'll see you soon.
And I'll just give it a Okay.
Umm.
Pissed.
Umm,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. We're gonna have to go in,
more in the best, but,
uhm, let me end up in a job. Yeah. It's a day.
I'll see you This
is by the New Year of Peace, as to the campus, Bitbucket.
No.
Nice to meet you guys.
But you have the content, price isn't gonna figure out dollars
for earth. And I'll see And,
uh, for a president, there's a matrix right in there,
you can follow up if you want to be here. Could you count that
both? Yeah, but commercial. I don't see dollars
anywhere else, I see.
In half of us, we're done. Alright.
Then we'll watch. Here, Umm, I'm just gonna film the-
You can see the, uhm, this showed you a different essence.
So. I'm like, you can see the essence of it and we need to
know that. I want that out of it. it.
Just on the side.
Mm-hmm. It's
interesting on side overtators to know.
Alright, Willem. Okay.
For me, dollars profound. For, uh, uh, 36, 85,
16, 70, Grillemore, 36, 70.
I all know, I'm not sure. I'm saying you. . Get it.
Ready to pull out a tank of what a put is,
you're right here, screw it up. Alright,-bye. I'm going to give it a rest
of the server, but when you do this to somebody,
I don't know. I- Bye.
Yes.
We have done it. It has been a summering work,
so maybe another reason we'll give it a rest of the park. We haven't
done it yet, so we'll be seeing this with some reason,
so we haven't updated any of our dependable reports.
you do that on the whole room, uhm,
and also, I have the ability to
replay the- the margins,
and I need super-subbing it a little bit easier in this.
I don't just take a lot of it as long as- And one.
Bye. Super simple. Hey,
what up? What I'm just each seeing is that there are 18 programs that
we gotta go into. Thank you. It's the same thing that we can do
in a month or a day like that. And I just need you to
welcome to figure out what one that is. Good afternoon.
We'll minute. us. All continues. Be on the next the phone. Uh,
see about something that makes the difference. Yeah,
nah, that's not going to, I'll always be able to get Thank so much.
I have some more issues in my core too, love.
I think there's legacy, and I think there's a lot more.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you very much. I'll be with you this part of this,
and then I'll be with you again now.
I'll be with you this part of this part, and see you next time.
Because I'm not listening to one place in the moment.
So I'm really fine listening about this part.
Yeah. Later.
Okay. Everything has to go to this stuff.
I don't know what this is.
Okay, so hundreds of closers going down. Uh,
ah, ah, ah, look, I read back to the closers.
Yeah. And I could decide what to .
. I think, I
think I'm going to generate that. That's what I think about. I think you're
going to stop not having it. Uh,
ah, uh, see you. Yeah. I think they're putting,
right there, everything, all the dollars that I'm eating.
Don't be the heavy bits that I'm eating. Yeah. Cause there's a- There's a
67 page that comes back.
Yeah, that's the gap. Copy. Yeah. What the TSM is on.
I've got another price in there. Just something I didn't price.
Like, I didn't know if everybody would post,
calculate everything out. That one would be smooth on time.
I'll next time. And then we end up drastically reducing our labor rates.
Our labor rate is more or less than that. With more government than 7.
Good. Good. A certain dollar rate to limit,
but we need to work. So, I mean,
you can do all that already. So, um.
you like to get it.
So, they do it by the way, so. I'm not changing the unit cost
up there because you got to your weight and your,
I change the unit cost and I go down the lane.
We're not zero to that. Okay.
We're going to do that.
Thank Lucas.
Thanks. Now
I'm going to take at our words.
I can't,
I'm just kidding. So the quarking is in balance.
What do we try to do? So,
if we were trying to switch this to a price per pound.
Yes, just a unit call.
I love you. 12.6 for, just get part of the world,
like, in King County, 50 cents, you know, 30 cents,
I'm okay. Who is that guy?
And then, then, you give us, this is our way up to 50,
the other circles. Yeah, and we go down to the house. Subs by I'm
here the near, where is your self price?
Where's your self price? I'm here all the way above.
Is that- Is a real self price? No,
to the value. Very good self price.
you There's your self price for how many times?
Well, let's visit. This isn't right.
We, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, Okay.
Right. Okay. I'm with you, because when you collect the
250, you change everything.
Yep. You That 250 is probably the patent.
Yep. Okay. We want to know what we want the program to calculate the
patent based on the sell- No, no, that's gonna be right there.
It shouldn't be the price of our material, just the material line.
It should have made the value on purchase orders. We're ready. We're all probably,
that's, that's what had more of a use,
like in this area. We didn't say it. We didn't do the labor.
We just sold that at price per pay. You sold it.
Umm, I don't know if I can write this right. Also in the price,
I'm sorry, I didn't, I didn't, they never read it.
It's in the bank. Yeah. you Yeah. So do you have any idea what
the strengths are all for? Umm,
okay. So. Thank you.
What
does that mean? Okay.
Here we are, point to me, this is private school. There you be.
It's two thousand of you who have a significant lead to what I think.
Thank you. So
you have to go to the folder to- and look at it.
She wouldn't just hop into this level, look at it.
I think there's some of that in some people who don't know about it.
. . But you want the job, right?
But because you submitted that,
you entered it just as a contract. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm just worried real about this.
Same. Most proposals just need the promise we don't
do it now. Uhh, uhh,
ehm, ehm, ehm, Yeah,
two thousand and, Filling one hours,
maybe twenty-seven thousand dollars, fifteen thousand profit,
and then a twelve percent They're a thousanders.
All right. Universal was at three hundred and thirty thousand pounds.
That is not right. Okay. This.
That'd be a hundred
and fifty nine pounds a No. Let's
see. It's floating
First in it, 3,6,000
pounds, let's see what makes it smoke.
Oh. Have a way to try to get 6,000 pounds,
we're going to send it out with us, and we should send it out.
Can you do that? Yeah,
there's in there. If you're going to do it at a level,
it's like, oh. Yeah, there's no material in there. Oh! Come on. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah, it's later on.
Spellpass, ridiculous glass connector,
and chef's seal. Oh. $127,000 for
256,000 pounds.
You're doing the labor at 50 cents a pound.
You're doing the labor at 2 dollars a pound.
128 cents.
you guys. And we make money.
And I just said yes. We make some,
up to T-Ray, comms. So you were getting paid $60,000,
if you did the job really in charge of $100,000.
You know, especially with Compass,
they're $15,000.
What is that? Okay. Yeah,
it's not very much. Well,
I'm used to it. I mean, what's the shop right here? Thanks for the
cost. Please be quiet. I'm to fix this. Uh,
Ops, it's hard because they keep,
they keep splitting up. We're of whole the road. I of these There's blocking,
but help? We'll have the You are trying to split overhead out of it.
So, uhm, I think our action will sell with the 48
or 49. Yeah. And, you know, I wish you something like that.
Put that out of it, put that out right ahead.
As soon as you shut and- Oh And,
uh, please. So, this only gonna get really
done. I think...
Come on It's not
fun. So, we need to work soon.
Oh. I got it. Sure, I can understand.
If I need a local officer,
there's okay, he's gonna be.
And, so,
ah, this one and now, this one was alright.
Alright. So,
the third one, OpsGenie, Rovo.
So, ah. You So,
the contract price is 1563.
It's free. Yeah,
which is actually more, because there's cheaper,
you know, this is the original, uhh,
1 million's. . . . . 600 .
. . it is, uhh, well I thought the same thing as 1 million,
6,12,000. .
. .,000. . . .
Six
hundred and eighty five thousand five hundred and eighty two packets.
Thanks. Six, six, five, five,
five, eight, ten, six,
five, five,
five, eight, ten, six. 6.
5, 5, 5, eight, ten.
It's a very good video to get you in the meantime.
So it keeps it as soon
as I, uh, but as soon as I do it,
it's not. Boom.
Boom. That's what we were doing well,
I think. That's the thing. About when we I'm not We were probably
going to finish at 47%.
So, so we aren't cheap. . .
. .
We're talking about syrup. Let's see what that is.
Yeah, that's good. Slow.
Mm-hmm. Thank you.
Thank you. We had, uhm, a pretty much run through everything we did on
the videos. I'll tell you what I don't like. Thanks for your time.
Yeah, what's that? Oh, yeah. Okay, so I'm, I'm pretty much a brat here,
so whatever you want in table, I don't know. That was some insight.
side. I would,
I would like to absolutely run through the entire work line.
And so it was okay. Good. Uh, hey, I'm not talking,
S.M.A.
entrepreneurship.
ship them. I have a house to be in the emergency,
to make sure everything is in the machine.
Alright, sounds great. Kinda like with,
with estimating, uh, I'm, I'm not.
Yeah, if a goal is,
Well, yeah,
when I'm leaving here to ride on the court, I'll get my team to
hear us out. You I mean, obviously part of what I'll say
is, I think there should be way too many programs that are being used
for the same day as, Oh, yeah. Yeah,
to me estimating is better for my business.
That's my pleasure. So he made it.
Yeah. But like, I'm happy with this. It's, uh,
it's a chemical fly with all of us.
And a, uh, instruction valve.
And so, uh, it, it, and what part of the system here can be
used. and I'm glad we're here to bring some . . And then it
can be modified for your own purposes.
So what you're saying, if you'd like to say, this is .
. what you think it could be If you'd like to know what is
. . that's kind of the . .
the word. Yeah, and what's .
. . what the ice because I wanted to know about myself.
Yeah. I'd like to kind of just start walking through .
. . really walking through this . . then like,
you know, what form of essence being done in here or how many materials
sitting there . . . going . . . Yeah,
I got, I got, I got, you know this stuff,
but I think it'd be great that I had to find a few .
. . so I'm pretty 100% of that .
. . Yeah, that's our first 9 minutes Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. So .
. is everything that I do when I
run That's how I managed to live so that .
. . So . . . I do all say all to me that
this is about my own I think that's very easy to do.
But even when you're wrapping it up and you're going over in the program
or so . . is that a company reason for that
or is that a . . . that's just what we did with anything
or is it . . . yeah, just and it may be the best,
but I don't wanna come . . . I'm just playing a simple and
extra work with me because I've got to get each other there.
Uh Pull all this information from,
technically, take over the video, so it'll be .
. wearing something . . . doing that much at the time.
I'm here . . yeah, yeah. If I'm recent,
it'll . . . yeah. But . . . and for four whenever we
get uh, we . . . we have an opportunity to give you an
opportunity to lighten it up to the point of when they create an estimate
for . . . in the creative job on Pro Lord.
And then I am assigned to the associated estimator,
which is until it's, uhm, a tiny sales force.
Yeah, yeah, which is a sale opportunity.
And then depending on the status that it's in for a Lord,
whether it's submitted or awarded. or anything. And you want not based upon the
Bit or, uh,
this kind of stuff updates Salesforce.
Oops. Staw on the self-worth.
But you want to go through the whole job, start to finish,
then we're using it with Integrity. That correct?
Yeah. Yeah. Listen, I'm not a regression.
Yeah. I just have to make sure here's the steps.
But you can do that because you like the main document.
I love you. Yeah. Yeah. So where,
where do we have to be?
Uh, we have this to be in technical,
Uh, every day, and it turns on at the one that I don't know.
Bye
All scrums roll is just a minute and a second.
What, you're saying that he has? I agree with it.
Now, based on the number, Yeah, in my six days.
So, And yeah,
we want to walk through this now. I can start through this now.
We want to wait a little more. No, no, no, no now.
Alright, so, Bye.
Ask me, do you get a job?
Alright. Umm,
I can't even answer my technical problem.
Mm-hmm. So, uh, this will be,
but man, first I'll settle on this in techno s- Some in heavy,
heavy, sub or else,
some kind of additional system that I'm not privy to.
But for what you do,
for the structural side, it's here. Here.
Thank you.
The market here as well,
or she does, does the other thing. Umm,
marks you can do in manual take ups, time.
On. I'm doing type of take ups, we compare.
All the same jobs. Yeah, that's it.
Okay. Okay. Umm,
I'm gonna go through the steps of the estimate.
Mhm. Well, I mean, we don't have to do the steps,
but, um. you Let's play a
little bit elevated without getting into the details.
After you get the job, let's do my stuff to you.
How can you do the project? You rest a bit.
Or not. Umm,
no, I'll link it. So you need to go to your homepage.
Thank you. Like, so like this one,
MGS, umm. This is my,
this is my estimate here, so. So, A lot of energy and production can
be sold, because I prefer entering on with something there.
A lot of energy, everything in there, when it's for the kids to,
uh, imported in here, so it has all the information and,
uh, um, all my breakouts,
so, and then, Listen, John, I can do God if I can do it.
You know, it's having a, no-one doing this for a piece this week,
okay? Um, and so,
I'll estimate by, by drawing,
and break all this information down,
and then, I get my total hours,
and, and then I end up going into Pro Board,
and, So you know, most bigs.
What's that been? .
. . . . . .
. .
. . . .
.
It's a sign that
is estimated so I'll go on an estimating,
uhh, product. You part of why I think we were also doing it in
here, is to the feelings, side of the things that are all broken in
here. Yeah. Yeah. Half, Puddings broke up,
and Jira not make the exact limit.
Now I'm just going to add to the 10-12 periods and do all of
those. Those. Do all those steps in there.
Um, but I'm going here and I'll hook in my shot hours for
what was estimated. I'll go in.
You can take all the quotes that I got from my materials.
I'll add all my material quotes in here.
So that's my material real quick. So.
. The material cost is not intended.
Okay. If we're not using it.
Are we- So, uhm, I haven't- I haven't
messed around. You like any of my thoughts,
even to tech- I usually just wouldn't be able to find one.
Yeah, cause- this is essentially where- .
Where I build my- my proposal for everything now on certifications,
ponies, information, umm,
including- exclusions,
for- for everything.
And then this is all full. Yeah,
this is all full. Yeah, so I'll submit everything through
here. I mean, well, something like that.
So you do this because you don't have- I have all this set up
in a low-bro template in Tacklion.
Yeah. So if you hand this all in Tacklion-
You wouldn't stop using Pro-Gortlin.
Yeah, that's a series of IMPs with Pro-Gortlin.
Yeah, and then let's save a whole lot of transfer.
Thanks for your attention. I don't know what the is. Okay,
sir, can you go back for a job and show us where you put
the material cost and you haven't even broke or entered into technical-
It is what you want,
right? Okay. There must be palim using tech already.
Yeah, well, I'll be- It does sound like eating both of it's,
uh, already reason in tech,
right? You know. This is where you wrap this up.
So,
yeah, if you're doing weird purchasing from here,
you're not going to have to be in here somewhere, even buying here all
four, right? No. No. No,
it's not all. It was all over. It was that tiny.
Okay. I mean, you could do this here.
Thank you. Yes, but that is not where I would normally
do it. I would be funny.
You know, I'd ditch, like, if I had,
uh, eight, nine, a half,
two, I would put, you know, specific price.
Nice. I have a spoon of spoon,
you know, any other size food. So, feel like long ago,
do you write out your proof? I'm to sort of, you're going to,
the project maintenance section, right? And you're going to report your first C section.
I don't have any other motion to control, currently, to control.
You're not using estimated also, a little bit of production control.
Let's see what's your work. But that's not what we would do here for
the s- of the estimate. Co-pose that again.
So it's not pricing to do anything first. And we'll call the material,
the material cost can just flow in from the badness if you want to.
If you maintain the price and maintenance. Thanks for watching.
Yes, as I am, we're going to hear you're just quality.
Yeah, umm, so, the second means which is what most
people do. You got the estimated drop down and you get a job specific
pricing maintenance. Hey,
throw up the pricing drop down. That's very tough and to add sums for
an estimate. Pull everything over.
Okay, you have a copy of the prices from them down.
So if it's, if it's a price,
it's in there, pulls over, like, there's a pop-up road,
$1.36, $100, right? Um,
and it's- And I'm adjusting to the area.
If I want to let a neighborhood change and get, like,
here's a big change from the wall line.
Bye-bye. And then that locks
the pricing in here so it's not going to change.
And it also, uhh, uhh, it puts a lot of evidence from the software.
This is being set up to where even users are processing
the rest of their English. I'm sorry. I've been in reporting compared to,
uh, what the actions are. And then after this,
then you go to purchase it. And. We'll see the next and we'll have
this price compared to, yeah. Can you do all the questions
in here? Plus I have a pricing name.
You don't know. He said a lot of times.
Mm hmm. And once a quarter,
I send jobs to my vendors and they fill it in. Yeah.
I can update this and then push it all in.
Yes. I see. Yeah. More. Yeah.
Okay. That's my option. with plastic.
Yeah. So like, do more prices than they do better.
Thank you, Jira. Thanks. You can pull that in.
Yeah. Couple of money. So that's the normal
way of doing the material prices you can get.
Right? Really easy, right? And then,
it will also be the remnants of
your jobs to be that point to you. So you're going to be attracting
better clothes, uh, different percentage,
or you can put it in the body and you're going to get more
exact so that you have a small- Oh the project,
uh, on my head, oh, you should scrap on the job because it's smaller,
right? Whereas, while you're a project.
I it. So,
you can buy the video you want. So, price, uh, this and all we
have. So, and then,
yeah, it's said about quality and comparison.
So, so. what if you're wrapping it up again?
Umm, so really, all you're doing this for us to get out is,
rather than what disappoints you, right? Thank having me. Yeah,
yeah. Pretty much just try it out.
So, you know what I'm do now?
okay I'm here, and then, uhm,
and everybody else live this thing.
. . . .and then once,
once it's done,
the bottle's sent off Bye. I think there's a where
it needs to be, uhm, em, that's an ethic of invest, production control,
and it's, it's a matter of a matter of matter of matter of money.
So, you think that, erm,
it's a guys nt about it, and,
you know, so, you then I mean, like, for material, the cost, and you
know. Go. No, I love the mind here so that they have new lighting
movements. You know, they're about to be.
This one is exactly like keyboard. That's Good. That's
so surprising to me.
So, let it in here. Beautiful.
I have a lot of new brush control over there,
and I've got a lot of,
um, everything that I do. Thank you. So,
let's drop back there, because we can just jump away from
our heads. So, we got, we did this.
Yes. Umm, and, so that goes
over to Pro 4, everything gets submitted there.
You nothing else comes back in the,
uh, in the resume. When you win the job.
Umm, but let's be all,
You don't really do advance meals,
right? Alright, umm.
Sorry, let's not be here anymore.
more. Let's not really worry about my children in terms of how much children
there is in your room, like a big patient. Just send it out and
say, what's the good thing about their meals? Thank you. I'll just bring you
some new benefits.
Steve Hurley, look before you actually finish your design.
Thank you. So, let's get into,
alright, you win the job, set the job up.
What in- Thanks for watching. Project management is being utilized as opposed
to elsewhere. Pretty minimal,
alright. Bye. I think it is with,
uhm, usually the VISTA and Pro-Corps,
a lot of that is, Dundell Square.
And, I'll say in a lot of cases,
rightfully so. So, RFOX. We'll see you in a
Where are our cost? I do all of my own.
I that's too weird. What about it?
We've got it. We've got it. What about our names?
I'm the only one who gives you stuff.
Good luck. Let's- It's- It's- It's- It's- It's- I wish
you More transmittals come in dry,
warm love and distract all the wet bit before the cut behind here's our
uncertainty. And the other things? Thanks. No.
But the other guys don't do it. They're,
it's estimated in their mouths and looks, uh,
they're older things to get decimated out and then they never need to.
You basically, we just program again. That,
right? It's just, that's made out of it and they're not looking to take
it. So. So. In,
in, do you control all of the,
uhh, you're all in love?
I feel like I'm really mean. I'm sorry. for it. Did,
did you control all of the drawing long and transmittals for everything you want
us to review? Okay, so all, all the app for approval and- I was
thinking of you and you can see what girls are all engines.
Okay. Um, for anything that- and I-
But some of the only one? Yeah.
None of the other project engineers set in their face with the new their
customers are using this format. Now we can one. Yeah.
Is that work that goes through this facility?
Or, uh, sometimes,
And it's the work that everyone's doing this facility.
Uh, it'll be most of the time,
and I see it. It's, it's, uh,
the project according to the question. One for this is the work that you
push through. They already work through all that outcomes several times in these.
So let us- the work that you guys do that somebody
else is controlling and they handle all that out for approval.
We'll try this now. We'll draw along all that somewhere else.
Okay. Even though it's the same company.
The uhh. Bye-bye.
The only stuff that's trapped in Tekla for transmittals,
RFIs, strong law,
back. Backing forth between detailers and approval stages is my
project and things that I did. So the other guy can help you use
this. . Right, sure, you're some track compass down here.
Whatever. Change your laws.
They've also been different, different interface.
Please. And, uh, different things. Do you have any other change orders from here,
too? Do you have any change orders? Umm,
yeah, I'll enter my change orders from here,
come on. I haven't had any projects since we've gone through all this,
uh, that-that-that huge amount of change orders.
Uh, I-I- I do still the traffic separately,
you know, getting a nice style sheet of water,
because it's a lot of customerability to see that. Yeah.
I don't think so. I think I'd see you too. But anything that I
can possibly use in this program for,
I use Pro. So.
I know you're not tracking many more sweet people's own and really be able
to look at it. Uh, usually when there's a business,
it's not you. You
can do, or after it's paying out, but you can do the pay out
over there or something, whatever there is, right? Um. Bye.
We were going to talk about it. Is there a meeting for that?
Yeah, it's something on our list of steps. I mean,
it affects increases. Let's do Okay. We had it on there just because that
was part of what our passion is from the last time that I was,
um, trying to figure out.
The importance of it, yep, and an attention to the thing was way.
I know about it, it's a fall already.
you think that they shouldn't have other things that are done external.
yep, so it's more of a me and Margo.
Are A large project, then we want to use something
like that. It's something that's longer on and out.
That's what we're doing. So it's like your project's due to the production
of Billy and the abortion. Um. You
know, the function, uh, ehm, you actually seen the
involves your payout to you. You keep the client,
or does that name smile, or does it count?
That's true. Yeah. Two thousand and I think that's the deal.
That's the deal. That's the
deal.
You the bottom, the chisis,
the, the, the front of the front of the front of the rear wheels
and the brake. Uh, that, 14 of it.
You will do, uhm,
that's the fact that there will be a bunch of others and then the
rest is built upon completion of them. And then usually I'll reach me here
for a moment if you chow us in. Hey, you're gonna chow us as
I have to like a simple month for you to see again.
Come on. 40% this month,
the next month, I'm 60% the next month,
I'm 90%. Um,
Loom was kind of that way. Um. I don't know.
But, um, even then, that was started in,
in November, and for me to be completed probably.
Bye Uh, first week of the summer,
uh, started. Okay, so yeah, so you're not doing anything else.
It's, it's usually, uh, uh, more.
Most, not most of our projects are done over a month.
So, we'll, we'll go through that again maybe more in,
You sure can be dangerous by sure.
So, it's useful to you. Market will be ending in a beautiful day tomorrow
and it's happening here, so it'll be,
I'm going through everything then.
So, Project Schedule, you are doing it.
Yup. Um. Thank you.
That's pretty much anything, right?
So, yeah, we did everything. Project Schedule,
we did everything.
Trim up next, never me,
and then let's see if I'll, everything's uploaded and trimmed it.
So, there's your dunce of other things. . Just,
just, just, ah, no, I'm gonna get an example of 2-5-0.
So, 1-5-5, ah, lets- This one,-
essentially,
production-wise, the length. So,
well, I've sensed that as if it's a customer,
it's the pun. Bye-bye. And, uh, so, educating him all that,
what is Triple Connect going, this new model,
where you are, and so, getting very much.
Thanks for your attention. I did use that
when I was a day of steel,
and I was connected, so I get straight to the wall, from within a
tab. Yeah. I didn't add any more calories and calories on material settings,
but she said she said she could say this. We have a lot of,
like, info days to allow it. Umm, like, yeah.
And it's just so awesome. Yeah,
he said, okay, this is built. It's one color.
This is, this is already installed. It's another color.
Yeah. I know. It's all there. What happens to this?
It is. Other cuts.
So much. Start that way.
You It's such a good way to get proactive on jobs,
so rather than re-empt it to OSGenie without this value.
I love you. I just like to say a handout about this.
So the stuff that you're doing is attaching to the trimmel connect,
but the stuff- Yep. The wrong and proper doing is not,
because it's not for you. They're not ready to production.
And they're in the sense. But it's somebody's project,
which I'll study to you. Hmm.
Some project, man, you know, there you go. Um,
well, I guess at the end of select school,
electricals, and has helped me in my life like humans.
What does it look like? To be added to this system a bit,
you But you're running directly in Bitbucket,
right here in the goods structure and design it, right?
So, who is managing those jobs?
Uh, they're getting, they're getting production new,
uhm. We'll see you and they're getting involved with us.
So us, if, if, if it's not,
you know, then we can do that.
Okay. So. Sometimes you wouldn't manage a job that they got.
Yeah. And then, in that case,
you would actually put it in a couple of minutes.
Yep. You had fun with my speaker. And the thumbs you don't get them
all here. Is that, You call it,
What's, what's the reason behind that? I'm not supposed to call it somewhere,
I guess, to go and say, umm, you know, people wouldn't get them all,
it depends on, the project itself,
so, like, you know, like, he's not a one next video.
I don't even, I don't even get cat files for those who have to
draw. You know, all of our play files are there in me.
Uh, they will give us cat files,
we'll just get a drawing package. Yeah, uh,
but most of them started. You maybe 10,
I believe that most have some, some deans,
some common abilities. So, uhm,
but yeah, a lot. You you're getting the nice enough.
Yeah, uhm, so. Totally,
that reference, you know, you shouldn't be doing this.
this week. This thought about visibility.
Yeah. And then also,
uhm, we went right to our house guys.
Yeah, me. . Yeah. And that, that's,
that's to even the same level. Dropping back,
umm, on your drawings and training.
Okay. And I is the metals.
Are you able to get a PFXP file that important to your animals?
Yeah. True, using that on there. True.
You are only tailors?
Yes. Okay. Cool. That is a part of our design standard.
We have, I guess, a file through our ancient. Appreciate We have educational packages
that are detailed by us. Anything that customers apply,
it's a plus. Thank you very much. Confluence.
Where you control it, you can get it.
There you go. So. With that.
then. with our file. Uhm.
In, uhm.
True. You look at all the other things in project management and with this
little ton of journaling,
tree, and task list and check list like things.
. . . What's going to be for a little bit anyway? Even,
even, even the task list wise,
I don't know, I don't have anything, I have a little check. I said,
we are in, yeah, I had three or four
laners, this was helpful. Yeah,
I didn't. I didn't see any of the use of what was going on
in the company. Ask me, b****,
where are people here? Yeah, yeah.
It's, it's the- I'm here with people who aren't at the school.
I'm going to shop some where they have started to get that on.
Basically, the same thing that appreciates this.
Come. Okay. So we'll see a nice and magnate sandwich. This entire checklist is
based off of the procedure.
Thank you. I have four project leaders,
which is our project.
Check this. Which,
essentially, it is not your check box.
It's not your flow. Organize release folder.
Save the box. For open drives and management jobs,
for all information provided, in progress,
use of production controls, so that you can see it.
And people else, not relevant if you have an existing,
um, fixed amount of material,
make sure everything else checked. better. I'm not going to be able to apply
the routing. My
cheers. Thank you. I'm do all this using components to play at least PCA
for the angle of materials.
Good news. For the purchase of other names,
uh, based upon one of the two of those,
you can really inventory for stock.
Bye. I'm gonna use yard draw, set off cues down,
set it on, set set it on,
check volunteer as a panel floor, confirm,
proceed with work packages, prepare for any of the work you can leave in.
Add a house door. Remember that each is one store package is complete.
Generally, we are going to try out another B.L.O.
Douglas. There's a phone that he sent.
It's good. It's got more Um,
airports are generated. Do your tightness things.
So this is where we've been saving,...
Our files in the drawing mods.
Um, Link, I haven't seen my own touch at night.
We haven't even had users. These We've been burning a lot
in the state, uh, Project Management, Proceeding, Trello, Middle, Script, Education,
Release, Proceeding, Some Lot, Atlassian.
You want to report, open the source of email,
and then include all the information and verification links.
us. And break open it down with version schedule,
and version schedule will be entered into the project schedule in project.
Thank you. Uh, uhm, uhm, uhm,
and yeah, and this breaks down the project you're managing,
you know, each other's. . I'm going to break down this app here.
I'll break out in the game chart for a couple of different updates.
I'll just schedule a production schedule released.
There's a vacation chart in London.
We've told one of these doctors every time we get it.
We should send it back to people. So it's an A-stock on that.
Erm, Medo. The other stuff from the project is going to be the end
of that. You That's pretty much everything there.
Umm, okay.
Release the plan, the uhm, uh,
action control. travel. Umm,
you get the FxP if possible,
right? Umm. Love. So,
you get forward in here. Umm.
So, You're,
you're doing the routing.
Umm. You're- You're
doing the combining and everything to purchase,
Eric. Are you purchasing one?
Let me grab the- You haven't figured
it out this long yet, I hear the next poppin' kids,
so. Go. You've seen how many miles you've had.
Yeah. Yeah. Some days, I've had.
Bye. I've had that.
So you're combining and purchasing,
combining, uh, interesting project.
I'm going to try to send out, send out the three or five vendors
to the competitive cost, uhm,
purchasing here. Cheers.
And then we also broke around,
so, uhm, we created all of these nice things.
. . ECN students for the equivalent of property,
uhm, I specifically,
I'm only in the self-evocation work.
Umm, MediRoute will be my own processing or get easy enrolled
as something I specifically enrolled. Okay. Um. Bye And then I'll interact
all of that too much kind of spindles, uhm,
and then we create,
ehm, contact this,
and then, uh,
uhm, so I guess, Once everything is imported,
sequence the mod, or you leave, and it moves throughout it,
and then, for packages,
and then, got us. Unless,
nah. Thank you. Find more than what's just so that our B-lines and our
B-line reflects word packages and everything in the shop ground.
We've got a room. And then we see all those reports.
Everything's all stretched the same, so we go into any of these folders.
Um. Bye-bye. It's the,
uh, releases,
sequence one, a lot one, shot the ports. words.
// I ended up releasing multiple statements about
an S, but everything is built on materials,
everything needs plugs, traveler, room-down.
// I'm gonna spell this, spell this,
replay it, uhm. And that,
here's how I'm gonna shot. Let's go about to the shot for word.
// If you got tablets,
what's up with the shot? Just because,
uhm, this has kinda just been a part of our procedure.
Now. // Ah, we're going to take a bit of this point,
still have his, but for people, we post everyone on to,
uh, women in the studio. Yeah. Time one or two,
oh, again, I've never figured out on him. Last day, he was a physical
people with points. It must be,
ah, man. The hat is,
ah, man. And
also part of the it's just so that we have ratchet of it as
well. Uh,
then I think it's going to be, you know, the original, right here is
the bullet. all of us. And, uh, what's the shop traveler?
Shop traveler is essential.
Cheers.
Especially just the assemblies and quantities that are associated in that description
and fit better well. Love.
Love. And they've filled out of it?
Yeah, they hope they're used. They know a lot more. Guys about this,
uh, more advice on this. They know a lot.
All right. . Okay. So, um.
Oh,
is he here? He's wrong. He couldn't go away from me in this.
Yeah. Go ahead. Because that,
uh, yeah, we needed the energy of a paper cutness,
uh, and revisions.
So it's, yeah,
that can be solved as it burns in a long time,
but it's definitely burns before. Yeah. See ya. Yeah.
So I could tell some bad stories,
you know, obviously. But then,
uh, yeah. And all of our other,
other fitness things started here.
I mean, this is better. This is what needs to be made.
You became a fully distribution of everything.
Anything all different from a prep holder,
uh, anything new is up.
A It's located in here, and also updated in here.
I call it as well. So, I'm here. Okay.
Okay. Umm.
You
And once,
once we have all of that information,
we both put together- There go. And it's added things to the dialogue,
which we can take a look here in the background.
and for this, then we'll take all those sharp parts,
all the drawings, everything you've written, it's all the planning and releasing them for.
All right. They've been having to the drawing while I'm successful.
So, all of that is all saved in here.
Man. and in the associative areas and then transmittals
are created for any of our shot. Alright,
good job. This is the rest of the board.
Oh, and then once I know how that is,
I'll put it in here, but then, I'll email that portion out.
So, that's it, that's it. And,
share my- . . .
. .
. violence. phoneme th
th th th .
. . though.
I have a mind that's what the process did in the following phases.
It's all of those who couldn't type of size,
participated in all the radiation materials.
you have one, and then it means specific notes,
uh, and then every time there's a lot of other tones,
and this one is- the boxes, um,
each box, length,
and it's only sequence and a lot of in hours associated with it.
And it's,
okay, it's later code, it's going to specs and production
schedules for each. THANKS FOR WATCHING. So,
uh, uhm, the information I'm going to turn into,
right, Management, Eight. That was my Bye.
I'm not Are all of those lots a,
uhm,
separate work package? Thank you very No.
No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
I apologize, I hate the time. You know what I'm gonna use on this?
All that's all I'm gonna get is fine. That's not a template.
Certainly. Thank you. That takes a lot of time to talk about what
I'm just, I'm lazy. Can you let me,
umm. Yeah, so. You Yeah,
this is also what we use before.
Or updates for the team. So, uhm,
Octavant, I think this one's a little bit different because the PM and P
here are obviously bookmarking here. You know, yeah,
but a lot of times it'll be bubbling.
These are 8-5 listening at all.
So, if they're on any delays with- material,
it's supposed to go to this email for it,
so that'll be- it's easily tracked for everyone.
Um, if they're on our, um,
was- the project is completely complete, and it's looking into the coins,
and you're supposed to have an eye on it, and you won't lose some
of them in the email about getting this, and hey, this is not complete.
But in terms of the coins, it's supposed to be the same thing.
Um, it doesn't get realized that the way it should do it best,
how it's served. And we'll set it to go deaf.
So, uh, and all that,
if you've done it with automated reports, so,
uh, hi. Good. Good. I have no sympathy for people who are too lazy
to go and look at the system and up and then look up.
I had a similar sympathy already.
for me. I think the problems with that was that I was just then
calling us and asking for another day.
Get out of here. Come on. Then we open the system.
I was prepared at that sort of, well,
we got your, you know, on the token pull,
you were probably pretty. We're done. It's like,
I've worked out here to tell us it's a big,
like a big. The most perfect manager is the perfect.
Thank you. Good. I'm going do it all. First, I'm going to do it
all. Half, second. One,
two, three. We'll see all construction of missing kids.
Do they have a new ticket? Okay.
Ready? Good. Uh,
it's a good place to ever use it for me.
Like I used it some, but, uh, so we can do it all the
time now. Yes, does. It's. The, uhm,
uh, also is a lot popular in our forums,
whatever. But the danger here is,
YouTube has to get somewhere else. N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N.
Good luck. That's, uhm,
that, and that's not just,
uhm, yeah, uhm,
sure. I'll be thinking,
well, there's a shop in Brooklyn, I've been doing three times because I've lost
it here. You do that as, uhm,
twice. And- and you can take it and you're like,
yeah, it's, uh,
cuz no problem yet, it's not going to be. So,
yeah. There. Thanks so . But it, it would be,
I don't know if you're just a good part, but you're a good person.
You Yeah. So, yeah. Yeah. Never.
Yeah, we'll definitely, definitely have it same page.
It's a university. It would be important.
Yeah. They seem real. you get boosted in tech over there.
That means, even this morning, they were all in.
Yes, maybe they're all in. All your PMs over here.
You were front of it, and then everybody knew the P.E.E.X.
and the P.E.X. admin was all of the all of the other people who
are already underbicious. Thank you for your idea.
Yeah. That I've been using Trello.
We did all of the stuff that he's pointing at.
They were the ones that- In the transmittals, there are those who did verify
that they were the ones that took the drive and talked to me and
the system. They filled out all the stuff they were- was that pulled out
the trigger from the neck and said, okay, I got this check now.
I got this check now. I got check now. I I got that company.
I'm meeting guys for two weeks now. The system.
Uh, 10.
Today I feel that's really good.
All the brother getting ears and all the rest.
And project managers, they are all on it.
They all do, all that stuff, but in this city.
It's ready to be here. Yeah,
and, uh, go. I'm not trying to help, but I got,
uh, I have some, uh, uh, I have some videos on it.
If anybody has, It's pretty odd. 30% has,
uh, I've seen it work. Okay? And then,
this honestly is an un-tobbing Atlassian.
. . Well, it be a beef…eat my house would be. But the… it
wasn't that hard. Like,
you were talking about it wasn't I'm looking in there.
Man heads off so much. We also have the first thing I could use
again. We have the truth. You have a week of four or five times
managers, five or six other engineers.
Cheers. All those people are using it all,
and then the estimators looks like three or four engineers used to get it
as well. I'm about to eat me when you see I
don't know, but 300 shows me. They do a lot.
It's not, you know, 60 million. . . . . a year plus.
They're, when I left them a year and a half ago with MediRoute,
they were trying to get to a hundred and a year.
This is a tradeover market for three years,
and it's just pretty awesome right in here.
But in my power, it goes about two feet in front of me and
I have to give a mark,
but I really don't want to eat cookies for a little bit.
you I'm gonna say, I began to miss them when they told me how
I visited. They were in mind for a little bit this morning when they
talked to them. Since I knew how to text them,
since I've added it, then I've been following the key,
and I have been following it. Everything made me move up.
... ...and there hasn't been a lesson made in a few years,
and most of it became a lot of the time in the investment.
So, Okay. And now they're trying to push more things,
but it has been a, I didn't say greater than I'm sure.
Yeah. Done. This company and the other one,
it's their main news. That's tech,
uhm, their role is that they've got that.
Good. So this call came from a little girl,
they want to be a technical or it came from us and we pushed
them to that. They saw what we had, they saw. Bye. Bye-bye,
bye-bye. Oh, okay.
And I still feel it from the top. Perhaps you guys are ready.
We'll see later. Bye. I know it, I actually think so.
I've seen it.
Okay. Yeah. What should you do for the phone,
you can be the manager. Enjoy. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Certainly I can be expected, right? I think I'm going to be better,
uhm, uhm, uhm, Just go to the car.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, absolutely.
That's the truth. Nick, you got it on some of these other systems.
Let's go. I mean, it seems like you're double,
at least double working. Yeah, uhm,
that's right. I think so, to do the,
uhm, a reporter, everybody. I'm ready. So,
after the reporter, uhm,
after the release,
and so, Receiving is,
that's, we're working on getting that done out there.
So, uhm,
The, uhm,
NTRs in London, New York, should be shipping where you're seeing this,
should be where you're seeing this. I'm little bit of this. Uh, well, of
course, I thought so.
Yes, sir. Alright, you're gonna have IPAs to be out.
I've got them in the apartment. the board. Um. Okay.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. And uh,
so you can let me just go and sit back. If please subscribe.
Do like, I just think it's how we see it in there.
And it's right last day I'll be inside a moment of the jerks here
in a week. Let's say I'm making a piece of that in patience.
You know, I can get one in the rest of the package.
I'm like, yeah, yeah, I'm all going to try to get a job to
build it with. Can you show? Okay.
I think we're basically just being needed for it.
So this question was if he needed to build up a job.
Go. We're all looking at Kiara's plan for it.
Peace again. Something today. Anything you want?
Alright, do it. I'm showing you this is a golf ball.
We're a job that's where we've got three clinics and we're getting a new
job. So they're starting to,
where we were and we just. . . . Congress under,
because you have to know all the purchase orders and then you can pull
the purchase orders in one by one. Yeah. It's horrible.
Look at that. Too revealing to have this to the fans,
yeah. Thank you.
Hey, members, appreciate it.
Man, that is sweet. There's a very few without one.
I can't tell you that, you know,
I had to know. I can't the box to the connection
and it's so cool.
I got it. One of these that has a multiple.
This one probably has the conumbers for almost five minutes.
That's welcome. He's not sure how to get here.
So they do well. I wish you a little bit. That's good.
That's So they did just study documents that bothered us and all that to
the folder. Yeah. Thank you. Study documents,
and then you can also get a report that gives you a piece mark
by he can remember that. Bye. Bye.
And you gotta go and have to do any,
hmmm, hmmm, hmmm, hmmm,
hmmm. Uh, I'm only gonna have to keep us in the center but,
You think that they ask you how they could be all over.
You gotta say, he should read you all this.
And you can play it all over. Yeah, there we go.
I'm going to stay in the, the childhood cause.
Oh, that's a really stable, and that's how it involves that.
Yeah, yeah. When you, I don't know the game whether,
You gotta save it somewhere. So, I think that's kind of the direction on
the video. to help.
We want this project to go to the front,
should be received, received. You would pay the fee in the NTR.
you are. All the money you have made, I don't understand why we have
it, because it's not in addition, it's bottom. Yeah,
and care. But if you think that's where you just got- You know,
all but they're literally saved. In here,
at least if you have it. Yes. Yeah.
So- The reason we had MCR Folders is because,
as ASME shot, we had a certain amount of step ahead of me to
view it. We went- I'm putting this to the MCR Folders until I see
the view they'll file. The uh,
the thing about it, if you- just go back to follow or to pull
everything, that takes away your ability to be able to stop
and and then reset the machine. So.
Like, you know, the one we bought from the jobs on the bottom of
the sack of Keenan, I'm not going to get that out.
I'm going to go up top. Going. phone. Machine,
then I'm stalking the machine.
And then it's going to record the problem of the year.
But it won't be about over the right moment,
right? So it doesn't start. But, yeah. See ya.
That's cool, but it's awesome.
It does. Umm, so there you go. Okay.
8 8 8 8 9 8 Okay.
Umm, the, umm, the everything,
yes, and that, you know. you I'm getting the,
uhh, time tracking meaning all the,
uhh, things are changing here. I believe they're producing the time.
. . . . tracking through Techbud.
. . . . . . . . . Ok. Speak about that.
Ah, a uhh.. Yeah, Yeah,
I really didn't It's been two years or so now.
So if you're . . . so wait a minute, let ask you names
later. Or now .
. . you know, you've known it in a time check. You know .
. .
it's so much there. See you later. I really am,
man. Especially in this segment. Yeah.
Yeah. You
want a couple, but you don't have to be much in.
It's sense, yum. It's okay. You it's
ready. you
So I'm going to give her all of our
time and issues to work with. Okay, I'm going to do that.
That's really good. I guess I have that. So.
Let's give them a day on them, please.
And then the job, they're the mandatory stretches they have to do in the
morning. They're safety. That's better than it is,
that's like th-th-th-th-th-th-th-th
So, no worries. I've never seen that in shock.
I've never seen that in the field. You know, it's- it's- it's- it's- it's-
it's- it's- it's- it's- it's- it's- it's- it's- it's- is this a five-minute
thing or something? 10 hours, 30 solid, yeah,
that's all the discussions. Thank much for your attention.
Come into the shop and blast the chutes and test it.
Oh, you need to get this. Yeah, I'm gonna do a play all over
there, uhm, uhm,
uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, . . . .
. Plfued of Okey,chidison,
J.S.A. Okay, child safety.
Thank you guys. See you in the show.
Okay. He's probably testin' on J.S.A.
and fell down towards to the, I said, the man's in J.S.A.
is done in the shop. And what are you A.S.A.
is significant. Huh.
So. It's almost as good for me. That was good.
I didn't say it was bad. Yeah. I haven't seen you before,
but I'm just saying it. I'm saying you can't say it.
Ah, good. Just. Yes.
Because people in mind that we were going to talk about Sourcet on the
stations, it will be an addition to this.
Yeah. Yeah. So it's that time though.
Sourcetree and TJ will be over this every day and check their face scan
in and against what they have. you It's a 30 minute scope.
And 12, 12, I'll interrupt. It's not over yet. Okay. It's not correct.
Okay. It's not correct. Okay.
Okay. Oh,
I think it is a good job. Okay. Okay.
Okay. It pulls launch out of here. I'm gonna kill ya. Thank Now,
I know that, uh, Ted is following through on this talk.
Thank you. We'll be right back in August.
the here at the channel for, um,
7th and 8th or, uh, another day.
F*** with F*** with it.
What you change about, that I'm trying to hear me change.
Um,
well, one that missed the integration, you know. I was being able to settle
this, the engineer, and the hours, you know. I just got a little bit
of air clover. Um,
the other thing would be. You get it, it's, it's.
And I guess I'd be using it in your business,
at shops, most of them. . Umm, here, uhh,
in your job, and hop on your own,
and then clocking in and out of it physically.
Umm. . . And this one,
in an EPN go, can be a pain in the ass when you're typing
things in that is not adding notes to it sucks.
But I'll say that. So,
that would be the main thing. Bye.
Umm, I'll be done on that chart by telling you in this fashion.
So, don't worry, I'll put my back,
and I'm sure a few better than this. I don't have for us to
say like that. Um,
I don't have any. Well, as you can see though,
it's just a good disparity. iggle. to to 4 cumbersome for a guy against
jumping in this way with jobs,
3rd leg jumping in this way, 3rd leg jumping 3rd leg jumping in this
way. Stations are going from,
you know, fair up to a lot of it. I was going to give
a little bit of it to the tablet, don't you know. And I think
this brings a lot of intent down. A lot of the shops are going
to be new stations. There's a computer over there.
I'm going to get out of my breakfast. I'm going to show my breakfast.
Thank friends. All right. I've been, it's not safe. I've got to go over,
I got to go walking, and then I got to enter my stuff,
enter my job, clocking, clocking, clocking.
Oh, my God. I'm on a podcast in the next job, and I go
back, and I'm in a safe station, and I got my materials,
and I get back for this.
this. I was having a great year growing up into the goal I put
in here, along with this shop. We'll, we'll grow this next file to steal
and recommend this job. No. No. So,
next, I'm going to do a great, uh,
video of a swap job, so it is, uh,
because there's that style, e.n, e.n, e.n, e n,
e, n, e, n, e, n, e, n, n, e, e,
e, n, e, n, e, n, e, n, e, n, e, n, e, e,
n, n, e, n, n, n, n, e, n, e, n, n, e,
n, e, n, e, n, e, n, e, n, e, n, e, n, n,
e, e, n, e, n, e, e, n, e, n, e, n, n, n,
e, n, n, n, n, e, e, e, n,
e, n, e, n, n, e, n, e, n, e, e, e, e,
n, n,
n, n, Series to think about regardless of the we're perpetuating
the interface for. What was the best one you'd see?
Thank you. Umm,
I don't get into a lot of people's time talks about their reason.
What I used to be using is about time. Plus,
hey, hey. I came home pretty well. I just couldn't get a bit of
a neat one on that. So I could, I could give you a job
and see what's in this, as well.
So, uh, so I'm going to, I have a good input on
what's the best thing out there.
. . I didn't vote on R's change to where,
excuse me, you can walk up, you know,
whatever you did last, come right back up.
Yeah. And the new system, you had to do it at a time.
It was a great experience. Yeah. You might be,
some guys don't talk, it's for you. Yeah. But,
yeah, I don't know. I really don't think about that in my game.
I'm living in the face of, uh,
this and about what they're going to do.
Um, you know. Good,
thanks. So,
yeah. So, what it does, what it does, what uh,
it just, uh, almost needs to set up all the things that are,
or what it does to this. So, automatically it will let you have to
do it. Like, automatically,
the integration here goes P-A-P-R-C-N.
. . That's it! But David jaron,ied as Lisa Sarone,
next 4 favourite videos is-A-N-E-L.
we have to get in the right form after this and then get in
head. That is the right thing. So,
how is that today? I don't know,
I don't know what to do with Lisa, but I don't know what to
Lisa, but don't know what to do with a minute,
and it's almost a week. So, it will begin when you take it back
or time. Bye-bye. Now I'm going to start with you.
It's a side pass for somebody else beneath the end.
They're ready to go. So,
thank you. Nah, nah,
I think I'm myself. No.
Yeah, that's pretty much,
. Prior to process, uh, on the passive soldier with one spot,
I don't know. And then,
er, yeah, I would be, very useful,
but I have more members who give this,
uh, understand this, and have it suited.
Uh, uh, All right. I'm gonna my machines,
I can have it in 2 or 3 and D. I'm gonna help me
set it. Yeah, that's the plan. I'm welcome.
Oh, good. I don't know about this, but,
you know, not all surveys and time studies,
I guess I learned to sweep that,
that's my job. It's time. . . So, uh, um,
I think about the, uh. . well. .
. so these, eh. out
of the system, you see. This is the last channel.
Still, yup,
none. I'm going to do that. We've already got it just to do.
Thank you, thank all C.I. and even responsible for all of that.
Yeah. We're having a while.
We're going to get it sometimes than this. We're having to change the spelling.
We're having to do this.
We'll be changing the spelling. We'll be pushing against that.
We're having if you can change it for that size.
Uh, yeah, we don't even have to have a C8 by 11.5.
I have to get crazy. Great. I see it in this thing,
but that's it. So, uh, uhm,
it's never, uhm, pushed into the room or anything you just decided it is.
So. So, And that's, that's something that I don't believe you
should accept that. So, yeah,
okay, I'm ready. I'm sorry. Last point, did it mark me?
It's something that I don't like. Yeah,
I didn't think you were looking at it just a minute. That's it.
That's it. We'll see you Happy Tuesday. So they're all right. I think this
should be pretty annoying at the moment. In the normal text.
Yeah, they're all right. So, I'll wait a minute.
No. Yeah, I get it. Thank you. Any quarters of the shot,
six, four, and a one, you take it to my start 10,
17, I'm so I'm gonna get it really out.
I love you. I haven't,
I think he has, umm, a hundred, yes, so he's gonna pay hard one.
I'm gonna get that. So that sounds good.
I'm not gonna miss him, Josh. Sometimes that's a challenge.
Man. And so he goes, me and Biddings live,
so he won't be hurt. . . We were picking up live for a
while. . . No, no, no,
no. It's, uhh, in each song.
Let's take a look. Okay.
Oh, yeah, and then, as you guys are doing,
very,I mean, what, slime, chris, go, over again.
Storyaran. Like,
it's, to me,
it's one of the biggest issues, you've It's since the curiousness. . People of
serious communication from the series.
You put the data in question, you know, that's what happened,
so I can follow you and figure out what's happened.
And that chick in the middle of the night.
I think it's like we're not even supposed to be working.
It's a communication. Nation.
Don't let everybody have to get a lot of time to call them.
You could, and I'm going to show you that.
We're doing the workout back now. I'm to show you guys next to this.
I know we have a video, we have a video,
we we have a we have have a video,
we have a video, an example of a pitch tail, or we know if
we find it, one dot there. And ask you screen tomorrow and send out
the video, the production, you know, also, uh,
here And if he would,
if he wouldn't get involved in all the time by the project,
then he'd be like, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey. I'm gonna do this. I really,
I'm gonna do this. I'm gonna do this.
Let's go,
go. If they will not mention this,
then I will hear what it gets. They call.
You should have won. I can do it. Let me take off all this
stuff. I mean, that will be hard.
We'll do it in a bit.
How much you don't need so much. How's it going to be this long?
Good morning. You know, why are you so many kids?
I don't know. I just, I don't know. I I don't know.
I've heard really good. What do we think? I have generally, it's like a
different thing. Take me. In fact, you should be able to do this.
Exactly. I'm a fan of music,
and I'm supposed to let you use the product in it.
I'm gonna make sure- Thanks to you,
Mark. If I just want to let you put it on in the bed.
Yeah, I can't plan so many interpretations. I'm looking to- Thank you.
Umm, and it's a point where it's safe,
you know, different, you know, like, oh, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, that's it. Thank you. Especially in the really long name.
Hey. . It's one of eight hundred bucks. Just one car in the diaspora.
Me, Tim's, is all good here. It's all these three here.
I have 12 minutes. I take myjo Woo-hoo. It's stuff. I think this marriage
is a problem. It's like, yeah, it's a toy.
It's a chain that doesn't make me know inside. But if it has a
shock, it's gonna make a lot of place for my kids. Make to subscribe
to our kids. I don't even know what to do just get.
I know you're gonna get the wrong kids, but I can't get wrong kids,
couldn't you? So I'm a bit fat that's kids too much.
I'm gonna get scared. Alright, let's take a look at that. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Alright. Hey, okay. So 7, 8, 8, 3, 4, 5,
2, 1, 2, Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Thank sir. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
We're going to have a little bit of a touch of the work on
the English research science that we have there. I wish I could still.
Oh, jeez, if I don't want it there or, uh, it's like,
yeah, I can't believe it was falling out of the zone.
It's a really nice to be thinking about it. The program that we're going
to think are the people I'm hanging with.
He has. I agree with him.
There's something a little back in Jason.
Please. Please look against the daytime and set up to show you how to
hear it. The rest of the world will return to the time all around.
It's gonna check whether it's a monostemal- No,
that's what it's going it's going to be fine.
So, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm,
uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm. So,
uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm. Thank you.